Hello
everybody!
Hello, hello!
As you guys can see, I am alone right now, and we'll be
soloing, streaming today.
The collab has been postponed to, I don't know, I don't know
yet.
It depends on everybody's schedule.
But it has been postponed because Snuffy's internet is not
doing so well today.
Apparently she has been having internet troubles lately.
in and out and uh lily also just finished her big league
tournament and she was ep so i was just like why don't we
postpone we should push postpone like we shouldn't force
anything so uh so it's gonna be uh rescheduled so yep today
we're just we're gonna be playing fortnite yay uh pia and i
we were thinking about maybe doing a 101 collab instead but
i was like i'm tired i straight up i was like if i have
enough energy for a one-to-one collab right now i i was like
uh i felt really bad because i was like i woke up early um i
woke up early today well i woke early in my definition is
like 11 or like 12 p.m it was and like i hadn't like and i
had energy for a group collab but like for one-to-one i had
to be like and i didn't take a nap at all today i was like i
didn't take a nap at all so i don't have another energy i
don't have a lot of energy for a one-to-one collab because
one-to-one dynamic is different from a group dynamic so i
was just like oh i don't think i have the energy i feel bad
because i was just like i was just worried that i wouldn't
be able to do a good back and forth with pia just because
like uh just because like i wasn't mentally ready for a
one-to-one collab you know yeah not like i i usually when i
have a collab was like it depends on what collab is for i
right now i'm mentally prepared for a group collab but i'm
not mentally prepared for like a one-to-one collab because
that's more there's more like dynamics and like uh back and
forth than it is in a group collab so i my brain's not ready
for it at the moment yeah and it is when we are streaming a
lot later than my usual hours too so you know like i'm at 5
p.m now it's 8 so like usually that was when my body's like
is like relaxed like where either i'm already marathoning
already at like the halfway point of a stream or uh or like
i'm about to end the stream so uh so i was like next time i
was like next time i just gotta be mentally prepared for
like a one-to-one collab if it was it was around 5 p.m.
and then like we decide to reschedule at 5 then it'll be
fine i'll be fine to do a like do a one-to-one collab like
um with the remaining people so it was just me and p.m that
were free today um but it's 8 p.m and it's 8 p.m and my my
energy level is not ready for a collab like not ready for a
one-to-one collab at the moment and i think it was super
chat thank you thank you he's off the grid that's all i'll
say uh he's currently living his life and he is enjoying
life right now.
Yeah.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's more because like solo, I just talk to myself.
It's easier.
Okay.
I'm trying to wait.
No.
Okay.
Why?
Why won't he played fortnight overwatch with us so basically
uh okay wait give us five tell him to give us three reasons
why he won't play okay so for those who are wondering um i'm
trying to i would try to get the squad back with me gully
sure for and ben to play fortnight because i was Bro,
Overwatch Update.
But for those who don't know, Sure4 is like, I'll never play
Overwatch again.
But we're like, okay, but there's a Overwatch Update in
Fortnite though.
And we were like, come on, Sure4.
There's an Overwatch Update in Fortnite.
Yeah, but it's four people though.
It's four people.
And we were like, come on, Sure4.
A-stream, it was for like another stream because I was like
talking to Gully about it because I was like, oh my god, we
should bring back the squad.
We should bring back the squad because Overwatch is back on
Fortnite and Gully was trying to convince Shure for it.
And this was his response.
Let me show you guys the response.
It was not for today.
It was for like a future stream because for those who don't
remember usually we were every, not every update, but
there's a good update uh if it's a good update um all four
of us will play together for it so usually i won't be
streaming that i you would see on short for a stream it will
like gully ben and i wouldn't be streaming i just hop on off
stream with them um but there's a famous clip with the ice
spice where we died to ice spice and then also the simpsons
clip too um let me see does any oh let me see if i could
find it let me find the let me find the clip oh yeah but
this was the this was his response to us trying to convince
him i'm gonna see if i can find the ice spice that's like
one of my favorite clips of all time one of my favorite
clips let me see i could oh my god wait let me see ice spice
wait I don't even I don't know I someone has to like link it
I don't have it right off the bat he hates us he's always
like he is a freaking hater with poison in his heart he
hates us what did we do to him not a homie
get him to play overwatch again not even a fortnight update
um other than that um uh but but what else oh oh yeah i can
do the announcement today because you guys will find out
anyway when the when the game releases in 9 10 11 12 and 4
hour i believe it's 4 hours let me double check uh but
members already got this exclusive uh announcement so you
guys know how it said there was an announcement can
technically give you guys the announcement early right now
let me let me double check okay just says it's leaving early
out okay so for those who don't know why the member goons
there was there is or currently still is a special
announcement for tomorrow but I can give the announcement
early right now so uh if you guys oh my gosh maybe i should
not just tell you maybe i should show you but if you guys
read the community post i did say uh there was a hint um on
what it could be and you might be able to hear that hint on
what the announcement could be and there was a dragoon um
that said that was like oh i think i know what it is i don't
know if he made the if he guessed it correctly if you solve
the arg um but let me find my media upload so i can actually
show you guys and not bait you guys even more oh my gosh
where is it where is the video upload part where is okay
media media source all right here we go but is it this one
this is just an announcement We use a hand here.
Working hard.
These chickens.
Keep that musketeer away from my little guys.
What's up?
Well, he's there.
No problem.
Sweet gritches.
Wait, which came first?
How did I get here?
Trachor?
Oh-ha!
Gold Gold Adventure Gold 1.0 available May 15th.
Harvest him.
Use a hand.
So yeah!
Yeah!
I'm gonna be in a video game.
Woo!
For those who don't know, I did a sponsor with Gold Gold
Adventure Gold, I guess like a year ago.
Oh my gosh, it can't believe it's been a year ago.
And right after they asked him, I was interested.
in voice acting one of their characters for their full
release and um and also you guys are in it too for those who
don't know you guys are actually in i requested for uh
dragoons to also be a part of the game so it is my very
first real serious voice acting gig um i was very nervous um
i was i i was like i don't know i really mean like it so um
so yes i am the farmer girl in gold gold adventure gold and
it will be on the full release of the game which is tomorrow
so that's why we are playing the game tomorrow because we're
gonna get a lot of farmers on our in our town um but yes i
was very nervous because i was basically it was like dokey
bird as a dokey bird so i'm sorry to members but basically
sort of pulled a Chris Pratt where I was just like I this is
one thing I would have changed I wish I did differently or I
wish I did put a more of a character voice like maybe pitch
it a little higher or something and I was just like oh no
what if it's just like a Chris Pratt situation it's a me
dokeybird where I just sound like dokeybird so I hope you
guys like the voice acting for it because I was very nervous
because like I say like I said before I don't think of
myself as much of a voice know how to do a lot of voices um
i usually just sound like me so also the long goons didn't
make it in i'm sorry we found out in the members because i
thought it was just a chonky goon but apparently everyone
got invited except for the long goons so so there is a when
you play the farmer girl there is a gotcha rate where the
chickens can spawn in as Three of the Dragoon types.
So they can spawn in as either a Dragoon, a regular Goon, an
Egg Goon, or a Chonk Goon.
I'm so sorry, Long Goons.
You guys didn't get invited to the party.
I'm so sorry.
They forgot your invoice.
But I'm so sorry, guys.
I was talking in the membership.
I was like, because I'm like, I was like, I've been binge
watching Malcolm in the middle.
the last two months, like I'm on the final season right now.
And I was saying how like the long goons is basically Dewey
and Malcolm in the middle.
Like he just, he just gets left out, but compared to all the
other siblings.
It's like, and it sounds like, and then one of the long
goons in the member stream was like, even a goon gets
invited.
And I'm like, I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry, I guess he's like, even a goon and not me.
so uh but yes i'm so excited uh for you guys to check out my
very first um official uh voice acting debut um in a game
that's on steam well technically you can get the game right
now uh but the official release with the farmer girl is
gonna be um is gonna be out tomorrow and we're gonna be
playing that game tomorrow um and yeah uh oh yeah when i
said by the way okay when i was saying like there was a hint
as to what the announcement could be if you look at the
twitter and uh on their trailer that was released a month
ago in the trailer uh there was there was uh audio snippets
of my laugh in the trailer like there were three segments in
the trailer where you could hear my voice and that was like
if anyone caught that on um it has it was in the trailer for
at least a month but nobody noticed no yeah nobody noticed
it was me yeah it was actually me as the farmer girl yeah
and then um their funny story was basically when I was voice
acting as uh the farmer when they gave me the script in the
script they were like being they were saying like can you do
a southern accent for her and I straight up was like no I
would be like, I can't do accent.
I'm so sorry.
I would love to be able to do a southern accent, but I
cannot do accent.
At best, I can be like, howdy y'all.
I just, I can't, I couldn't do a southern accent.
I tried.
I was like, I didn't even like, I don't even know how to
twist my tongue to be able to do that southern accent.
So it's basically Doki Bird has Doki Bird.
It's me, Doki Bird.
But yes, that was the big announcement.
Before we play Fortnite, Overwatch Fortnite, I do want to
say thank you guys again for the huge support.
It wasn't for you guys.
I'm going to be able to do stuff like this, be able to be
part of such cool projects and you know i got you guys in
the game too well all almost all of you guys i mean three
out of four not too bad three out of four uh we now need a
foghorn wighorn tokey bird they're even a super chat thank
you thank you hashtag not me though i'm not in it everyone
but you so um i'm glad that we were able to get um almost
everybody in the game i mean dad's not in the game guys come
on we didn't get dad in here the civil war continues so um
but yes to get like i said it's a gotcha rate to pull the
dragoons.
I think it was like a 50-50.
It was like a, it was like 40, it was like 20 to 50%
depending on the dragoon types.
So it's gonna be really exciting.
I can't wait to see what all the updates and the changes
they made for the full release, because the last time I
played this game was, you know, the last time I was
sponsored to play this game.
I'm not sponsored to play this game for tomorrow.
I'm only, I'm playing it because I'm in the game.
So technically, it's not sponsored.
I only got paid for the voice acting.
Oh, thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Instead of a prison, I got my own pen.
Wow, what an upgrade.
But seriously, congrats, Doki.
I knew my cameo.
Oh, she can do it.
Thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
But yes, like I said, thank you guys again for all your
support and let me, and for helping me get such an amazing
opportunity and cheering me on and helping me build myself
up to take do these crazy things i never expect myself to do
um and it's been a wild adventure i can't believe i'm uh
i've voice acted in the game it's crazy to think about and
and it seems to have very positive reviews that's the best
part uh hope it doesn't change tomorrow and i get to voice
act in game with very positive mostly positive reviews too
so yay it's the little things you know all right all right
now okay all right now now we play fortnite long run rest in
peace congrats to kiana roll thank you thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i can't wait i can't wait to
check it out tomorrow they're gonna be tweeting about the
announcement later because i was like debating if uh i
should tweet out the announcement or let them tweet it i
remember they tweeted on that quote retweeted
let's see all right fortnite fortnite time where's the
fortnite how do i fortnite if it doesn't show oh there you
go fortnite i'll go sound sound guy i forgot to uh oh it's
called gold gold adventure gold sound guy forgot to uh do
the sound balance i don't i never saved the sound settings
for fortnite so i'm gonna need your help oh my god oh my
okay is that oh i thought that was widow maker no more mr
ice guy the rock wait what is he i forgot he's in here
rivalry started
Oh, he's back?
But he can never lose.
That's in his contract, though.
Oh, you can't die from fall damage anymore.
Good.
Gravity had it too good for too long.
Oh, you see an enemy team in the map?
Are you showing us an ad?
No, I just want to play Overwatch and Fortnite.
You can, they brought Mercy's staff.
Her staff is there.
You can't rest, but you can damage boost and heal.
So you can be someone's heal slut.
That's my pocket Mercy.
You can be someone's pocket Mercy.
Cool.
Wait.
Oh, you can rest too.
Oh, my God.
all it's all they're all it's all coming together done all
right let's check out the shop by the way guys you guys
didn't know i have a fortnite code you go over here support
a creator um and then press dokey bird and then apply and
then look at that apparently this is cheaper than one
overwatch skin like in the actual game yeah you could have
you could have a pocket healer in fortnite so it's crazy
that this is cheaper than one overwatch skin like an actual
skin in the game all right get me in here give me that
overwatch skin oh my god even overwatch legos yeah it is um
Look at the tiny Genji Lego.
This is like around the price for one skin.
For one Overwatch skin.
Alright, what else do they have?
Alright, I bought the Overwatch stuff.
Oh my god, the little diva.
The little tiny diva backpack.
The little diva mecha.
That's crazy.
No.
No win.
Unfortunately, there's no Winston.
Oh my god, Ed is going to heaven.
Okay, wait.
Actually, give me a sec.
I gotta change it.
Alright, where is...
Oh yeah, I've got...
I got Mordecai too.
And I got Jake.
I had to buy Jake.
Okay, where is he?
Wait, where is my...
Okay, there they are.
Okay, I think this one was...
Oh yeah, by the way, for those who didn't know...
They brought her back.
They saw the Marvel Rivals competition with the Gooners
skin.
They had to up their game.
They had its back, guys.
They might have taken her away from us.
Five plus years ago.
But she's back.
All right, what's this?
We're so back.
See, what else do they have?
Come on, let me see from the other side.
Oh, no, I already have that.
Oh my, oh, Kylo Ren is in the store.
Oh, wait!
Keanu Reeves!
Alright, what's this?
Her back is back.
I'm as poopy, but what?
What kind of lyric is that?
Okay, but if we're gonna...
If we're gonna watch this, it has to be on Genji.
Look at him go.
look at him emote before he begs for heels what's this
oh is that ice spice okay that makes a lot more sense uh no
it's getting to you with the converse wait not converse oh
wait with the nike or is that adidas i can't tell they had
so many shoes with the air jordans the cracks oh
my god wait the stance is perfect oh
it's this look at me hey hey
no it's casual genji it's because they don't want him to be
naked guys guys he has to Put clothes on.
You can't just be naked walking around.
Oh my god, wait.
That's the cyberpunk skin, right?
What was this phrasing in?
Wake up, samurai.
Show me the Genji butt.
Oh my god, wait.
There's a stormtrooper.
Wait, a dark side.
Yeah, wake the fuck up, samurai.
Why am I asking for water?
This is a shitty e-mode.
I'm going to...
This even fucking sucks.
What the fuck is this?
They're like, please pass me the water.
Oh, wait.
Is that the flyer?
Oh my god.
Wait, I can have a tie fighter as a glider.
Wake up.
Wake the fuck up, Samuels.
We got it.
We got it dropped.
What's this?
Do I have dab?
Wait, I need to buy this.
do not have the dab i can have genji dabbing
guys i can have genji dabbing oh my god that actually fits
genji so well wake the fuck up dokey bird we gotta stream to
start oh that's cute okay more air jordans okay i don't know
oh my god wait lois fina
because it's Mother's Day.
I don't care much about Lois, though.
I'll have to admit.
It's like 2016.
I knew you used to enjoy it.
But we're buying that.
and the other.
I already have Anna put respect to Lois's name.
Oh yeah, and there's Linda.
There's Linda and there's Peggy.
There's Save the Bird.
Oh wait, it's the polka dot Bunkini.
Oh my god.
Genshi could wear the little... Wait, I want to try it on.
Try it on.
Okay, that doesn't work so well.
I might buy Linda though not Lois I might buy Linda but I'll
think about time to think about this one Oh they're the
tiniest violin oh my god this is back This would this fits
Genji so much He's stomping on the hams Anymore Let's see I
think that's everything Oh wait oh it was bugs bunny is on
the battle pass I forgot about that Alright let's check it
out oh level 85 no fuck that all right let's go wait i'm
gully oh wait what is he doing what is gully doing did he do
it oh my god what is where is he oh i joined i joined rock's
team
get him just randomly i thought did he convince him i'm
sorry i'm leaving he didn't convince him get out of here all
right just pick a side i picked the side that has the rock
you can't lose guys just remember that you can't lose all
right okay
잔 nana nana nana nana nana nana nana nana ea makadina hot Go
Genji go look at him Gannam style Okay, by the way lemme
know if the Gannam style oh oh oh All right, and then he
gets Snoop Dogg too Look at Genji go And it's my favorite
with a Genji.
I'm out for Christmas.
There is no something why no he'd Oh, up he's?
Alright, no worries.
It's Missy.
Mercy won't be able to ignore these moves now.
She's got a heal now.
She can't ignore him forever.
What other emotes do I have?
Oh yeah, this one.
Alright, wait.
I need to know what other emotes I have.
I have so many emotes now.
I didn't buy... I didn't buy...
I forgot to buy the VTuber emotes.
I do have the naruto run this fits him though oh my god he
can finally naruto run finally he what he was meant to do oh
my god default fortnite dance move i need healing mercy
please i need healing mercy He's finally a ninja.
Oh, this.
What animals do I have?
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Look at him, Deb.
Oh, and then the Jake Bug.
Let him go.
Go, Bug, go!
Dance your heart out!
What is this?
Oh, it's the...
The SpongeBob dance.
oh
i wish i had more kpop dances
They're like, Genji, please, we need you to save Overwatch.
We need you back in Overwatch.
Where is he?
Unhouded.
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
Genji, where is he?
Please, we gotta fight Talon.
Oh, and then we have...
The well, the way around.
Save us.
and it's my favorite part whenever i get a new skin i can
make all my dreams come true
oh yeah there's apparently the arcade moon where where uh
they brought back mercy original res in no limits apparently
so like people were just playing mercy and be like die on
point just like the good old days die on point at half rest
so new Overwatch update I wish there were more sexy dances
for him I don't have enough sexy dances on Fortnite heroes
never die I'm so sad I don't have enough sexy dances I guess
this all I have are funny dances I don't have the sexy
dances we're gonna do triple triple fill oh yeah I need to
adjust the settings too all right let's see uh because like
I reset in my is it still low oh yeah it's still high
New medium.
Oh, never mind.
There was a cool clip where I saw they're like how did I
describe it?
It was basically like transcending games.
Oh, it was such a cool clip.
Let me see if I can find it.
And then I bookmarked it.
Where he's like, I'm going to kill you in another game.
It was such a cool clip.
yeah bro oh there you go bro went to a different game to win
a fight that i was like damn that that that was that was a
sick edit i will say that edit was actually a fire yeah i
saw the neopets too i think it has to be like you know the
pet feature because i was like there's no way there's going
to be like a like a player skin for it because you know
unless they're doing like the medieval medieval skins
because usually they're all like you know they're a pet
that's a dog like you know
all right oh my god go straight in I didn't even have time
to like adjust anything um oh my god how do I play this
again um are they dropping I don't know they apparently
added Gibraltar too um Are they dropping?
Where are we dropping?
Tilt the towers?
Wait, there's no two.
Where are my teammates?
Why do none of you guys ping anything?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, I gotta turn down.
Oh, oh, there's so much lag.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Shedron saved me.
Shedron.
run save me i didn't have time to adjust any of my settings
oh my god this is bad i thought i would have time to adjust
i really did i thought i would have time
oh this is bad oh am i saved oh i should have just drank my
potion my My juice first.
Oh, I'm a mess right now.
I'm already a mess.
Did anyone else land here?
Okay, there is.
It's okay.
Oh, where are they?
Oh my gosh, SpongeBob, tell me where are they?
Hello, guys.
Can I borrow your stuff?
Don't worry.
Stink, too.
God oh my god there's the bloons monkey I forgot I forgot
the bloons guy was you dude look bloons and sponge balls
don't worry I'm on high ground
wait where is he I see footsteps what what where did he go
what he's over there where is he
Oh my god.
The ping!
Like, I'm just forever confused.
Oh, I'm fucking dead.
Okay, give me a sec.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
No, I didn't see him!
Sink!
Do something!
Okay, I can adjust my settings now.
I'm...
Okay, that's fine.
I can adjust my settings now.
Alright.
that's okay it was that loss was met guys it's because my
settings guys um i had to adjust my settings right there and
that's why we lost uh yeah sponge bob why didn't you help me
where were you sponge bob my background audio all sounds so
i can tab out and we can still jam out.
SpongeBob!
Let me get my auto.
Alright.
Turn a lot.
SpongeBob do something.
Yeah, guys.
Guys, I had to I had to adjust my settings, guys.
That's why it didn't go so well.
This is what happens when you take a shower before the game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Turn off the what thing?
The nanite thing.
What the fuck is the nanite?
I don't know what that even means.
Okay, motion blur.
Oh.
Yeah, the what?
The what thing?
The nanomachines?
Where are my fellow Overwatch gamers?
Hello?
Oh, wait.
there's bugs bunny though hello hey bugs let's go what's up
doc oh my god look at his kicks though man bugs bunny even
retirement bro you're dripping what the is that wait is that
billy eyelash
there's billy eyelash too oh my god look at it look at the
collab of the century
the collab of the century guys they're all here everybody's
here Philly who?
it's Philly Isleish
alright I need to be able to 6-7 somebody
alright Spongebob we gotta grab a gun
alright I'm gonna put that here just in case Oh I'm scared
Oh there's someone near me Oh I hear so many gunshots Okay I
got bullets
Oh I hear so many sound effects around me Oh I should need
that I'm gonna drink this first Doing the strat then boom
I'm not a team player don't worry watch this they'll never
know I'll blend right in in this building I'll blend right
in how
would they know I think they're trying to shoot me what the
fuck is going on over there on my team
my team better be real people i swear to god oh wait that's
fine my team will be okay i believe in my team to do this oh
nice see i told you guys i told you my team will be okay how
would they know i'm how would they know i'm here guys it's
full camo They'll never know, guys.
I'm fully camouflaged in my surroundings.
Surely this walking bush isn't a person, right?
If they know they're cheating, they're walling.
They're in-bottling.
Alright.
Just walking as straight as that.
There's no way you're real.
That's right.
Oh, you still walk.
Yeah, I was like, there's no way you're a real person.
I refuse to believe you're real.
Oh, fuck.
I have no more ammo.
I'm still gonna kill you.
You might have ammo.
I don't care.
You can keep rolling all you want.
I will dab.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck it.
Okay, okay.
I got stuck.
I dabbed too hard and got stuck.
everything is fine oh we shoot they might be real because
they have pets they have a little dog following him around
death by tab I forgot to equip the tab guys oh that's not
real oh oh wait they're fighting someone the worm coming
over I will be useful.
Rivalry now?
Oh my god, I won.
I did it by doing nothing at all.
I got my rivalry credits.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Oh, what the fuck is that gun?
What gun did I just use?
There's a gun.
right here what the fuck did i use there like i have a right
click like a right click nuke boom that's right dodge this
i'm ulting oh my god i'm no longer ulting no longer ulting
there we go i finished ulting It has limited range, yeah.
Like, I do need heals, though.
Okay, I'm going to grab this.
Okay, I don't want to actually use that, though.
Overdrive grenade.
Don't worry, guys.
The shrub will be useful.
I swear.
Boom!
That's right.
You can't run away forever.
Jesus Christ, the range sucks.
Oh, there's a...
Wait, there's a Rhine shield.
There's a Rhine shield.
Oh, my God.
There's it is.
The first person...
There's recoil.
Wait, how do I dash?
How do I dash with this?
There's recoil.
I'm in first person now.
Guys, does anyone know how to dash?
It's real now.
Cheers, love.
I'm overwatching now.
No, aim, right click is recall.
Oh my god.
Okay, no, it's not that.
Wait, can I beat this for slurm?
There we go.
Am I doing it?
I don't know.
Okay.
I'm blinking.
We just need the staff.
We found the... We found the Reinhardt shield.
We found the tracer.
Wait, do they have the sword too?
I wonder they have the sword as well.
Okay, maybe we don't need this.
No, the shrub.
is gonna come in clutch i swear guys
all right wait rivalries where i hit the zone
the shrub meta will come in clutch guys trust the process
wait they're not with me so i'm a little scared walking
there by myself
oh watch this
Rico!
Oh shit.
There we go.
Okay, this is a lot harder to aim than I expected.
We're doing it.
Oh, I could do like a mini dash thing.
It takes me a while to adjust to first person when I'm
playing fortnight you get a feeling of deja vu i do need
heels though i don't know how far i assume the range is like
at tracer range i think the charge is for recall i'm pretty
sure wait it's not did i bug it i might have bugged did i
bug the blinks
you think i bugged it or something thing?
Like, why is it not taking charge?
This is my first time with this gun, so I don't know.
Oh my god.
Am I infinite?
I have the bug gun.
I've searched this stuff.
I don't know what this is.
Where am I?
Where's Gibraltar?
I know there's a Gibraltar.
I'm already breaking the... Is this Yeah, I don't know, but
I'll take it.
Wait.
Oh.
They found something.
I thought they found somebody.
Okay, I should need this.
I need to drink this a little bit.
Oh, I should need another chug.
Okay.
No, it's not even taking my stamina.
Look.
I can technically blink forever.
Oh my god, I see that tracer.
Wait, I can actually...
I can blink forever.
I might die here though.
Oh shit,
that's the wrong guy.
Oh my god, is that dupin?
I got confused with the gun I was holding.
My bad.
All right, there we go.
I forgot what gun I was holding for a sec.
The third party.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm not supposed to have unlimited blinks.
It doesn't feel like that should have been in the game.
Oh, I do want to keep my shrubs, though.
The shrub.
I want to keep it.
Oh, he bit my SpongeBob.
I feel like the shotgun would be so good.
Oh, I can't.
We can't keep it.
No, we.
Oh my god, Overwatch, Gibraltar!
We're here.
Well, I can't believe Gibraltar had budget cuts.
I can't believe it.
It ain't the same.
I don't want to drive.
You drive.
It's what are you going to do?
Ban me?
Just...
Oh!
It's time.
Now we're overwatching.
Now, okay, I feel like I should get the shotgun, though.
There we go.
Now we're overwatching.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
I'll damage boost you.
I'll pocket you.
Go shoot your gun.
You're pocketed.
You're damage boosted.
Okay.
Wait, I can heal myself.
What the fuck?
I ain't healing stream in gate.
Okay.
Now Genshi can heal himself.
That's so true.
Don't worry, I got you guys.
I got you.
Genshi is now perfect.
It's so winnable.
Don't...
Don't keep playing support in Fortnite.
Oh shit, I should grab one of these actually.
Maybe I should grab one of the twenty hundred legendary
guns.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh no, don't worry, I can heal myself guys.
Do not worry.
Wait, what am I doing?
what am I doing I have unlimited blinks what the fuck am I
it must be like who what the fuck was that oh and I got help
my team out
Wait, where are they?
Where is he?
Oh, I accidentally recalled.
I did not mean to do that.
Oh my god, dad, please.
Got you.
Let me res you.
I have heals.
I'm not wasting a res on him.
There you go.
Don't worry, I got you!
I got you, bro!
I'll use my last remaining heals on you!
Alright, we're good, we're good.
We still have 15 more left.
Heroes never die!
Goodbye.
Time to go again.
Sayonara team!
What?
Okay.
Where is my teammates?
I'm a little worried.
I need to stick with my team.
I should not be zooming away.
I shouldn't be moving so fast the grass can't even load.
I was gonna say, I need to not zoom in too much though.
Oh my god!
I got mercy!
Don't worry, I can still use it to blink though!
It's just my movement.
I'm just going to use it for movement, guys.
Guys, I don't have...
Oh, no.
Guys, do not die in the storm.
Guys, do not die in the storm, guys.
I can't save you.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I have...
I'm going to save the 15.
It's okay.
it's okay guys we're so healthy if we stay here we're so
healthy i have the sick i just need him to get closer
okay it's gone now that was the last one all right there we
go i'm a team player i have movement and one gun that's all
we need oh oh wait they're fighting
Where are they fighting?
I don't see them.
I don't see them, though.
Okay.
I have an idea.
Oh, shit!
I guess I don't have an idea.
Oh my god, where is he?
Wait, he's healing himself!
That's illegal!
Where did he go?
We did it!
I don't think I'm supposed to have unlimited, but I don't
know how I glitched the tracer gun.
But I just...
I don't even know how I glitched it.
I just happened to have unlimited plinks.
I just flew away.
Victory Royale.
We take those.
guys we should all my team left me too many team too many
dashes nice easiest victory royale my life lord accurate
tracer all right wait oh give me a sec let me fix it all
right i out beat it i can't believe that worked all right we
gotta change one of them um what are we getting rid of all
right we're getting rid of that for the dab all right we got
the dab now too all right final gun himself this guy is back
lolly thank you super chat thank you thank you now genji can
heal his own damn self exactly that's how it should have
been oh yeah check graphic settings again yeah you're right
uh oh wait I should play it oh fuck I was gonna change
careful even in fortnight I managed to play support even in
fortnight oh my god there is tracer someone said turn off
the nanite or what oh this one oh I can't Okay, I'll change
it when I'm out of this game.
Oh my god, my teammates, the rock and tracer.
It's, it's, this is winnable.
Oh my god, there's a geck, isn't that gecko from that Pixar
movie?
There's no way we could lose.
All right, can you be even more up-ease?
All right, it's up-ease now.
Oh, yeah, let's jump off from the sea, guys.
All right, here we go.
Yeah, hoppers.
Isn't that the new Pixar slash Disney film?
Yeah.
Yippee.
Alright.
There seems to be a lot of people around me.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm a little scared.
I don't know how to loot this area.
I think I'll just loot further back, maybe?
I feel like I won't have people with me, though.
to help me.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, I'm ready.
Let's go.
Here we are.
Drink up, real quick.
Okay, let's see if I glitched it again or if it's gone.
Oh, that's what it's supposed to be like, guys.
That's what it was supposed to be.
What the fuck pizza?
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh my god, wait, I can't do that.
Wait, not right now.
What the fuck?
Why is everybody here?
Okay, wait, wait.
Tracer v.
Tracer.
There we go.
Tracer v.
Tracer.
And I'll heal myself.
I'm gonna heal myself.
There we go.
Okay.
I don't care if we lose because of it The Calvary is here
It's so It's so weird when you go from Third person to first
person Because I have to readjust my aim So I was like oh
shit Let me heal myself It's so awkward I don't know if
anyone else has Like when you have to readjust from First
person to third person.
And then readjust how you aim.
It's char.
It is so jarring.
I'm so, I'm like, fucked up from that.
How did I bug it?
I want to recreate.
I want the infinite blinks.
Give me back the infinite blinks.
It was So nice.
I was so used to spamming it.
I don't know how to replicate it, guys.
Whoa.
Oh.
Hello, yeah.
There you go.
Oh, my gosh.
It's invincible!
Not so invincible, are you?
They already nerfed me, guys.
I'm already nerfed.
Mark?
Alright.
Triple kill.
I might need more.
I definitely need more bullets.
No, no.
Tracer gun.
Oh my god.
The rock is now a healer.
He now plays support.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go for Overwatch.
Oh my god, it's title card.
Let's have her support on the roof.
Surely nobody will shoot him.
Oops, all healers.
He's emoting on the roof so cool.
I need more...
I don't...
I think the tracer gun, it's like...
It's not unlimited.
is it does it actually have oh wait does it have a specific
bullet for it i don't know oh it does it does okay i can
refill it
previous game you didn't grab any of the enemy chapter
killing maybe grab them this game i'll try i wish i know i
wish i know how to recreate that bug that was crazy i was
just like how am i doing i wish i knew what it looked like
for my teammates wonder what that shit looked like what guys
what the fuck oh goodbye car
oh no more bullets get out of here get out of here i need
more your bullets guys give me your tracer bullets all right
nice well actually i need oh i needed that though okay but
double Okay, no, it doesn't work like that.
But what if double?
We did it, guys.
The bots have been defeated.
Oh my god, I need to make sure not to do that.
I need to make sure not to use my blinks because it's not
unlimited.
It's not unlimited.
So I have to make sure I don't do it.
I'm so used to flying.
Like all the bots are marks for some reason why are they all
marks all
right i missed it too guys i missed being able to fly it
felt so good it really did coming over
oh we gotta kill bill
word i knew i believe in my teammates on killing him oh wait
was that a ttv or i killed wait a minute Did I just saw TTV?
Oh, that's embarrassing.
I just saw TTV.
No, it's not with mostly bot.
It's not because I played more than three matches.
That's right.
Dabbed on your TTV.
All right.
That guy can't be real.
Wait, he has...
He has a big chug jug.
Yeah, that one was a bot for sure.
That one was a bot, too.
Eventually, we're going to get punished soon, guys.
Just so you know, we're going to get punished for what we're
doing.
Okay, maybe if I swap.
No, it's still...
That's unlucky.
It's still the...
It's still the non-broken version of the gun.
Where are we?
Okay, I need to make sure there's no one.
Oh, there's somebody.
Okay, that was our guy.
Apex live!
There we go.
Nice.
I'm getting used to it.
I'm never punished.
Alright, this is fun, though.
Don't worry, I'll heal myself if only this was actually an
overwatch is this guy fat oh oh wait that might be a real
player wait what oh my god wait there's more than one i have
to be careful yeah i knew it it was more than one player it
was more than one oh my god I gotta be careful.
Oh my god, they're actually gaming now.
They're actually gaming now.
Guys, wait, where's my fucking team?
It fucking got went so fast.
Is he chasing after us?
Okay, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
They're third party.
Okay.
I might be able to pick him up.
I'm gonna go pick him up now.
Okay.
Gotta make sure to...
There you go.
Back to my...
Alright, I got him.
Alright.
Oh!
Look at me!
Movement!
Oh my god, I'm so good.
I'm so good at this.
Heroes never die!
Oh my god Maybe heroes do die
Maybe how does he think
Oh my god I should have to go Okay maybe heroes do die Oh my
god our guy left Our other tracer left
Guys here do die apparently yeah I might be if he comes here
there we go that's no good my tracer left me how could he do
I thought we were what happened to overwatch bro God people
change what happened to overwatch okay
Alright, it's alright.
If anything, SpongeBob will always have my back.
My guy, the guy is a coward right now, so I'll heal him.
There we go.
Alright.
See, these guys are real.
Now they're real people.
I see them.
They're, like, over there.
Now they're real.
We ain't joking around no more.
We ain't fucking around no more, guys.
now where does he want to go you not one more loot bro what
oh i see him i could fight i couldn't go over and kill him
is it one guy where is he ping him spongebob doesn't know
where he is
oh my god there he is okay i was like worried
all right well yeah i have four both 14 bullets on this so i
have to use this just for movement after
it should still be here
where did he go i see him just to be sure nobody oh oh it
got looted i'm gonna say
oh hey What the fuck is this?
Oh, I got the K.
Whatever the fuck that is.
Am I not in zone?
I need more tracer bullets.
I see him.
Oh.
Obaid him?
Well, he's in the sky now.
He's now in the sky.
Goodbye.
Where did he go?
Oh.
that's a full team he doesn't know wait where's my teammate
wait where's my oh wait my teammate's right below me isn't
he oh I mean sure I mean sure I'll take it let them fight
we're not pussies by the way we're just trying a third party
oh my god they have the respawn truck Dude, that's not fair.
It's so crazy not to have fall damage anymore.
God, I need ammo so badly.
There must be extra ammo.
Thank God.
Okay, we got ammo now.
I really needed that extra ammo.
I think everybody's gonna start fighting at it on us.
100%.
I feel like this area is too good to not fight for.
There's no way they'll see us.
I think with the blink, it makes this so that the fall
damage um doesn't like affect me as much oh there it goes oh
where are they coming oh my god oh my god
I thought I thought I thought I thought the little pet guy
pet guy who is
it disoriented in me.
He looked like the enemy.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, where are people?
Somebody's respawning.
Nobody cares.
Oh my god, all I hear.
Oh my god, there's missiles everywhere.
What the fuck, buddy?
Okay.
He just went off without me.
It just left without me, bro.
Bro, what the fuck?
I risked you, bro.
Oh, my God.
I actually don't know where to go.
Oh, this is where I die.
No!
Wait, we're safe!
That was the last team!
I wasn't counting.
You bet.
No!
Yeah, I got me Q done.
Get me out of here.
I didn't even realize this was the last team.
I was just followed.
You're not very difficult.
Fuck my teammate.
Get that side.
Fuck him.
He left me.
All right, let's turn this off.
Uh...
a tiny bit more volume all right let me turn this up and
then apparently this needed to be off all right i got you
bro i've upbeat a little bit more all right now now it's
time oh yeah apparently i saw someone on twitter talking
about it but even in fortnite mercy has the most skins she
is the only character she's the only one in fortnite that
has night no none of the other none of the other characters
have extra skins it's literally just mercy she's so greedy
how fucking course you're so greedy lord act she'll never be
satisfied her greed knows no bounds
feels like oh
agreed they talk about i'm surprised kierko didn't even make
it in honestly if anything it should if anything i'm
surprised they even added they didn't even add a fifth
character in wait why am i this is a trio lobby where's my
third person hello excuse me i signed up for trios not duos
I'm not going here nerf already.
Oh yeah, I won't be surprised to Kiriko.
Kiriko, Juno, Ash, who else?
And Anuron.
Or Wave 2.
Or Wu Yang.
Anuron and Wu Yang.
Wu Yang is the male equivalent of Kiriko right now.
Wintun.
I don't even know if they can add Wintun.
Do I have no teammates?
Oh, wait, I have one.
Sorry, bro.
You're solo.
Oh, never mind.
Sorry, bro.
You have one teammate now.
I ain't doing duo i i specifically sign up for trio phil oh
yeah mercy with the crocs let me see what other stuff do i
have on here oh no 100 the crocs fit the best um let's see
what do i have the maximum glove what do i give her let's
give her the yeah the turkey and then I don't have any of
the good trails.
All my trails are ass.
I guess this.
Inflatable.
Inflatable, man.
Um, but I know.
Is there a, the Overwatch dropship?
Oh, I almost made it.
I almost have it.
You're right.
They have to save Kiriko for phase two.
They gotta make sure they don't...
They don't take all our money.
They gotta be sharing.
Wait, what did Golovo say?
Got it.
Wait, you're actually running it.
Oh, wait.
I didn't even see it.
Damn right.
Damn right I'm running it.
Do we have...
Let's get Ben in it.
And make...
We don't need a sure fort- We'll show him how fun fortnight
is in Overwatch
Well, he was like wait a minute you're actually playing
fortnight
I want a full-ass queue Oh wait, JJK Wait, no, that's not
JJK.
Wait, where's my JJK guy?
where is he oh my god that looks like sombra but it's not
it's legally distinct sombra oh there he is jjk man forgot
his name the the potential man's dad that's all i know about
him he's the dad of potential man john jk that's it that's
him All right, where are we going, guys?
They did so much for Mercy.
Potential, Dad.
When they add Skibity Toilet to make Overwatch, well, thank
you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where's my team dropping?
Where are we dropping?
Okay.
I'm getting over.
Wait.
That's not my... Oh, wait.
I was gonna say.
Why did Mercy... I thought it was the toilet.
I was gonna say, when did Mercy have a ponytail?
That was just the toilet.
I got confused.
Let's hope I don't die.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm sorry.
What?
I'm okay yeah it's okay I'm okay everything is fine I don't
know what happened to me but I'm okay hey staring creepily
into space what is this oh it's a doom fist
there you go you're a boss but I still dabbed
Don't worry.
The dab is not restricted to anybody.
Is there anybody else here?
Everybody gets a dab.
Dab sees no.
Oh, there's a car.
I'll keep this.
I need to change my gun.
Yeah, look.
He's just like, what the fuck?
Oh, shit, there's a guy over here.
Dude, I'm coming over!
Oh, where am I?
Wait, how did I get here?
I did...
Oh, shit.
When I said I'm coming over, I didn't realize I'm actually
coming over.
Wait, there's Lola Bunny.
That's right.
Hoop.
I wish I could land faster, though.
Pretty annoying.
there we go wait don't kill him no no oh I wanted no it's
the tab Lola bunny yeah they're rated E for everyone like
right below us I'm pretty sure wherever they are where are
you
Go in there.
Oh.
Wait, where's our third gap?
Ring a ding ding.
Here comes the cavalry.
Did they leave?
No, because like they're here.
Oh my god, it's Daffy.
There's blip laps.
There we go.
It's Flip Blast's friend.
There's still a guy in there, isn't it?
Oh, wait, no, he fully left.
Never mind, he's actually gone.
Yeah, but I didn't want to jump in there.
I wanted to stay in the high ground.
I didn't want to leave high ground.
Oh, secret chest.
Oh, there's more of the gloves.
Is the gloves even good?
I can't tell.
Oh, yeah, no, it's good.
Uppercut.
Never mind.
I can, like, blink and uppercut.
I can, uppercut, blink away.
Oh?
I heard the tracer gun.
Where?
Doesn't know.
I see him.
Jump down.
Yes.
Yes!
Oh no!
Keep jumping down!
Yes!
Alright.
I'm gonna grab the staff now.
Thank you.
Thank you for the staff.
Yeah!
Oh yeah, you can have the shield.
never die.
I'll heal myself now.
Mercy on Mercy.
Valk, like, no, come in here.
No, don't work.
Come in here, bro.
I'm scared.
Well, I was a little scared because I had to take Agra out,
but I'm going to do this.
Oh.
Oh, wee.
Where are you going now, team?
Or my team got the contract.
The thing is, if he has the contract, You know, like...
Wait, why do I...
Oh, this is bad?
Hey guys, um...
Alright, now we're coming over.
I messed up.
I might have messed up a little bit, but I'm coming over
now.
Do not worry!
The Calvary is here!
The Calvary is still coming!
We gotta help this guy.
Are we leaving him to die?
Are we potentially leaving this man to die?
Oh my god.
He tried to recoil.
Wait, that's Santa!
Oh my god.
Punch!
There you go.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
It's all I can find.
No.
My items.
Santa!
No!
I knew I shouldn't have listened to the JJK man.
JJK man led me to die.
I jumped 10 feet away.
I'm totally fine.
It's okay.
What are you doing?
You don't even have... Oh, wait.
You do have our cards.
Oh my god.
He'll shield us.
How could you do this to me?
John, JJ, K.
No!
I have nothing now.
I'm broke.
I need something.
there's anything.
I'm so poor.
Is this healed?
Like, what the fuck is the fireplace for?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's coming.
It's these guys.
It's the same people.
No!
JJK, don't be a hero.
Run.
Oh, no, I'm paddling.
I'm paddling.
JJK, don't be a hero.
JJK, just run.
You can rest me.
No, I bumped myself into the wall.
JJK.
Come over here.
Please, I am so...
There's no way.
Okay, okay, I was going to say.
I was like, but heroes never die.
I'm just gonna swim away now All right
Oh my god here all the gunfights in front of me Surely
there's loot here I'll take it I'll take the ride shield
Surely there's anything here Oh my god there is there is Oh
my god no longer broke no longer poor just just just average
income I almost said middle-aged income it's okay there's
hope
okay we're gonna grab this just need any gun just any gun
Surely they're not gonna come downstairs, right?
Surely, right?
Surely I'd be safe down here, right?
Surely nobody's gonna come downstairs on me, right?
I don't want to touch anything right now.
My mission is just to survive.
Surely they won't know I'm down here, right?
Oh!
What happened?
What happened to my team?
how did he where did he die oh my god he died out of the
storm he actually died out of storm
my other guy left he's like fuck this shit
everything's fine
it's everything is fine The 1-H-E update saved me, my hero.
My fucking hero.
Okay, now go back up.
Oh my god!
You're busted!
I didn't notice him!
No, I tried.
I tried.
All right, at least my sponge bob now has emotes he's my
sponge bob in emotes that's all that matters wait what's oh
he's 3d bob he's 3d bob how does he do it imagination emo
how do i make him emo i didn't think he'd still be there i
thought he'd left it's not a bot no bot would camp the thing
no bot would do that
i refuse to believe a bot is programmed to spawn camp
that fucker that fucking
There's no way If a bot is programmed to spawn Cap Then good
job Fortnite you've done it You fucking We're oh wait
there's my teammate oh my god It's Genshin Then you've done
it Fortnite you create the perfect AI
We have Genshin on our team oh wait wait where did are they
okay they're landing there yeah is that Genshin skin
oh I was live oh we mom my Shenron where the fuck is this
guy going oh my god he knows the tech he knows the glide
tech guys I don't think we're make it in time, guys.
We may or may not be the last people out here.
Guys?
Team?
Oh, I'll grab here.
I'll grab the lost.
Oh.
I'll go here, then.
I got shot in like that.
Alright.
I got shot to my left, and that was no bueno.
Oh.
Nope.
Let me grab that first before I grab my gun.
Who shot me?
Oh, I see you.
I see you, bot.
That's right.
AI will not rise up today.
Well, it's in the water.
That's fucking right.
We will prevail against AI.
I will fight back.
I need a chug jug it.
Yeah, I definitely don't need all of that.
How do I use this?
Am I, like, am I shielding?
Is that, is that working?
Are you called a scanner?
Oh.
Oh, it's like a bloodhound.
Well, I only have one.
one left.
Wait, me?
What did I do?
He's so far.
He's, like, on the next town.
Why me?
I just got here.
Wait, does it recharge?
It's not, too.
Oh, it recharges.
Okay.
I don't know if this is useful, though.
Alright.
Oh, it's the same goddamn gun.
I need something else.
We're not going to go for the rivalry that they picked up
for me.
They forced me into a rivalry.
What's that?
What is that?
Who died?
Oh, it's golf.
I was just like, who's that?
Is that guy like praying?
Yeah, I did not consent to being in a heated rivalry, guys.
Unless I make millions and millions of dollars.
Yeah, I thought that was a grave.
I thought that guy was, like, crying over a grave or
something.
But it was just golf.
Oh, whoops.
I just got spoiled so much with the Tracer gun.
Oh, hey, Tracer!
Hey, Tracer, from Overwatch.
Oh, is she on our team now?
Is Tracer from Overwatch on our team?
Oh.
Oh my god.
These guys!
It's like Benny Hill right now.
Where did they go?
Where did they actually go?
I'm literally Benny Hilling right now.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
You're gonna have to get...
That's right.
Come on.
Holy shit!
Never mind!
I'm just gonna chug this.
Don't worry, my team will be fine.
My team will be so healthy.
Like, what the fuck?
I was just rolling around.
I don't like the shield at all.
I don't think the shield is that good.
How did I open this?
I just break it.
Oh, I guess I just break it.
Thanks, SpongeBob.
Thanks, Tracer, from Overwatch.
We have two purple guns.
I guess I'll pick up...
I thought these were different purples.
Oh, yay!
Don't worry, I'll be your tank.
Tanky bird is back.
I do hear shots.
Why is Tracer breaking her house?
Alright, where are they?
I need...
I need the Tracer gun.
I need the Tracer gun or...
Oh, wait.
Wait, everybody has that now?
I didn't know that.
Wait, so that's how he was hopping all over the place.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Nice.
Oh.
All right.
Easy.
Take off the bot's loot.
Nice.
Okay, there we go.
I will no longer.
JK, I'll play DPS.
JK.
It's DPS time.
Oh.
Oops.
Yeah.
All right, I want DPS.
GPS now.
A riptank.
GG's no heals.
I played DPS.
Oh.
There's fights over there.
All right.
I go this way.
Battle mercy time.
I'm a retreater.
Should pick mercy.
Come on, Father.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Should have picked Mercy.
Any kind of support.
Yeah, you can tell these are bots fighting.
Oh, my God, Tundasura!
Okay.
Nice.
I got...
It's Tundasura.
This game.
What a game.
We have everything.
That cursed meme.
They have everything here.
They have airplane legs.
You're real.
No, no!
Why would a bot be called airplane legs?
Oh!
Oh yeah, you're definitely not real.
there you go judge fudge oh wait unless huh might take it
just for that oh shit oh no oh no oh i'm sorry guys i'm
coming back right now oh fuck okay i might be able to grab
him
maybe though
oh my god okay i want to grab our buddy these things so
badly.
I really want to grab it.
Where am I?
Where did I fucking go?
Oh my god, there's another team.
I can't.
I'm sorry, bro.
There's another team.
I really want to go in there.
There's several teams around me.
Oh my god, there's more people.
There's 20 teams right now.
Okay, wait.
I might be able to arrest him.
Okay.
Got you.
Did someone call the doctor?
All right.
There we go.
We got the reds.
Okay.
I'm going to try and grab him.
I have to thirst him though.
Okay.
I might be able to do it.
Yes!
Boom!
Oh!
I got him, bro.
I got him.
Let me get you patched up.
You guys never die.
all right that's all i'm gonna risk for you okay we gotta i
don't think it's worth it i'm gonna go i'm gonna go to a
reboot station bro we gotta go to a reboot station we gotta
bring him back
okay hello
worth it
I feel like I hurt people.
Alright.
Oh, I love the movement, though, for this.
The movement goes crazy.
I hope nobody shoots me in the back.
That will be in shape!
Woo!
Oh.
We do it?
Oh, wait.
We reboot it.
I thought I heard.
I think that was the Genshin guy.
Oh hey, we got a bush.
We got a smoke cloud too.
Oh, Jamin thought that was like a guy right behind me.
I was like, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Yeah.
Okay, the tracer guns are so fun.
They are so fun to use.
The movement you can do with it is crazy.
The movement abilities for the tracer gun actually go.
goes hard.
Ooh, shot something at me.
Who's shooting things at me right now?
What the fuck?
What is going on?
What?
I'm so confused.
What happened?
Oh my god, that's what happened.
Oh, I don't even know if I can grab it.
I think nobody will know.
You're a bush.
How would they know?
I want to grab it, but...
Are they fighting?
Oh my god, I don't think I can.
I don't think I can grab it.
We have to go.
Oh, I'm so fucking dead.
No!
I didn't realize they were all three there!
Don't worry!
Oh, no.
Maybe we're...
maybe where you guys you'll never know there's a bush in
front he actually didn't know he actually almost got away
with us crazy that's crazy he didn't see the bush on the
bridge he did not see it that's crazy he didn't see the bush
on the bridge that's just a push that's just a push guys who
could it be just the push they'll never see it coming oh
it's fun i i really love the new guns the new guns are
really fun to play
He almost got away with it.
Where are my Overwatch gamers?
Where are they?
Am I the only Mercy player here?
Am I the only Mercy one trick?
Hello, guys.
Looking for a duo.
Looking for a duo to damage boost.
It's not me.
It's always my team.
No, does anyone want a damage boost in here?
Looking for DPS player.
Stop!
Who wants a pocket?
Who wants a pocket here?
Oh my god, look at him!
High five, Groot!
Nice, he missed.
Stupid treat.
Oh!
Yeah!
All right, where are we going?
Where are we dropping?
Oh, wait, my teammate's driving the bus.
Wait, wait, is it like players drive the bus now?
Oh, shit.
One of them dropped.
Where is he dropping?
Sir, where are you dropping?
Wait, where did my teammate drop?
Where is he?
Okay, he's right here.
All right, we're dropping here, I guess.
Oh, oh yeah, cause like, cause they killed the bus driver.
I forgot about that.
For those who don't know, they killed the bus driver.
So now players drive the bus now.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, new lore drop.
Gamer, thank you for the Aka.
So, thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, wait, I'm trying to find the chest.
Doki deity on the Aka.
island.
Thank you.
Why do we need that?
Yeah, they killed him.
He's been bus driving for so long.
And now...
And now he's dead.
I should drink this before I go in.
I go to my teammate.
Well, technically they didn't fire him.
He literally died.
He's literally just dead.
I can't believe in bus drive.
They have to... Oh, shit.
I can't believe it.
That's the...
Even they have to give the bus driving to the interns.
Oh.
Why am I jumping so high?
Oh, he did it.
Just one.
God, where's his teammate?
Oh.
Where are they?
Hey, there.
Hey.
Oh, oh no, that was the last guy.
Right behind you, buddy.
There's the arms.
I want to try the arms again.
I feel like the arms would be good for movement.
Yeah, some of these players don't even have a license.
That's crazy.
Gaming, thank you for the Give the chips!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Oh, nice.
Now we're gaming.
Okay.
I think it's just crazy.
Like the bunny hop movement tech here.
When you have like all three blinks, it goes so hard.
I don't think we need that.
Alright, I just grabbed this.
But thank you again.
Thank you so much for the support.
It's just for you.
Just for you.
Man, I wish I knew what I looked like when I had infinite
blinks.
I really do wish I could see what that was like.
Oh, well, goodbye, I guess.
Whoops.
Wait, where's my team?
Oh, they're still here.
I was trying to go downstairs, but I didn't realize when you
go downstairs, you get warped back up.
Oh, oh, you can go.
Oh, goodbye again.
Abuse my power.
Don't let her thought she's back.
It's never too late.
for Christmas.
Where are they going?
Guys, I want to fight.
Why are you guys still looting?
We can loot their dead bodies.
Actually, I actually need that.
I want to keep the arms just for, like, the motion.
It's a long...
We'll keep a long-range gun because we technically have the
tracer gun.
That's a long range.
Guys, let's get out of this.
city let's leave this city guys oh my god they're fighting
the fucking boss
that's sad
there we go oh and he gives a shotgun i mean they spent more
time on it than me guys come on we gotta escape the city you
guys let's get out of here what does the pepperon pizza do
anywhere i don't want it i don't know what it does oh is it
just you eat it you eat a slap slice i'm eating it what did
it do oh i can run forever oh that's pretty op
Oh, never mind.
I can't run forever anymore.
Guys, come on!
Come on!
Oh my god, never mind.
Rivalry restarted.
They're right here.
Oh, it heals health and shielding.
Why the fuck did we grab it?
Oh, I can run forever.
I hold the... I did not realize that.
Oh, I can.
Is that new?
Has that always been a thing?
Alright.
It's time to get rid of bots.
There we go.
We're bot farming right now.
Okay.
I don't need the heals.
I have these heals.
Rift Palooza.
Okay.
Do I need...
I don't need health packs if I have the staff.
I feel like...
I need a better gun though
Oh this one's blue I'll check that Alright let's go Come on
guys Come on Not here to wait Yeah I know the staff is so
fun I like that I can heal myself Too bad I can't damage
boost myself Oh
oh hey chili dog you're not real so i'm not dabbing on you
i'm not wasting a dab on you you're not real where are you
wait wait where are you oh wait there you are okay oh
give me a sec oh he's dead never mind never mind okay i do
need ammo though where is the ammo there you go that's oh
that doesn't refill it i don't know what refills my ammo
anymore i don't want to waste my staff on the little things
oh that's what refills it okay oh infinite run staff is for
i have i've been playing with 80 frames this entire time
okay i'm actually nerfed right now i didn't even realize
that but not 80 frames this entire time oh hey okay wait
guys that resets my staff there's no fucking way oh i guess
i got to lower more shit i can't believe i've been on
fucking 80 frames this entire time Are we fishing?
Guys, please, time and place Pro, the whore No wonder Guys,
now I can have more excuses On why I can't hit shots They're
vibing, bro Guys, please We gotta fight Oh my god, another
rivalry.
Oh, JJK, man.
The second JJK, man.
Where's the other JJK, man?
Marla, watch out.
You're close to the other JJK boy.
Oh.
JK.
That's the pet.
That's the fucking pet.
God damn it.
I always get confused.
Wait, did he teleport?
pointed away.
He looked like the JJK guy.
Like, it looked just...
Okay, if I look from the distance, it literally looks like
the JJK, man.
Oh.
There's gunshots here.
Where did the gunshot come from?
I don't know who he's shooting at.
He's sniping at something.
Please ping, sir.
How am I supposed to fight if you don't ping?
It's because they make movement.
I'm like a... I'm like a goddamn... What's it called?
Velociraptor.
I can only see movement.
Is it ammo?
No.
It's not what I want.
Oh, wait.
Somebody's here.
Holy shit, you're crazy.
Oh, I got you.
I wish I could, like, bunny hop them.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay, I don't got you no more.
Your damage boosted!
Yeah!
Oh, I see him.
Oh.
There we go.
I got you.
Wait, he took everything!
Are you serious?
Come on, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Let me heal myself.
I would like to... Okay, I'll heal you.
And then...
Wait, he took the stick.
Wait.
Excuse me, sir.
That was supposed to be my stick.
Okay, yeah, there we go.
I needed more ammo anyway.
Yoink.
actually i'm a foe i need more tracer here oh i do there you
go look at that i damaged boosted him and we won support
gameplay at the finest that's when you can tell i'm a that's
when you know yeah i got top 500 in support yeah that's me
yeah i i yeah that was me easy.
Yeah, I might know how to play a supporter, too.
Wow,
where do we go?
Why is my ping still there?
Like, someone get my ping out of the way.
The shift?
Oh, wait, no, it's not my ping.
It's this guy's ping.
I thought I was red.
Oh.
Oh, I got myself.
Whoa.
Yeah, I'm healing myself.
Don't worry.
I'm damage boosting.
You got this.
Oh, the range can go far, though.
Wait, did he do it?
Did he hit him?
I can't tell.
Holy shit, what is that range?
Oh, wait, he did do it.
We're coming over!
Keep shooting him!
I got you!
Just shoot him!
Okay, maybe I should heal him.
Just shoot him.
Alright, buddy.
You're getting 6-7.
Oh, wait.
I actually have to help.
Never mind.
I have to help.
Can I grab that?
There you go.
I got you, buddy.
Look at that.
I told you I got you.
Alright, that's enough heals though.
You gotta use the other stuff for healing now.
Oh wait, oh wait, Emma Frost is in my team.
Has shot him.
You had your own staff?
And you made me use it?
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Damn the evil combo.
Easy.
You should be a...
Hey, I spent my V-bugs for this.
For this exact moment.
I should be allowed to do this.
I spent my hard-earned money.
Sorry, your hard-earned money to be able to six, seven, and
dab in Fortnite.
You're welcome.
And I said, all right, it's been, it's fun.
I'm really enjoying Fortnite right now.
I'm just really enjoying the guns.
really fun to use.
Arabs, think of a super chat.
Thank you.
You know she's a support mate when in other games she still
plays a support character.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
Alan, think of a super chat.
Think of a thing.
And I'll do it again.
Naimo, think of a...
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh.
Come on, how many O's can we get?
Oh, no more O's.
Let's go.
Go, white girl.
Get some mamosas.
Stuff striking.
Thank you.
Let's super chat.
All right, who do I have on my team?
Oh, everybody.
Oh, they also won the game.
Not just me.
Um...
Oh my god, this guy's drunk.
This guy is drunk.
Where is he driving to?
Nice.
Someone click.
Stop him.
He's drunk.
Why is my teammates not dropping?
Do they know where they want to go?
Oh, here.
Okay.
I'm a little scared that my teammates are both bots.
Just a little bit worried.
I'm just I don't know those names don't look very real right
now they sure look very not real
oh my god that's not fair that is not fair No it's mark
where am I
Okay hey guys
okay I got one I helped
he's on me I don't think he saw my SpongeBob though
bro I don't have ammo
oh my god I gotta help oh
my god so close I was okay he said he dies for this he would
die for it though oh my god yes yes my killed him another
mercy that's a win that's a win in my book he whipped he
whipped all his shotgun shots too that's embarrassing that
that's a very no the thing is he whipped like five shots on
me on shotgun i got so many shots in before he actually took
me down
that's embarrassing on him not me i made the best of it also
i'm gonna use the bathroom guys i'll be right back
i'm back guys zekra fight vincel john and nexi ania meddy
allen thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
hey cleveland hey there wait isn't that the what the fuck is
going on okay i was like what's going on with the bus
all right where are we going my the big muscular dude is
driving the bus
oh oh where is he go where is the big muscular dude taking
us all right he wants to drop here where that's not even
loot there okay here is there even loot there oh my god
smell me toes left us hey a river buddy i ain't i if i
wanted to duo i'd cute duos sorry bro you're on your own
i guess he i guess he was done smelling toes it was like ggs
guys i've had my fill
squads there's too many people Four is too many.
Three is like the perfect amount.
Four.
I would say four is like just too many people to fight.
But three, three I can take.
I can take three.
All right, let's go.
I like trios more than squads.
Just because it's like...
It's just way too many people on the screen.
You know?
oh hey now it's my hero academia man
i know how can you name the stream next time dokey barren
diva killing cleveland from family guy at 3 a.m gone wrong
perhaps they give us a super chat thank you thank you we
gotta abbreviate that that might be that might be over the
word cat now where did he want to land the guy like didn't
ping anything where are you landing Bro, ping!
Alright, I guess he doesn't want to ping.
You know, I would do custom lobbies if I don't trust him.
But I may or may not trust you guys.
I remember the last time I did a Fortnite custom lobby.
And 80 people dropped on me.
No!
You know what?
I'm gonna fight.
I might have trust issues, guys.
If I do...
If I do a custom lobby.
And what's wrong?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, this is not fair.
This is not fair!
I had... I had my fucking...
Oh my god.
I had my fucking pistol out.
where else are i don't know there's like 80 percent of the
map to drop on where else would you drop there's still 80
percent of the map around us what do they have what the fuck
escape from vader here or any what is that oh there's the ai
is that ai or that looks like ai all right not gonna lie all
right blitzroy i like how they're all overwatch characters
now volume can honestly come up a little more oh my god
fortnite why are you so quiet all right i boosted the volume
a little bit more
all right all right one more game and then we'll do custom
lobbies but it's not gonna be it's not gonna be battle
royale custom lobbies i i the thing is i know I know I won't
live.
I know I won't survive.
Alright, Battle Bus is launching soon.
Oh, hey guys.
Yay.
We want to play Overwatch together?
Alright.
Let's see.
Where's the driver taking us?
He's like, yeah, you're just going to be on this part.
of the area he's just like yeah we're just gonna land on
this side only yep yep fuck the other half of the island who
gives a fuck about that half of the
island trying to figure out where I want to land it's here
oh nice staff right off the bat I should all drink this
first Oh, and a shield?
Oh, my God.
And tracer gun!
Anybody near me?
So I'm just gonna loot.
I don't really know if this...
Oh, pizza.
I'm just gonna eat it just because I can.
Worth it!
100% worth it.
I don't care.
No.
It's worth it.
What the fuck?
What shot me?
Oh my god.
I didn't realize I got shot by fucking Robin.
I was like, did I get nuked or something?
What was that?
I like stopped.
Oh my god, wait, that's so broken.
He's literally using a jet pack and then That's so broken.
Shotgun him!
Yes!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh I'm, oh my, don't fuck this guy.
I actually fanned with a bazooka.
That's so broken.
I was like, I'm fine.
And I didn't realize I was getting nuked from above.
I didn't realize I would have kept running.
Okay, wait, one more, one more, one more.
I would have kept running.
I didn't realize it was artillery from above.
Oh, is the audio god?
Just as rains from above.
It was basically fair.
Is it 480?
It's because of Ben.
It's Ben, isn't it?
I think Ben fucked up my audio.
He fucking sent a fucking nuke onto my...
He sent a nuke on me.
Oh my god, it's that guy again.
Oh my god, I got the shitty play, I'm leaving.
No, no, I'm not playing with you.
I'm not playing.
You've already disappointed me.
You were ready.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
We go in.
Okay, one more, one more.
And then custom lobby.
I want to shoot a little just one more shot
All right, here we go I just didn't want to play with that
guy She's already disappointed me enough I can't do a rerun
with her
I can't run it back with her
This is it
Oh my god, I swear it out Is that the same Ben?
Is that the same Ben?
I need a no Is that him?
Was that the same bed?
Where is he?
Was that him?
There can't be more than one bed player in this lobby.
Was it this man?
Was it him?
Does anyone remember the name?
I'm like one guy who shot me down.
No!
I can't believe there's more than one bed player in this
lobby.
I thought there was more than one bend player.
Oh, whoops.
All right, guys.
I'm landing here.
That's my bad.
I tap back in.
I think the other bend had kicks on.
I like I get free fall.
That's nice.
Okay.
Where the fuck are guns?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got the staff.
It's over.
GG's is over.
Oh.
Let's chill out.
Chill out.
Chill out!
That's
what you fucking get.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, I can't!
Oh!
I wanted to dab!
So sad.
I'm so sad.
I was trying to dab, but I couldn't get it.
I kept jumping accidentally.
You bitch.
You took this away from me.
You fucking whore.
You took away the one thing that brings me joy.
Dad denied.
I couldn't help it.
I just want to jump.
The one thing that gives me happiness and he took it away
from me.
What even is this?
Oh, dude.
I got him.
Oh, you're not real.
You're not real.
Get out of here.
No!
I wanted that.
I'm so sad.
I'm not allowed to have anything, apparently.
It's okay.
I'm so sad.
I'll get there.
nothing oh I'm so sad you won't let me have anything yeah
nothing at all guess I'm not allowed to be happy I mean
there is a I mean there's a tracer gun somewhere here I
believe I believe I can find a tracer gun what even is this
Like, what is that doing?
No, I already have that.
Um...
Alright, I grabbed shields.
Then health.
Because I have the...
I have the staff for it.
Alright, I have enough bullets.
I just need to figure out how to get out of here.
Where's the exit?
There's something on...
Oh.
How do I get out?
where the fuck is the exit oh it's this way all right figure
it out guys oh what the fuck i still don't know what that
cube is but oh it's xp oh that makes sense just for xp i
know
i'm still chasing that high the fucking glitch tracer gun
high i'm still day.
One day.
Oh.
Oh my god, he's over there.
Little does he know I have teammates and my teammates might
die because I'm baiting them.
I may have accidentally baited them.
Where did he go?
I like shot him.
Okay, they're dead.
I was gonna say, who's still trying to shoot me?
Yeah, first glitch is free.
That's how they get you.
That's how they hook you.
They know.
I don't know what gun this is, so I'm just gonna remove
that.
The other one is always double.
Oh my gosh, it's just double this.
Grab the gauntlet then.
Oh.
Ah!
Thanks.
You know what?
Ah, my turn.
Wee!
Where's my team?
Oh, nice.
There's my team.
Wait, does someone drift them anonymously?
Oh, wait, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Look at us.
Uh.
Wait.
We're getting shot.
chat from don't worry that's right there
you go i did get to do my thing now that's all i wanted yeah
at least i got my one dab i got my one dab in yeah you know
what i'm starting a rivalry let's go Oh, wait, that's not...
What?
Oh, that's me.
That's right.
Fight me!
Seagal Tamer!
Oh, my God, Santa!
It's him!
I never forget you, Santa.
That's right.
I'm here for revenge!
Where is Santa?
Oh.
There he is.
I see him.
Oh, Santa.
Santa.
Where are you, Santa?
Wait, where is he?
Get out of here.
That's right, Santa.
That's working right.
I never forget a face.
Free the elves.
Don't worry.
I'm here to save the elves.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
What is that?
Collect the shield item.
Oh wait, there's a care package.
I haven't seen one of those in 20 years.
And it's ass.
It's somehow ass.
Christmas is cancelled now.
That's fucking right.
I do it for all the kids that receive their call.
I did it for you guys.
Santa will no longer terrorize us.
You are allowed to be bad.
Finally.
Alright.
Oh, is that self-revive?
Oh, oh, that's what it is.
I see.
Yeah, start another rivalry.
Fuck it.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, wait.
We already have it.
Oh, my God.
It's the Heat Man.
Let him go.
The world is right again.
Finally, we are bringing back anarchy.
I'm pardoning everybody on the naughty list.
Okay.
I'm for the people.
That's right.
The naughty.
Oh, my God.
That's right.
No, I got stuck on the bridge.
Oh, my God.
I deserve to win that fight.
If I didn't get stuck on the fucking bridge, guys.
Me, Angi.
if I didn't get stuck on the bridge
yeah and I have self-healers oh hey SpongeBob it's alright
yeah now I'm gonna drink this oh oh my god that's not get oh
my god wait that's not what we want it
oh my god i'm just gonna heal myself i'm just gonna heal
myself and just hope for the best okay
jesus christ i don't know how to do the combos for this i
want to go save ben ben ten oh
this is bad i don't have any more blinks
Holy shit, they're ever...
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
Ever get that feeling of deja vu?
Oh no.
He definitely doesn't know.
And the moment I do this, I'm gonna run it.
Oh my god, no!
That sucks for me, that actually sucks for me.
Oh my god!
I'm so sad.
I actually I actually was I fucking made such a play too I
made such a fucking play I just didn't know my body for my
guns that sucks I literally moved the shit out of that too
guys bro my movement went fucking hard there my movement was
crazy I had movement
I'm moving the shit out of that I'm so bad at quick swapping
no I keep because I need like I should put the my gun key to
like wherever to wherever like i'm planning on using my
tracer gun but i never put it at the same place so i always
forget like which which key is the is the tracer gun so i
always get like i always forget about that and that was like
my biggest mistake every time
yeah oh my god that's so close to
i'm so sad i lost my tracer gun
I'm gonna grab this.
So at least, like, I have something.
Alright.
Just put it over here instead.
I need a quick swap with number keys more.
Oh my god.
I wish I had the morbidly Chinese.
What a name.
What a fucking name.
I need the pulse pistol so badly.
no
if only I have the pulse pistas
someone I'm pretty sure that guy's real I don't think
Fortnite would generate that name
maybe I'll find well you can change your skin while you play
Ben that's so that seems pretty broken
how does he change does he like change it as he plays like
if he feels like being a different alien
he's a very chinese time in his life right now true
yeah i know like his omni tricks but like i'm talking about
like in game like in game oh it's oh it's the built-in emo
oh so wait that's so smart he's changing his he's emoting
the changes uh to change his skin to fit the environment so
he camouflaged is better wait that's that's pay to win what
do you mean there's pay to win skins in my fortnite wait a
minute i
don't even know what gun is good i'm just there's only one
gun in my head mine that is the best and i don't have it
also puyo thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
get out of my way
Oh.
I see him.
Hi.
I see.
Are you winning?
Yeah, we won a couple of the games.
We won a couple.
There's still 12 people alive.
There's three more squads alive, right?
Not including us.
Oh.
My team's going.
See?
Quick maths.
Where's my chicken?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, chicken doesn't appear when I'm running.
Oh, I see the foot.
Sucks, because they have pulse pistols and we don't.
Only our Ben 10.
Only Ben has the best gun.
We're just, we're poor.
We're fighting with poverty right now.
Okay, why do we have a rivalry contract?
I didn't consent to that contract.
I'm scared.
You can look closer.
I knew you had a revive.
I'm not going for it.
Okay.
I guess I am.
I guess I am going for it.
Alright, I'm going for it.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Oh no.
I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry.
Baited him.
I baited my bro.
I'm sorry, bro.
I didn't mean to bait you.
Wait, I got the mercy.
Yeah!
Kill the mercy!
Dev.
That's right.
Kill the mercy.
We did it That's fucking right Can't get healed now Alright
now I know how to Okay I hit every tracking shot There holy
shit I did not Miss during that fight And I know they were
real people Too I I know you were real I know you were real
Too so you had To look at me damn Hell yeah.
That's right.
I played these games before.
Dopamine rush.
Alright, but yeah, I saw that, right?
I didn't miss a...
Oh, hey, Golly's here.
Golly's here.
Damn.
Back to the lobby.
They go
There we go what that's right Is he even here all right, I'm
gonna I'm gonna give I'm gonna give dad I'm gonna give I
think he might need his water refilled.
I'm gonna double check guys.
I'll be right back.
Don't worry While we're doing that you have The macarina
I'll be right back
God, okay Gully's calling Oh my god, I don't know if I have
energy right now We couldn't get Ben Hello Where's Ben Oh my
god, wait, wait, you're on speaker Give me a sec It like
swapped the speaker for some reason Don't stop the thing me
go do it okay all right there you go there you go where's
ben i think ben's dead wait hold on this amongus guy just
got out of a game oh wait wait wait wait wait can we get him
in can we type in i'll type in this chat too we'll peer
pressure him on stream
we'll be like did you type in a stream already don't yeah
don't queue i have wait gully why Why don't you have mod?
Why don't I have mod?
Yeah.
This fucking guy, bro.
Play Fortnite.
The holes.
That's a lie.
He does not need one business day notice.
That's a fucking lie.
I asked.
Yesterday.
oh that's true we asked yesterday it's now sad
bro this guy's at actual grins i can't believe it why won't
he play fortnite with the homies he can relive his overwatch
days I can't believe they said
Okay, send in the Wait, wait, wait, how many gifted Send I'm
not gifting, you're gifting it You're not using me to gift
You're not using, I will gift I'll give him the Overwatch
bundle
500 He wants a 5 500k.
He doesn't care about the homies.
Hates his friends.
Oh my god, and he got in a game.
He got it in a game, golly.
This guy's an actual fucking hater.
We're not that bad, right, golly?
Wait, is he saying he needs alcohol and painkillers to play
with us?
We're not that bad.
Yeah, why would he say that?
Why would he say that?
Every time we play together, we had a great time.
Every time we play together, I'm smiling ear to ear.
Exactly.
Why would he need alcohol for that?
Unbelievable.
Not a real bro.
I can't believe it.
He's missing out.
We can, we buff Tracy.
It's so fucked up.
That's...
You said, well, I don't have mod.
Um, I always tell people, why be...
Okay, what was it?
I'd rather be VIP instead of moderating people, right?
Why?
Like, I'd rather be in the cut in the booth getting bottle
service.
No, you want to be there?
like a very important person yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
then you can't abuse your power
what's the point it's probably for the best
i have this thing where i just like i just don't care and i
don't look back so i think it's probably for the best i'm so
sad i can't believe he would i can't and ben's dead too gone
too soon is because of all the marathon bro okay where's ben
actually he only plays if you ask him to but he doesn't like
playing those games he'll like playing it with us though
we're like a party we need we should like have all three of
us together and then send a screenshot send it to sure for
it be like you're missing out wish you were here wait hold
on wait hold on hold on i could probably let me see if i
could find someone you're like this is what you're missing
out right now bro this could have been you dude lock in we
need a fourth we need a third and a fourth what do you mean
we need two more
and then he's just like wait you asked moxie yeah oh wait
wait did you message it on discord i did yeah yeah hop on
fortnite with gully and i i asked him earlier and he says so
you're telling me overwatch skins are making you want to
play fortnite no it's so fun it's it's really fun the oh bro
the pulse guns are crazy like i was It is actually so fun.
Wait, you're invested.
No, I've never had this much fun on Fortnite before.
It's actually crazy.
No, and then, like, they brought Mercy staff in there so you
can pocket people with the Mercy staff.
Hold on, let me see if I can convince someone.
And we could be like, wish you were here.
This could have been you right now.
It's like they combine Apex, Overwatch, and Fortnite all
together in one game.
Like, this should be a game mode.
This should be a permanent game mode.
This should be a permanent game.
Yeah, no, no, when you get the pulse gun, like, you don't
understand.
When you get the pulse gun, it's actually, like, adrenaline
rush.
When you get it.
Was it, like, Thanos gauntlet from like years ago?
Because you can, like, okay, so in my first playthrough, I
accidentally glitched the pulse gun.
I've been trying to chase that high ever since.
had like infinite blinks i was literally blinking the entire
map from one end to the other so you're cheating no no no no
it was a glitch it was a bug it was a you were exploiting it
was no no it was a bug that i don't know if i don't know how
i exploited it then it's not cheating wait right right right
if you're oblivious to it yeah i thought yeah i thought it
was part of the game because it was my first time playing
with that gun a feature exactly it it was just a feature
also chat let me know if golly is like uh loud enough
because i know he was not as loud before wait am i quiet you
were yeah you were a little quiet earlier oh my god wait
moxy hasn't replied is he even still alive i think he hates
i think he hates us too bro no he doesn't hate us he doesn't
i rated no he can't hate me because i rated him I raided him
with 2k people yesterday, so he had...
He's not allowed to hate me.
Yeah, he's not allowed to hate me.
I gave him a raid.
Hey, I can turn it up a little bit.
Okay, I'll turn it up, Gully, a little bit.
All right, let me do the...
Yeah, I bribed him.
He should be fine.
Wait, if I send him a screenshot of us in the lobby with
like pleading eyes emoji, you think he'll join?
Yes.
Wait, who?
But who though?
Mox.
He didn't even reply.
Has he replied back to you yet or no?
He did earlier.
I don't think he...
Wait, how about with us dab?
I have a dab.
If you get a screenshot of my dab.
Let me know you got it.
Wait, hold on.
hold on i'm i'm dabbing for the screenshot i'd be like
you're missing out okay i missed it fuck don't worry i
misnamed it it's so fast all right two three got it oh hell
yeah yeah let's go let's go again you send it to me i want
to see what it looks like fuck okay we do it one more time
okay one two three got it all right i missed it i like a
frame all right we just do you think he'll unfriend you if i
we send him this one no no no wait do one more time okay oh
yeah every time i kill somebody i would i doubt I'm six
seven them every time.
Dude, you might be fucking evil, you know, though.
I spent my chats hard earned money for this, okay?
Of course I'd use it.
Wait, do you have triple T?
No, I don't have.
I didn't.
I forgot to buy it.
I have do you have him?
Okay, then we're both losers.
Yeah, we're both losers.
Whoa, whoa, don't go me with you.
What do you mean?
Oh, I have him.
Look at this.
I have Mordecai.
That could have been you.
Fuck.
That's right.
That could have been you right now.
I also have this guy.
I have the repo guys.
That could have been you too.
I still haven't played repo ever.
You?
never played repo nope you got i heard there's a new update
for repo have you played it i know i haven't played repo
since like it first came out i haven't played any of the
newer stuff oh my god you're look at you you're so glam when
i met you in the summer my happy song i'm so sad why won't
anyone join
I thought we were cool You gotta send the six seven pleading
eyes Wait, wait, send me the screenshot Okay, oh I didn't
send it to you No, no, no, no
Wait, why am I holographic?
How do I I don't know Why am I so pale Because how do I fix
that?
Why am I like transparent guys how do I fix it oh I'm on sit
out mode I'm not with a nice sat out wait we gotta take the
new screenshot wait wait wait I get a 6-7 too oh you got one
too oh we can both 6-7 are you ready well time it you take
the screenshot ready alright alright alright ready alright 3
2 1 did you guys screenshot okay I fucked it up okay one
more time three two one
all right that's actually really fucking wait what if you
six seven i dab oh god okay dude how many of these are we
gonna fucking take well that's like three screenshots one of
them will work on someone are you ready okay yeah you do the
countdown One, go.
Oh, wait.
Bro, your dab is fucking so fast.
Wait, you do six, seven, and I'll do the dab right after
when I see it.
All right, all right, all right, three.
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Fuck.
Dude, this is so impossible.
We need the screenshot.
This is gonna, this will convince me to be able to play with
us.
This will convince me to be able to play with us.
They'll be like, oh my God, we have to play with them.
They're so cool.
All right, all right.
okay three two one go oh this is perfect oh my god oh this
is so it's like no wonder nobody wants to play with you guys
there's no everybody everybody was gonna want to play with
us the moment they see the screenshot or send it to moxie
and also sure for and also ben someone will someone will
reply back
the six seven dab is actually crazy i'm rocking with it at
and at everyone at here server oh yeah yeah at the server at
your server your what's your server called yet the pup pup
bros
like you wish you were as cool as us right now and you could
be and you can be too kick shaving oh my i'm i can't believe
it why would you have you have this though let me go that's
right wait did you you bought the Overwatch bundle, but you
didn't buy Lois Griffin?
No, wait, no, no.
Wait, wait, look at this.
Okay, wait, where is it?
Wait, give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember how to...
Okay, but...
Oh my god.
But do you know the song by heart?
Wait, let me remember.
I did, I did, but I'm blanking out right now.
Seems today that all you see...
It's violence.
Wait, was it?
Violence and movies and sex on TV.
But where are the...
Where are those good old fashion values?
On which we?
I don't remember that part.
Oh, we're too used to lie.
Dude, you're gone.
Yeah.
His mercy got himself.
are we just gonna fill for now what people wait wait wait
wait wait wait maybe okay oh my god too many emotes stop
stop dancing did you did you send did you send it to moxie i
did yeah okay i'll send him send it to him too what you're i
didn't send them to deb hold on hold on i said What's you're
missing out on right now?
That could be you.
That could be you right now.
Please.
Oh, yeah.
I still can't believe the Shurfor guy said no.
I can't believe it either.
That is insane.
Bro, it's his game.
X, his favorite game.
It made his entire career And then He said no to us To us
Gasp I can't believe it
How could he say that to us?
What have we done to him?
You know, we only like You know, make him miserable every
game that we play We only like torture him Yeah, but it's
like out of love You know?
Yeah, we only like Like, you know your true bros when your
bro harasses you until you cry.
You know you're a real one.
Yeah,
he can only tolerate us when he's drunk and on painkillers
and...
Yeah, but when he's drunk, you know, when he's drinking, he
wants to let loose, you know?
Because he wants to enjoy the moment more.
Oh, right, right.
You know?
He wants to be like...
he wants to like relax around that means he wants to relax
around us and he's taking the painkillers because dude he's
taking off his tie yeah yeah exactly yeah like hard day at
work that's awesome and then taking off the tie just to hang
out with us you know like a little bit of scotch before the
game dude what do you know about scotch bro it fucking sucks
it's so strong like one sip your what's your drink of choice
what's your uh what's your poison uh it's uh uh i usually
drink cocktails oh i love screwdrivers screwdrivers are my
go-to you know to me dokey you give off big buzz ball energy
what's buzz ball the biggie balls what i'm talking about no
where are you
BiggieBuzz?
Yep.
BiggieBuzz.
What the fuck is BiggieBuzz?
What the fuck is that?
Go, Leo.
Bro, it's a big pop from Fortnite.
They're real.
Oh, my God.
What do we have?
Star Killer 815?
Okay, the moment you have to get the pulse pistols, you have
to get this.
them they're so good i don't think he fucks with us but we
don't need him
have your teammates been talking tonight or no no dude
everybody's just fucking uh shooting their gun they don't
care about us okay do you know that they shot the they
killed the bus driver what yeah they killed the bus driver
them They did.
They killed them.
Wait, I should, I could maybe get a third.
I could maybe get a third.
But I don't know how good she is at Fortnite.
She's playing words on stream.
I don't know how good she is.
Because, like, I was supposed to have a collab today.
Then, like, it had to be postponed.
Because, like, one's internet died.
And then the other one just got off of a tournament.
And I was, like, too tired to do a...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, wait.
I forgot.
Oh, my God.
There's no jump leader.
Don't worry.
I'm right here.
I'm going blue.
Yeah, yeah.
I was just like, oh, man.
You were tired and you were just...
Yeah, I was just like, I'm just going to play Fortnite.
I was just like...
Yeah, so like...
No, what in doubt?
Fortnite.
Exactly.
You said they're playing Wardle on stream?
Yeah, she was playing Words on stream.
I don't know what that is, but because we had to disband the
collab.
It's okay.
We have Tracer, Overwatch, and Fortnite.
Life is good.
It's good.
And she got...
They gave her ass back.
Finally.
That's what the people wanted.
Dude, we are so...
The world is healing.
Her ass is back, guys.
all right let me drink it i hear people next to me i might
need help i'm only sure four is here to protect us we're
sure oh yeah the pizza heals wait this is where i've died
before i remember this place
honestly if we power scale if we power scale uh uh tracer on
a stab um how would you rank her versus chun lee power skill
yeah yeah can we power rank her how would you rank her
against chun lee greater or oh my god i'm getting damage
boosted right now i'm getting what are your damage boosting
me dude i'm a little mercy pocket and i can fly yeah yeah
you can fly they'll never know the bush is you they'll never
know it's so incognito yeah conspicuous bush the flying bush
who could that be basically i'm thinking tracer over chumley
tbh honest why
i mean are you kidding me she's not even here right now like
you don't even have a comparison oh i see you tracer
overwatch damage boost me damage boost me oh my god wait
wait wait that's the real guy that's a real guy dude you're
so fast that's a real guy wait wait we have to do the thing
where's the other guy where is he i know he's real too
I know he's real.
Where is the other guy?
I think our teammate's fighting him.
Is he?
I don't know.
Where the fuck am I?
Where is he?
I think our teammate needs heals.
I don't know where the other guy is.
The one that we knocked.
Wait.
They're resing.
in front of me.
Good Corp?
Don't give her do something!
Wait, they're rising in front of me, guys!
I'm coming back?
I think that's the guy we killed!
The one- Yeah, it is!
No!
I- No!
It is him!
I could do it again.
Don't worry.
Golly.
Okay, go, go, go.
I'll come back just to get- just to do it again.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I don't know where he is.
He's, like, in one of the houses.
Wait, he's here, he's here!
Oh,
wait, I'm going over.
I just hear you lying.
I jumped over the fence by accident.
Yo, Sinkum!
Get damage with me!
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm going to do it again.
I need to do it again.
Where are you?
My Zotachi again, bro.
I told you.
He's not safe.
Where is he?
Oh, I see him.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I got him.
Oh, my God.
He's lagging.
I'm not going to lie.
This freaking little sap is kind of OP.
I haven't played Overwatch in like five years.
Yeah.
This is exactly the same.
I'm just holding Yeah, it's like you never left.
It's like I never left.
Just like the good old days.
Boy.
See, this is what Sure Force missing out right now.
This is what he could have had.
I hear people, but I don't see people.
I think they're inside the house, I'm pretty sure.
I wish there was VoIP in this game.
Oh, just here, yeah.
There was in the game mode.
I see him.
front of me.
There.
There's one above.
Here.
Oh, he's so low.
Oh, I ran out of...
I ran out of juice, bro.
Oh, no.
Not the juice!
I'm going in.
Wait, where are they?
This guy's a...
This guy's a little gamer.
Who is?
Wait, where?
Oh, wait.
They're like all the way there.
They're pussies.
They ran so far.
How am I gonna 6-7 them?
They run away.
You had a railgun?
Dead.
I'm already there, guys.
Gully, Gully, where are you?
Where's my little pocket?
Gully, are you?
Is that all I empty?
Is it all empty?
Is it just a little pocket?
my staff i told you i'm naked wait i have pizzas though i
have pizzas you want the pizza okay i got this guy oh my god
this guy is like i'm just staring at you there we go he was
strafing me too much i whip like 80 shots here here what
you're full never mind i was like eat this pizza i'm fine
guy keeps running away i need a what is that oh i see him
he's over there golly go get him
oh we're gonna attack by the you're gonna attack by the mpcs
here's the mercy stuff oh my god nice that's what we needed
so back our little mercy our little want to be mercy wait it
it died already oh oh it's okay we can find you another one
you can heal sled another day actually feel i feel so naked
it yeah yeah oh my god wait she has the pulse pistol she we
have to get it we have to get it's like one of the best guns
we have to kill we have to kill her it's the only way
okay all right I think I hear someone resing I do too I
think it's them I think it's the Austin people again he's
resing the Austin guy I live one of them but no Kihou yeah
that's a bot there's no way you're real oh my god he's
rolling through it all i'm just nuking it oh yes i got you
the staff where are you wait somebody's above me there come
but where
i want to stick him but i don't know where they are i'm a
little scared gully bro i'm pocketing you why are you scared
i'm so scared oh my god there's the tracer i got the tracer
guy Look.
Look how fast I am.
Dude, you're zipping and zapping all over the place.
Go kill him.
Wait, he has the tracer gun too!
Go get him!
He's like, he's running away like a coward!
I can't get him.
He's way too gone.
He's gone.
I'm fucking...
I'm just gonna loot.
Wait, there's another player.
Oh, no!
Our teammate died.
Our teammate...
Wait, I could res him with my staff.
This thing is broken.
I can't get him.
He went.
He like, he's gone.
I'm going to go loot again.
The guy's gone, guys.
What's this thing?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
SMG.
All these are insane guns.
I'm going to grab this.
Is this?
There's a hammer, a revolver.
Yeah, there's a person above.
Where is he?
Ping?
Oh, wait.
You're right.
I can't get up.
there though yeah i can't either oh i want to grab the oh
wait who took my railgun wait i have one but it's mine there
you go i got free fire somebody took my railgun who's
getting shot at oh he's over there if i could i would go up
i could Wait, he actually got shot out of the air.
Yeah, I actually...
I told you, if I can, and it did.
Wait, I gotta grab this.
We keep talking to each other.
Wait, grab it!
Grab this!
Grab this, Gully!
This gun is actually an adrenaline rush.
You have to grab it.
Gully, Gully, Gully!
Gully!
Wait, Gully, grab this!
And you can heal yourself!
Grab this!
This game is awesome.
What?
this gun pulse pistols yes that is the gun oh no no it's
space it used spaces blank
it's like it's like i never left it's like i never yes i
know it's like we never left it's like it's like the booking
movement it's beautiful it's the day i lost you i'm stoic
bro where's your overwatch wait a minute gully where's your
overwatch bundle huh um where's your you could be tracer
right now where are you doing with you i want to be genji
bro yeah then why aren't you genji huh fuck am i gonna get
peer pressured and use code doki yeah check out yeah check
out know he's our guys trying to find people right now wait
we got oh oh look at that look at that distance i covered
look at me go yeah so tell you why don't you have genji huh
oh dude are you actually gonna peer pressure me yeah of
course are we really doing the overwatch update with no Are
you really gonna do that?
Oh glob.
Come on, you went, you bought the Simpsons skin for our
Simpsons run.
For the Simpsons update.
Dude, we haven't played Fortnite since, bro.
Yeah, but we build memories, though.
Did we even win a single time?
I don't remember.
I just know sure if we're yelling at us a lot.
Well, that guy's like, permanently yelling.
Yeah, that's, she's always yelling at us.
But, like, he likes it.
He likes it.
We relieve stress for him.
You know?
You have some homies you can yell at.
He's like, yo, let me yell at you real quick.
What are you shooting at?
That's a dude over there.
That dude just flew above us, too, to your left.
No.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, wait, you got him.
Wait, I'm- I'm dabbing.
Wait, how'd you fly?
Oh, you just jumped down.
Hey.
That's right.
Get over there.
Hey.
Come on.
Get over there.
Yes, climb back.
There we go.
I like how do you think he just watched us for a bit he kept
us company but they're fighting someone up there right oh
yeah over here oh shit there's There's a car!
There's a car!
He's trying to run us over!
Don't get run over!
Wait, where are they?
Oh my god, he tried to run us over there, freaks!
Wait, we gotta bounce, bro, we're fucking...
Yeah, I know, I'm just following the car.
Honestly, I'm just gonna run up to the map.
Alright.
this pulse rifle is kind of op wait this car is almost dead
he's healing himself
i need to heal my teammate wait i need to heal you
dude you're in the storm oh i got too busy dabbing we could
do the double together i got i'm okay i'm okay now
that's right i dabbed him where is the truck anyway oh
there's still wait there is wait it's it's one more player
there's five people oh wait there's two people left there's
two people left surely we find them if we go up the hill
right surely right oh what was that shooting bushes oh okay
oh you're yeah my game sense is insane bro what's your game
says yeah i would bro i would have gone pro if my if my
mouse didn't disconnect he's on he's here i don't know why
he got locked in pizza pizza time okay you if you saw what i
saw the guy got locked i see them he's up look at him go oh
wait it's two wait it's three oh my god they res they res
the team i knocked one I'm gonna try and kill the truck
there we go yeah dab we're so fucking good dude shut up star
killer 815 yeah shout out to that guy see he didn't leave us
he didn't fucking leave us he was a real one
box said ain't no way i don't believe it fortnite in 20 20
26 dabbing on me while i'm getting six
wait wait wait no builds dabbing on me while i'm getting 67
is crazy work and why the fuck is sponge drop there i am so
damn cozy already shit am i really missing out yeah you're
missing wait wait screenshot the wind screenshot the wind oh
shit wait no wait i didn't get the victory royale i forgot
okay it's all right okay wait wait let me wait should we
leave the lobby okay i'm gonna send this to him no bills you
are missing out we won we got a victory we got a victory
royale come
We accidentally queued up with this guy again, bro.
Oh, shit.
Welcome back, Starkiller.
You play...
When I match it in the summer.
Yo, yo, wait, where's my mic?
Yo, yo, it's not working.
Is it not working?
Yeah, bro was a homie.
He was gaming, so it's fine.
Starkiller knew what's up.
okay let's go we're so good glody wait wait a minute we
should leave so you can buy your overwatch skin we should
buy it all right dude aren't you like a gillian like a
gillianer what do you mean i'm not i'm buying okay as a
matter of fact if if you can get if you can convince moxie
to join us i will buy you a genji skin oh no you think
that's that's the bounty yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah i need
you convince moxie to join us and then you get a you get a
genji skin i'm dropping unbelievable i gave him a little
check okay what about diva thoughts diva i thought you said
you wanted to be genji yeah but i just saw a video of diva
like doing an emote and it changed yeah but she's like baby
diva though that's you're literally throwing You're
literally throwing.
Yeah.
He's a pro gamer, though.
And I'm a pro gamer.
Yeah.
Also, I, like, dropped really fucking late.
I have people on me.
Yeah, I'll be there in, like...
In, like, when?
I don't know.
I'll let you know.
I'm on the way.
Yeah, I have 20 people chasing me!
Yeah, you'll be alright.
You know, it's not a big deal.
Okay right now.
Yeah, do you see me look look up look up to your left behind
you.
Look look See where where are you guys?
Dude, I'm floating in Oh, by the way, what do you mean?
Wait, you're still in the sky I told you I was flying I need
healing What do you mean?
You know what?
Yeah, it's time for me to clutch up Yeah, you better our
guys might be dead.
She has no bullet The G and gully since we're Oh I think at
this point you should leave and res us.
I mean, oh my god wait this guy's really bad.
You can shoot.
Oh Golly, I got him.
I got him Go All right, I'm gonna go
yeah oh oh okay wait that was a good shot that was a good
shot now one v2 oh my god he's riding shielding he's doing
the ride shield deck oh six seven him
there's no
okay i didn't i i panicked okay i panicked you panicked you
were on an evo for four seconds i was panicking okay i'm
sorry wait how do i leave this lobby i didn't mean to kill
him wait wait all right get him get him over here get him
over here then you get your genji skin
i don't think it's gonna work wait i got an umbrella yeah
baby i can't believe he's cozy right now oh yeah let me
message my other friend you okay but like i kind of pwned
those freaking noobes no yeah but then like but then you
lost all your cred but you lost all your cred though your
aura after you emoted for five seconds and then died to a
guy crouch walking towards you i didn't know how to turn it
off so i just i don't play this game you gotta kill me some
that is not true that is not true you play this game you
played as much as i played this game i'm level 17 like
you're a veteran but that 29 uh that level 29 was from today
it's because of today that's not helping your case you're
cracked bro no you're cracked bro you could you could be
cracked too if you if you wanted that one reset and like
drink my little munis dude i'm just maybe you need alcohol
and painkillers too no i just You know what?
Maybe I, too.
Alright, I messaged my other friend.
If she plays Fortnite.
Let's get that squad going.
What do you mean if she plays Fortnite?
I don't know if she plays Fortnite.
I haven't seen her play shooters before.
But you gotta do the pleading eyes emoji.
And then send her the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true, that's true.
Send her the dab, too.
Send her the dab.
pleading eyes emoji never fails yeah because I wasn't
planning on I wasn't planning on doing like a one-to-one
collab today but for fortnight for fortnight let's get that
squad going we can love fortnight I love fortnight you know
what you can you know what code you can use that you buy a
fortnight skin buddy what which one if you use creator code
dokeybird you can support favorite creator and vtuber and
who's your favorite vtuber golly can i say it no you don't
know her you know her bro who's your favorite vtubers whose
name starts with a d whose name starts with a d i'm only
into niche micro celebrity vtubers who haven't debuted yet
oh yeah who are who is it yeah who is it would you like to
know yeah i do so niche dude i do Maybe I want to check her
out.
We gatekeep.
What do you mean?
She'll be niche for us.
She'll be yours.
Like, only you can watch her, so you don't have to share
her.
Is that it?
That sounds a little fucked up, girl.
Don't you want her to be successful?
Dude, no.
She hasn't been viewed yet.
So you don't want her to be successful?
Well, not yet.
Not yet?
You just want time with her?
Well, she doesn't share.
stream so like he hasn't debuted yet you wouldn't get it bro
you wouldn't get it you're right i don't i guess i'll never
get it
can't believe it why won't anyone want to play fortnite with
us dude that's because we're freaking losers for we're not
losers because we're freaking losers playing fortnite as
mercy and a roti maru bro No!
We're cool!
We're so cool!
Do you think... Do you think...
Never mind.
They're definitely... Wait, wait, no, no.
What do you think?
What?
Somewhere on the internet, there's gotta be like Orochimaru
X like Mercy fanfic.
There has to be.
There's always...
There's gotta be like Orochimaru X Moira or some bullshit.
There's always something.
I think we're pretty neat.
right you know what i think so too see we're pretty chat
dragons are we cool people are just intimidated by us that's
why they don't want to hang out with us
you're just scared itachi or the orrochimaru for the day you
should rock the genji
grab that gorochimaru again get that genji You should rock
the Genji.
Rock Genji with code Dokeybird.
Yeah, with code Dokeybird.
Someone said it doesn't exist yet.
I mean...
Dude, I've seen some crazy ships on the internet.
Not yet.
Someone can make it...
Someone can make our dreams come true.
Dokey, what's the craziest ship you've seen?
Like...
like those like tumblr edits you know what i'm talking about
oh you know over the ones for disney pixar with the elsa and
jack frost videos okay yeah that's pretty tame i remember
yeah they're tame but they're like the edits go crazy though
yeah remember the edits though they go pretty hard i feel
like the craziest one i ever saw was you know who
huandissimo is from fairly but on decimo it was it was
colandissimo x olaf frozen wait link the video fanfic or
video they were in love it was wait fanfic or video though
it was a video wait give me let's let's link in chat i don't
i don't know if it exists anymore on decimo x oh that's
gonna be under search history no I'm not.
It's okay.
Wait.
If we were a movie, is it that one?
Oh my God.
Yes.
Is it?
Can you play it?
What is it, babe?
Wait, wait, wait.
I wouldn't see it.
Wait, I'll link it to you.
I want to make sure it's exactly what I think it is.
Hold on.
I found it on kuba.com.
What the fuck is kuba?
I don't know.
I was like, am I going to get hacked or something?
Am I going to...
Oh my God.
This is it.
There you go.
this is it i don't know what coop is but if i shared malware
i'm sorry guys we're all in this together oh he's like i
love you starts crying i i love you too what is it babe wait
oh wait it just repeats no but this is literally it that's
it okay i thought wait there's more if you if you click the
arrow keys.
There's more.
There's more if you click the arrows.
Wait, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The arrows on the video.
Olaf and Juan Dissimo spend the most amazing day of their
life together.
This is so beautiful.
Flexus muscles.
I'm Juan Dissimo.
Want to chill?
Oh yeah, Mr. Craft.
What is this?
Wow, did you find this video?
Dude, I don't know, but like, I don't know.
I'm actually impressed that you found this, by the way.
I learned all I did was search upon Dissimo X Olaf, and it
was literally the first one.
It was not that hard.
It used to be on YouTube, right?
So, like, once it was off of YouTube, yeah, it like ceased
to exist.
It's used to try to censor one decibel.
It's trying to censor one decibel X Ola fan tag.
How dare they?
They were too afraid.
They were too scared.
Just let that out in the world.
They were cowards.
where is moxie bro i i actually you ever like you've seen
dad to a raven yeah you know when she like gets like a
vision she like stops and like a little tunnel goes through
her eyes it was like that bro but the end of the tunnel was
fucking one decimo and olaf was making out that's that's
what you just did to me like i was thinking more so of like
uh of like uh you know how like the ratatouille the
ratatouille meme where he takes the bite of the ratatouille
and you're transported back to the childhood yeah that's you
you saw that video and you were back you were back to to
where it all began oh yeah dude my pen drops to
Wait, what is that?
Oh, it's the AI man.
That's a Stonks guy.
He's a...
Oh, wait, it's Stonks guy!
You're right!
AI man!
Yo!
She has some respect to the Stonks guy.
I thought it was...
No, Fortnite has a skin...
Has a skin?
Where...
Um...
Where it's like...
It's like a meme on AI where the guy had like 80 fingers or
some shit.
I didn't even realize Stonk's guy had.
Okay, where are we jumping?
I don't know.
Oh, you pick, buddy.
Oh, we got kicked out.
I kind of want to go to Wonkyland.
Let's go to Wonkyland.
That was the South Park one area.
I can't believe we didn't play DL when South Park was out.
Did we?
We didn't.
We only did like...
We only did Simpsons.
ice spice they don't do simsons and ice spice yeah bro that
clip lives rent-free wait do you have the link to the clip
i'll tell you my chat about the clip i forgot where the link
was i get it wait do you have a bookmark like yeah it's i'm
pretty sure it's pinned somewhere because it was so stupid
you have a bookmark for memory's sake it's like you want to
be buried with that clip it played this clip on during my
funeral i don't think we ever laughed so hard fortnight
since then i think that was the day that sure for decided to
not play with us as much i'm pretty it was a day he
unplugged his mouse he hung it up unc was done bro he was
like i gotta retire now
i don't understand why why though we're so fun yo funny guy
on me all right i'm coming with you Oh, gully.
Does he have a shotgun?
He didn't.
He's really lit, though.
That guy was not lit.
He had shields on.
The chloroprene?
He's like sliding.
He's shedding right now.
He's shredding.
Dude, help me.
Kiesen.
Stonks.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
This guy.
You think this guy like...
Holy shit.
That guy.
hit every shot you're just like dude i want to be stonks guy
i think we're gonna lose stonks man soon oh goodbye gully
you gotta leave you gotta leave gully they're gonna they're
surrounding you i'm dead i can't rest because they're gonna
find you you know that right they're gonna find you can't
see me because like because you're invisible yeah you're you
are healing wait come to me I have we were a movie You'll be
the right guy And then And yeah Resme Resme I have I have
the new Resme I have the alien gun Wait wait wait Wait have
minis have minis Okay I do too I do too You know I didn't
want to give you my minis actually It's okay that Look I
save it for you Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I knew how much you need it.
Oh, wait, watch this.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a pot here.
Come grab this.
There you go, bro.
I'll never know.
Here, eat this.
Eat this, eat this.
Oh, my God.
I just ran past you.
How do I drop it?
I told you, they'll never know.
Dude, shhh.
I think I might grab this.
I think I might grab this gun and then we go fight, yeah?
Oh.
He's on me, I'm on me, Kali!
I'm coming, I'm stuck in this fucking building.
He's over here, he's on me, he's on me right here!
Oh my god, I can't get up.
He shot me instead of you!
Oh my god, he's low!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, he's one, he's one.
Just thirst him, thirst him.
I'm so low.
There you go.
You know what I did?
He didn't know I was a bush.
He didn't know.
up he shot me instead of you bro the bush it works I'm so
scared I'm literally one hit here have some meds for you yo
eat this real quick thank you we gotta save stocks man wait
are you okay where is he what the fuck was that I don't
fucking Don't worry.
I have shields.
Oh, I'm the one shooting.
I'm fucking stupid.
Okay, I fucked up my shield.
I didn't realize it was a one use.
Where's our stocks then?
Oh!
His cart is a bot.
It's a bot.
Okay.
Are you sure?
How do you have so many heals?
I don't know.
I just found them.
Guys, I do not think that was a bot.
That guy shot me too good.
he shot me too well yeah grammar's important turkey bird oh
shit I just I just goofed all over that whoops so
inconsiderate wait where is the card where's my man's ID
card there's a guy right here oh wait there it is a guy's ID
card you can reboot him but I'm here the fuck is happening
oh my god wait that's another team
how do i jump i am so low right now
no no we were so close dude if only ben if we were on my
server bro i feel them all arm on your server.
What do you mean?
I joined your party.
Um, um.
Kali?
What do you mean?
Dude, if I had to clean my mouse pad, bro?
It's over.
That's on you.
You had many, you had so much time to clean your mouse pad
before we hopped on Fortnite.
What was the last time you got a mouse pad, huh?
What do you mean?
I have one right now.
I mean, like, a new one.
I didn't buy mine like a couple of months ago.
I bought a new one a couple of months ago.
You know, some people change out their mousepads like
monthly?
What the fuck?
And their mice.
Okay, but they're like, but like, that's their life, though.
Every day they play, they like, play FPS.
Yep, isn't that fascinating?
Imagine buying like new shoes every month.
I mean, that's what people do.
That's their new shoes.
That's literally their new shoes.
Oh my God, you're so right.
on kicks they spend money on oh there's people with like 10
mice too i never thought about that way until now i don't
think that's because like what i think it depends on if
they're i think it's most if they have glass pad they don't
like they don't like uh what's the word they don't rotate uh
mouse pads that they're using glass pad because it's easier
to clean but if it's like fabric or something then that
makes sense my glass pad wouldn't last me a day bro i spill
all the time what do you mean if it's a glass pad you just
wipe it what do you mean well like over time it'll be like
all grimy oh i guess so when it slips through the cracks and
stuff i mean that makes sense yeah that creases
you drive the bus yeah it's it's the player that's the bus
driver so they're Wait, it's you!
You're thanking me real quick.
Go ahead.
No.
Press B.
What is it?
No.
I don't think you're doing very well.
Right now.
You're not driving very well.
I just hit three in a row.
That's all I'm saying.
I hit all of them.
Mm.
Could have been better.
You're going to like to wonky land?
Dude, I hit all of them.
You know, a good job, gully.
The ride doesn't hurt anybody.
The ride was pretty bumpy.
That's all I'll say.
Yeah.
It's pretty bumpy.
I play on 800 DPI with a one in-game sense, bro.
The smoothest, like, driving.
I don't know.
I got a little bit Karstic there, so I'll be, like, a...
I think that's, like, a three-star, honestly.
If I have to give you some stars there.
Are you giving me the Uber rating?
Yeah, if I have to give it Uber rating, I think that's,
like, a three-star review.
What is this?
Light fuse.
What?
Oh, it shot items out.
Both got it.
I somehow took damage from the bus, like landing.
Wait, what?
How?
I'm going for this fight.
Just really clumsy.
Yeah, see, this is why you got a three star.
A real bus driver wouldn't have that happen.
It was my first time driving a bus, okay?
Oh, and so you risked our lives?
our lives on that your first time driving a bus if you ever
think and you ever think about how like there's some amateur
pilots who like um yeah fly their planes for the first time
with passengers so that's crazy they're like a trial what
wait do are they are the passengers notified that they're
they're probably not you know oh oh wait there's someone
near us where i got the footsteps icon they're in wait
they're in the house they're literally in the house they're
outside the house now Oh, I see them.
I'm so late right now.
Oh, they're still in the house.
They're so confused.
What the fuck's your shot?
Oh, that's a...
I thought that was you.
Wait, where are they?
It's right here.
I'm like so confused.
I'm like...
Oh.
I'm here now.
Oh, shit!
What's this?
I fucked up.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I mean...
on me oh my god there's wait there's two people on me
there's a team another team on me i have no ammo bro like
i'm dead okay it's fine it's fine oh no it's no longer fine
i don't know if these people are on the same team together
but i think they are not i think they are dude you got this
They won't know that I'm on the roof.
How would they know?
I think they know.
No, they have no idea.
How would they know?
They're running away.
They're gonna go fight another team now.
Wait, where's Arthur?
Wait, he left us.
He doesn't like us.
I mean, oh no, SpongeBob.
SpongeBob!
Splash drop!
Dude, imagine he just gives you away.
Yeah, he just...
Oh?
Oh, he has the tracer.
Oh!
Bro, what?
Hello?
Oh, now he's in Zoom.
Oh my god.
Oh no, his teammate's gonna come over now.
His backup.
take the uh no okay nice yeah all right i'm on my little see
you later see you later what the you have shenron this this
might be the best game ever mercy overwatch riding shenron
this is Sabrina carpenter oh my god It's fine.
It's fine.
I got Sabrina Carpenter.
That's all I have at it.
It's fine.
That's right.
I got her again.
You didn't know Sabrina Carpenter.
Sabrina Carpenter is like a staple.
She's like a staple in Fortnite.
She has like a Christmas version of her too.
Could I...
Can I control something?
What?
I didn't know who Serb Marina Carpenter was until Fortnite.
You don't know H-O-T-T-O-G-O Bum-Bum, my, my, my, my I
should have logged into, like, Fortnite one day, or, like,
she just came up with my Fortnite page.
And I was like, why is there just a white woman in Fortnite?
And I was so confused.
Oh, wait, is this Ice Space video?
Alright, guys, guys, guys.
This is the Ice Space video.
This is why Sherford doesn't want to play with us anymore.
This is one of the top The top two reasons Why he doesn't
want to play with us anymore And I don't understand why I
think we tried our best Golly Oh sorry H-O-T-T-O-G-O isn't
Sorry it's I'm thinking about That's the other girl I forgot
her name That's the other white woman Sorry they got popular
at the same time Oh it's the It's the one about coffee.
Sheparone.
No, no, I meant the other song from Sabrina Carpenter.
The one about coffee.
Yeah, espresso.
Espresso.
Yeah.
Wrong white woman is so funny, Brun.
I had that happen in Rivals where I was trying to swap the
cloak and dagger and I chose invisible woman.
It was already too late to swap because I jumped through the
portal and I was like, oh shit, moment I'm sad oh don't they
like all look the same there's like there's so many there's
so many so many blonde women I lose track
dude I'm watching this clip again I know it's great it's
just like happy memories how horrifying is it to see I spies
fucking unsheathers like katana and just murder us She's a
baddie!
Oh shit.
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna grab water real quick.
You can go talk to my chat.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
I can do that, I think.
Hello chat room.
Hello.
Are there emotes in YouTube?
What's up?
Hi.
Hey.
Waiting, judging?
Uh-oh.
Do you have games on my phone?
Yeah, bro.
Hop on Umamusame.
Um, follow my profile.
I have a nine spark strength, uh, scene sky.
Um, okay.
Never mind.
This guy said no.
Thoughts on the collab?
I freaking love Overwatch!
Bye!
wait why is it just us two again what happened to our third
he's right here it's impala oh impala oh i just see it sorry
i i didn't recognize him he's a dog wait he dropped wait
impala left us where we left him dude he's on a freaking
mission yeah he's like what are these losers why'd
you say losers with an ass that's plural yeah what do you
mean we're losers here you ever hear someone say speak for
yourself we're losers together that's why we're that's why
we're playing with each other dude I just said like but the
spare GMO bro
golly if golly we have no one else to play with us dude
grown-ass man playing a Goli is the only two that will play
with each other.
Nobody else took our invitation.
Goli.
It's just us.
Because we're losers.
Goli.
We're losers.
Nobody wants to play with us.
But it's okay.
Wait, maybe.
Stick together.
Yeah, wait, wait, wait.
how many pleading emojis did you put i put a lot i think we
should do oh what is this collect do you think we're big do
you think we look too pathetic though if we put more dude
nothing's more okay you can't say no to two pleading yeah
but like but like do we think we look a little pathetic
though or do we just have nothing to lose anymore i mean do
you do you care because
I'm straight up, bro.
I don't give a hoot.
Play with us or we'll spam you.
I don't understand why people don't want to play with us.
I think we're pretty cool people.
Maybe we're just too cool and they're intimidated.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, you're right.
Maybe we are too cool.
Yeah, maybe they're just intimidated by how cool we are.
You know, it's not...
Wait, this guy found your pistols.
Wait, where?
Where?
where oh my god over there I need that all right all right
you said maybe we're too cool intimidating yeah I think
that's it what's the coolest thing about you um that I'm an
anime girl I think that's pretty neat and that we will save
our teammate in fortnight I think that's also pretty cool to
make her oh yeah do you remember what she had a vocal for i
think he's fighting a bot there's always a bot no it's just
a bot it was one guy i mean we could fight her and then get
items shoot her oh shoot her i'm why don't you shoot her
dude i'm pretty scared you shoot her look at her she could
she's like ice spice bro you want me to shoot her so I can
aggro her and die.
No, I would never.
I know you.
No, no.
Do you, though?
Dude, you're going to set me up.
Do you know?
Do you actually know me?
I think so.
All right, what's the color of my eyes?
No, when's my birthday?
Green.
When's my birthday?
Yeah?
Hold on.
Oh, you're going to Google?
You're going to Google.
When did Doki birthday debut computer computer analyze the
situation kowalski analyze all right we got mr cucumber 71
wait wait wait wait so the coolest thing about you you're
telling me is you're an anime girl yeah i'm not and i'm not
real and i'm not real wait i'm not real that's awesome if
you're not real real then who's in paula 646 yeah who's in
paula who is he are we like part of his simulation yeah you
ever think about like how he's playing solos by himself yeah
like and like we're the voices in his head yeah we're yeah
we're the voices in his head you just try talking to him see
what he says seven power gloves oh why don't you talk to him
my mic women aren't real i'm if i talk to him he'll think
i'm ai because women aren't real you have a voice changer
yeah no it's all in your head remember what it's all in my
yeah it's on your head i just feel fighting in front of us
yeah let me talk to them and let me do why is there a
payload in this
Dude, you killed Snoop Dogg.
Not Snoop Dogg!
Oh, what the fuck?
He's gonna get rid of this bot real fast.
Oh.
Hello.
Get out of here, furry.
Get out of here.
See you.
Are you like...
I don't know what to get rid of.
I guess I'll get rid of that.
Where do we go now, Gully?
Dude, I have no freaking clue.
Who's going to lead us?
No, it's not my game.
It's your game.
Dude, you're the coolest person ever.
You're so much cooler.
You're so cool.
No, dude.
You're like the coolest person ever.
Bro, you're the coolest person I ever know, bro.
Dude, you're the IGL.
you're the idea how can i show if i'm not real wait are you
ai oh hello um i don't recognize that problem can you
rephrase that
bro have you seen i need to show you a tick tock later
there's this one guy who like befriends like an ai and he
talks to him like a homeboy and it's like the funniest
fucking shit is he like serious about it or like is it just
a meme no like he he like talks to the ai like yo the what
i'm having for lunch and shit and then like the ai just like
roast him and it's so funny
oh wait that's a shotgun
what the that ai bot like freaked out i don't know you just
got three kills oh my god i don't know stop but he like did
like a like he just 360'd all over the place with like 800
like with what 3 000 60 to all over get rid of that do you
want these gloves no i have them too i don't need it where
are my where's my staff so i can get pocketed can i get oh
asking you shall receive all right golly dude is that all i
am to you just a freaking little pocket slut kill slay dude
no no no no kill slay don't call me that
you know what you are dude dude i'm you know what you are
don't don't leave your destiny what is that i decided
whether or not you live or die sure you do that was a real
gun oh yeah yeah i invited golly just so you could pocket
heal me why not a bazooka don't want this where's my pocket
healer where's my pocket hello how am i oh no oh wait they
might be real people they might actually be real people but
let me blow these guys up oh no that was nowhere near him oh
i fucked up
What are you being fucked up?
All right, good luck, Parker.
No, I wanted to kill him.
I knew we weren't winning that.
I wanted to kill him so bad.
Wait, is that another team or...
Oh, he killed you in that little room.
Oh, my God.
Those pussies using our staff are harder and staff.
Leveled up.
Up times two.
Awesome.
See, Gully, if you were pocketing me, I could have one V3'd
them.
But you brought your bazooka instead.
What did you learn today?
Gully, what did you learn today?
See, if you pocketed me there instead of using that bazooka,
Gully, if you pocketed me there instead of using that
bazooka.
You give?
Listen, listen, listen, listen.
Yeah?
There's nothing...
there's nothing more men love than explosions okay this is
just like a fact all right like i'm just letting you right
now like letting you know right now yeah it's like
how do you expect me not to shoot it you know like i have to
yeah but i i could you ever watch you ever watch
transformers you know like michael bay
big robots fighting each other yeah yeah you know yeah it's
freaking awesome that's true but then you could have
pocketed me and then i could have done the big explosion and
then we could have got the best of both worlds wait that's
ben 10.
wait we have ben 10.
wait what no wait oh my god do you know do you know ben 10
has has an op has a device that lets him become what the
fuck are you wait are you not a vamp bro are you uh oh my
god the hero is space why are you laughing at my car to
emote yeah don't laugh
wait our guy dropped our guy was he was already gone Don't
leave us So what you're telling me is you're not a vamp
Right, Doki?
It depends.
Are you in it?
I mean, I am a vamp, so like I guess I'm not
This guy's trying to shoot me out of the air Yo, kill him
Fucking freak Where is he?
Assassinate that guy I don't know where you are Wait,
there's a guy above you too Oh my god, okay We got to kill
him first.
I got reloaded.
Hey, so where are you?
Because there are two people in this house.
I'm a little scared.
I'm on the freaking way!
Okay, they think I have.
Alright, I killed one.
I killed gun show tickets.
There's still one more.
I don't have any bullets left.
Oh, it's added.
Wait.
Oh, you killed it?
Who's gonna tell the Ed and Eddie?
I'm a freaking murderer.
Oh my god.
How could you?
You can go to prison for that.
See if I care.
It was that badass.
I've been practicing.
Well, not anymore.
Yeah, was that freaking chills or what?
Oh my god, wait.
Benton's... Benton shot a defenseless man.
What are we gonna do?
He's just standing there, hitting that thing.
Yeah, because it gives us, like...
Pizza.
Pizza time.
I need to drink that.
Please don't take my...
Oh.
He took my heels.
That you get so sad, bro.
I said, please don't...
Your little...
Bro, your little ears just drooped.
Oh.
oh i mean that's all right i didn't want to get healing
anyway i didn't want to get those heels yeah it's okay yeah
it's all right it's not like i helped him i just shoot
everybody not weezy from toy story looking back is that you
buzz oh i didn't want that yeah i didn't want that anyway oh
my god he has a spongebob too
oh my god it's fit oh god i got shot by someone else oh i
got this dude that guy it's just his his ai friend i think
it's one across the river all right you guys got that he's
freaking dead we're gonna grab this gun
yeah we're gamers yeah that's why people don't want to play
with us because uh they're too scared to get like
intimidated they want to say no they're too scared to get
carried by us Yeah, exactly.
What?
So they don't even bother to join because they wouldn't even
be able to play.
They're like, oh my god, whenever we play with you guys,
like, you just kill everybody before we can even before we
can even do anything.
It's just not freaking fair.
What are you pinging?
I'm not pinging anything.
It's our other guy.
Oh, it's the kid.
Yeah, it's Ben 10.
Yeah.
They're all just so intimidated.
best all right i'm riding up why does he want to go there
what is over there wait our guy's so far god i go over to
ben 10.
there's a launch pad up here oh no we're saying that like um
they want to also be able to get kills but we're so good
that we just kill everybody in the lobby before they can do
anything you know they want their chance they know some
people just don't want to get carried i don't understand
also i just got dove at what the you know they're running
dive in fortnite yeah they're running dive in fortnite guys
wait what do you do something bro i just got dove done rev
do something wait this guy's shooting at someone peel where
are my peels
oh wait he got him bro he's just running at everybody yeah
he's oh i see something what oh there it is there it is all
right there's your destiny remember who you are i worry who
am i remember who you are looks at paws dude the freaking
way it's your destiny embrace it where is benton going holy
shit wait you can triple dash with the glove oh my god this
guy this guy no life's fortnight unironically he doesn't
play it whenever there's a cool new update he plays it every
day you guys are so fast wait oh my uh he doesn't play this
game as as a joke he plays it for real what the fuck do you
hear that oh my god I think it's the ice king speaking to me
oh yeah I told sure for like see log into this season
because like the ice kings on the battle pass yeah and he
literally just sent me a middle finger like I know I know
ice king couldn't bring him to oh my god what happened to
him where was it where happened to his whimsy yo what
happened to the light in his eyes i missed the old sure for
the the best widow maker in the world sure for the king's
row sure for the king's row sure for the los angeles
gladiators sure for what happened to him now he needs a one
day's notice to process the fact that he's playing Leaving
his roots!
Wait, I think I shoot...
That's me.
I missed the old sure for it.
Where's our guy?
This guy's been trying to hunt this NPC for 20 years.
Is he out of the map?
I don't know.
Wait, here.
Oh, a team is shooting the Ice King right below us.
Look.
Oh.
Alright, let's go.
you're shooting them by yourself so what can you and not
realize that i'm so sorry mika
oh my god he ran so far ben she's right over here ben what
the fuck
you guys chasing the other mika yeah we We got the other.
Wait, there were more than one Miku's?
I mean, I killed one.
Yeah, we got the other one.
I'm fighting the Ice King right now.
Oh, okay.
There should be one more.
The Ice King's gauntlets.
Dude, they're freaking mine.
I'm so sad.
I haven't found a pulse pistol yet.
Dude, we're going to get just these pulse pistols.
Is this the last thing we do?
But we still have to fight Atlético.
We got a damage boost, our boys.
I just realized, bro, that was supposed to be Spanish, by
the way.
Oh, wait, how do you pronounce it?
Atletico.
Oh, shit!
Okay, there's people there.
There's people there.
Dude, you just flew up.
I'm trying to heal you.
Wait, over here!
Alright, dookie.
Oh my god, he's trying to rest.
He's trying to rest.
I don't know if he got the rest.
Okay, I thirsted him.
What is that golden thing in the pool?
Oh my god, his thing is...
He's almost dead!
Wait, I'm gonna grab his stuff.
Wait, another stab?
For me?
For you?
Don't mind if I die.
Okay, what is this golden thing?
I'm curious.
I don't know, but I'm going over to Ben 10.
Ben 10 needs a- Ben 10 is an etope!
I was gonna fish for that golden thing in the pond.
We have to go back.
We gotta go get him.
Wait, oh my god, he went up.
Don't worry, Ben.
He's the hero from space!
whoa oh my god he's so far
i hit 69 nice wait where's our other where's ben he's up
here with me i got i got hybrid solid and no good yeah again
all right
my res Oh, where did he...
I wish there was VoIP.
I know.
So I can dab N6-7 at the same time.
Where the fuck is the guy killed?
Shrugging?
I'm down somebody.
I don't see him.
Oh, he shotguns him.
Oh, never mind.
He killed him.
Are we still trying to kill this Atlético guy?
um he's like all he's god god a let aletico
what is this overdrive grenade what does overdrive grenade
do dude i don't freaking know how do you not know i thought
you're a fortnite gamer turkey i haven't touched this game
in like six months yeah but you were born to play fortnite
it's your calling really yeah wait should i be it oh Yo,
should I be a Fortnite streamer?
Oh my, you should.
Oh my god.
To be fair.
When you're a creator code alone, you can make so much
money.
Yeah.
Wait, what is that?
That's good passive income.
Oh, it's like to support your favorite VTuber.
You can use a creator code.
It's good passive income.
Wait, do you have one?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's Jokey Bird.
And so what does that code do, actually?
Um, it doesn't do anything for you, but it does stuff for
me.
it basically gives me a cut of the skins basically whoa
that's awesome yeah that's pretty awesome so instead of
giving fortnite all your money you give me some of the money
hashtag ad hashtag ag hashtag not sponsored
on me i'm coming i'm so slow there's people on ben 10.
i was just down there
oh my god he's on the nimbus
it's the monkey wait where did the monkey go Goku's killing
me why do you heal he took my he took myself friends oh
that's not good
Oh my god, he actually killed you.
Yeah, he pumps me in the freaking back of the head.
He told me to look at the flowers, and I said, what?
I turned around and he shot me in the mouth, and I was like,
okay.
Where did he go?
Was Goku?
I got him.
Instant transmission.
But you killed Goku?
What?
That's right.
Wait, so...
i got him i gave a little dab too just for good luck i'm
spectating that kid i think he's playing on the controller
what is he no wonder he's so oh what he left us what he left
you bro he took my card he's raising me i was like what also
this car that he's driving is it's going like we were cool
it's going like a two two miles per hour it's like as flames
and like oh he's resin you yeah yo can you thank him for yo
thank you thank you so much i talk to him connect your
goddamn mic dude dude fuck it bro all right i got you have
you seen those have you seen those memes with like pochita
like being an alcoholic and he's like he's like yelling at
mock him up so i imagine you's like Dude, get out of your
goddamn mic, bro.
We're gonna be beating me on the side of the head.
Wait, there's people on us.
Okay, I'm going back.
Oh my god, it's scratchy!
Dude, give me, like, a sec or two?
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, where did scratchy go?
Oh, he's over there.
He's just, like, right above you.
Wait, where did my team go?
mate go oh he dropped down i'm running towards you though
dude i'm here wait welcome back i see them they're shooting
at us
oh my god what the did you do
giving them a piece of my freaking mind
holy he tried to crash me
Oh my god, I need to, like, go to storm.
Oh, this is bad.
No!
It's okay.
I'm so safe.
Gully, Gully, I'm so safe.
I'm so reasonable, Gully.
Gully, look at me.
Look at me, Gully.
Look at me.
Oh, you're not.
Never mind.
Golly, they'll never golly golly.
I'm so safe.
I'm so reasonable.
I got you bro.
I got you right here heroes never die Heroes Okay, why is it
keep stopping golly, please golly golly golly golly
I need a doctor I need a doctor stat I'm about to lose my
mind.
You've been gone for so long.
I'm running out of time.
How much use do you have left?
I need a doctor.
Call me a doctor.
Where's our guy?
Oh, there he is.
See your left.
He's like so hard to see sometimes.
There was like people here.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
There's people over there!
i didn't hit anyone with that nice there's no staff refresh
refresh your staff wait where literally right next to you
turn around what oh literally right there
oh my god they actually shield shielded him dude this guy's
bold he wants to go in there guy like just wants to what
I think he wants to do that, Doki Bird.
There's like a guy right here.
Dude, I'm so freaking scared.
Me too.
Benton!
Oh my god.
What the fuck was that?
Oh, thank you.
Team up there.
Oh, fuck!
Never mind.
Just nuke me!
Oh my god.
Is there a fucking team?
He actually is just nuking me It's okay.
I'm coming.
No, it's not don't do it.
Don't sack.
I'm doing it.
Six five I'm about to lose my mind You've been gonna crawl
bro crawl.
Oh I told you golly No, we had that we just need you to
crawl You have to help Benton
It's okay.
I believe I I'm watching Ben 10 right now Ben Tennyson bro
why is this gun no he's just nuking you you're so fucked
you're oh my god wait Ben 10's him he's actually him did
someone call a freaking doctor oh what happened I gotta read
the hood oh wait Dude, Vantan's not playing around.
Bro, you got to help him!
You got to help him!
Yeah!
Oh, my God!
Vantan is in it!
Vantan is...
Oh, he has got a warm back right.
Wait, you think he'll play with us?
Do you think he'll...
Do you think if we add him, he'll be our new friend?
Dude.
We don't need...
I'm rematching.
Someone signed this guy.
Yeah, so...
He wants to peel you off my house!
My God!
see see gully we're we are cool we are so fucking cool yeah
if no one wants to play with this ben 10 would play with us
ben 10 would fortnite yeah yeah shout out to ben 10 fortnite
the goat love that guy look at that better than any other
player we could have got God bless Ben 10.
God bless America.
Aren't you Canadian?
So bless a different country.
Yo, how come Canadians, do Canadians have like, okay, no
offense, but do they have any pride?
Like at all?
What do you mean?
Yeah, we do.
I've never heard someone say God bless Canada.
No, instead of that, say, oh Canada.
Oh Canada, our home and native land.
We bless our beavers and our caribou's and moose.
Wait, do you speak French?
I used to.
And then, like, I stopped speaking in.
I forgot.
What do you mean you used to?
I used to.
I had to learn French.
Like, in school, they, like, force you to learn French.
Yeah.
But then, like, I forgot my...
Well, I can still sort of listen to French.
listen to the where i don't have a gun i just don't know how
to i just when i speak it i need you to uh i need you to
look at the map and see where i'm at i kind of did you not
land with us oh i'm 1200 meters away i'll be there in a sec
keep up i can tell me more about tell me more about this
french french of yours so um so i don't speak french because
i have a really really big accent and it's not great.
I sound really dumb whenever I speak it.
Bro, the only French I know is Celevi.
Celevi?
Mm-hmm.
Wait, our guy is just killing the boss.
He's just chilling.
Dude, he doesn't fuck around.
Ben-Ten?
Oh, yeah, Ben-Ten doesn't- He's that kiddo.
Yeah, he's him.
There we go.
He's him.
I'm letting him have all the items.
Who is sure for why we should play him when we have is that
kid to go exactly you know what that guy should be you
should be a streamer You're so okay.
Wait, how do I type to him?
Where's the which is the button to type Enter is enter you
should be a streamer Kid you're so good Wait are you a
streamer?
You you might as well bake because you're good there you go
like that that glaze bro 10 years from now yeah 10 years
from now he's gonna have a he's gonna have a draw my life
and he's gonna be like guys thank you so much for 1 million
subs yeah this one never been possible if i didn't bump into
this player who asked me if i was a streamer because i was
so good at fortnite and that inspired me to that night i hit
shout out to dokeybird and then i'll and i'll be like i'll
be like in my armchair in in i'll be in my armchair my
retirement was like i knew that kid i i saw that kid i had
four i knew that kid she was in my birthday game and gary
gully and i now look at him he's it now has 13 million
subscribers then your grand killed your grandchildren gonna
be like yeah yeah Yeah, yeah, yeah, you definitely knew is
that kid zero?
Yeah, right, grandma.
Yeah, sure you did.
You definitely knew that is that kiddo.
Yeah, what else?
You were an anime girl?
Probably right, grandma.
I'm the birth and that's Ninja 2.
That's Trout 2.0, guys.
Uh-oh.
Alright, I'm putting on my costume.
Give me a sec.
Yeah?
What's the costume?
Go see.
Oh, Tracer guns.
Wait, where?
Where?
Right there.
Oh, nice.
It's like he knows.
He knows this is my gun.
Look at that.
See?
Ever since I complimented it, I glazed him.
You started giving me stuff.
You should start doing that too, Golly.
Nah.
Maybe you'll make more friends that way.
I'm a narcissist.
Golly, this is why we don't have...
Wait, is that an Overwatch?
That's an Overwatch pack.
Oh my god, I'm opening up the Overwatch loot box.
Wait, there's a bazooka.
Hey, Golly, there's your gun.
Wait, wait, give me that.
Yeah, right here.
Is it a bazooka?
Oh, it is.
It is.
hmm hmm and it has 10 bullets hmm yeah i mean there's
missiles next to it there's bullets next to the thing dude
we're so up wait is it a guided missile no what the fuck are
you doing i wonder where that missile came from wow it's
crazy i was wondering that bush shot it it was guided
missile who where is it gonna guide where is it good there's
no friendly fire my cursor bro aim use what hmm oh there's
another rivalry thing I'll take it start rivalry when I met
you in the summer I need like I need heals I think we both
need heals really badly bro you ran past the medkit no I
meant like shields Oh.
I got it.
Oh.
All right.
There you go.
I'm going to head to point.
I'm going to head to zone.
Oh my god, that kid is so far.
He's leaving us.
Dude, he doesn't have time for small timers like us.
I know.
He's like...
He's OTG, bro.
He's on the grind.
He's trying to grind like a hundred wins in one day every
day He knows every mob spawn like Like by the minute knows
where like people would spawn.
Oh my god kiddo Kiddo no kiddo no don't go down there.
No It's dangerous don't go there take this Kiddo kiddo
here's some shields kiddo Kiddo He doesn't want it.
He doesn't care.
He doesn't need...
He has a SpongeBob.
Yeah, we both have SpongeBob.
No, we both have SpongeBob.
I just realized I'm a nake, bro.
I don't have one.
Wait, wait.
Golly, look at this.
Golly, look at me.
Yeah.
Damn, we can be bushes together.
They will never...
They will never know.
They'll never know.
Hey, Golly.
How would they know?
We're literally in the forest.
We're literally bushes, bro.
Yo, we rock and push tonight.
Oh my god, he actually didn't know.
He was like, who is that bush that shot me?
He was so confused.
Dude, you killed Gia puppy.
Damn right, I did.
And I'll do it again.
Oh.
I hear gunshots.
Me too.
Like right in front of us.
We started a war.
I'm going to bazooka them.
Because I think it's funny.
Tommy?
Bro, they're just running away.
I'm pretty sure these are bots.
Oh.
No, bro.
We're just that freaking good.
You're right.
We're just so good.
Wait, kiddo's down!
Kiddo's down!
Kiddo!
my god I need it back up wait I don't have I just realize I
don't have heels what did you grab it oh no okay I'm gonna
leave I'm rolling another hill bye I'm rolling another hill
bye I leave I'm rolling down the hill wait oh my god stop
rolling we're in the open I swear to god I got shot I swear
to God, golly, if I get shot.
Dude, we're so bad.
We're so bad.
I'm going to try.
Wait, do we need...
Don't we need his car to respawn him?
We do.
I have meds.
I can go grab it.
Okay, because I don't have meds.
I have the car.
I have the respawn car.
Okay, okay.
Wait, let me get on.
I don't...
Yeah, why is there a bush right in the car?
I think we might get shot and we head over.
Guys, they could be anywhere.
Okay.
It's so winnable.
You got grab and go.
You got, oh my god.
You got, you got, grab and go.
You got to grab and go.
It's right here.
Gully!
I think you got it.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Are you rezzing?
Colleen!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
I just rezz!
Colleen!
I don't know how to rezz!
Colleen, you're supposed to rezz him!
Dude, you're still alive.
You got it.
I don't think you got it so far.
get out of the car when did you get out of the car cully you
were supposed to pick him up you think i oh i returned to
lobby accidentally no i dropped a little too early and i got
fucking gunned down like a dog wait we should we should add
him send him a friend request to see if he'll join us do you
think he'll join us you want to invite the kiddo yeah i'm
gonna see send them I'm gonna add I'm added I added recent
players I did it's okay we um it's in the you go to you
click your icon and then you go the plus side oh my God we
lost him he doesn't want to play with us anymore dude he's
like bro these guys fucking left me to die I can't believe
it he's probably like foaming from the mouth you guys are
freaking losers man I'm so sad I thought we were cool.
We blew it, Gully.
We fucking blew it.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I thought we were so cool.
Wait, look what you did.
What did I do?
I told you to grab it.
Why did you grab it, Gully?
Why did you grab it?
I did it again.
You drive people away.
Wait, someone said in chat, for future reference, you can
buy cards at the Revive Vehicles for gold.
So we did all of that for nothing.
No, no, we didn't do it for nothing.
You just didn't fucking grab him.
Oh, so this is my fault.
Yes.
You drove them away.
I drove them away?
You were the one driving.
You drove them away.
You were steering the vehicle as a bush.
How did I drive them away?
You could have.
You could have been there.
Nah, if I had my mercy staff, You guys all live.
That's true.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah, you're right.
Mm-hmm.
I wish kiddo would come back.
We're gone.
He's gone.
Let go.
Why are we so alone, Gully?
What?
Why do we keep driving people away from us?
Hold on, I think my monitor is a little blurry.
He's getting close to me.
I why am I so alone why don't why don't people why don't
people want to it's getting hard to see are you still there
dokey are you still the tears are just too much I thought
like I thought like We would be homies.
I said he was really good.
He should be a streamer.
Yeah, right, grandma.
You didn't know that, kiddo.
I knew him.
I swear.
I knew this guy.
Why is it raining indoors?
I live in the apartment.
How's the rain getting here?
What the fuck?
Dude, it's all over my face.
Dude.
Yeah, who installed his shower head above my desk?
I can't believe it.
That's our grief away.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Hey.
Whoa.
Wait, it's just us two.
Wait.
Wait, why are we still alone?
Wait, why are we in...
We're in trios.
Wait, why...
Wait, wait.
It's like the game's selling us something right now.
Maybe we could adopt a bot, an AI.
Wait!
Trooper stops streaming and he's still not playing with us!
DM him right now.
Pleading emoji.
We both DM him.
Pleading emoji, bro.
I...
Yeah.
wait where am i where are you i'm right above you look up
we'll go to the mansion go press tab look up little bro yeah
i can't believe it even even here nobody wants to be in her
lobby bro no one even even no there is there is a person
there is a person i saw don't worry they can't avoid us in
the lot they can't avoid shooting us
Do we have this?
Oh, he jumped near me.
How the freak.
Knock Kyle Reeves.
I don't even know.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're not Kyle Reeves.
Where did I drop?
Where did I down him?
Wait, I hear like four footsteps.
Oh my god, there's a lot of people.
I have one gun left, by the way.
and i'm worried that they're gonna raise all the people i
just down
they're all dead nice we did it freaking murder yeah yeah
look at that we don't need look at that we did it all by
ourselves yeah dude i don't know what i don't know what came
over me man something something inside of me just snapped
yeah yeah the anger overwhelmed me i just i had to prove
something you know yeah we had to prove something yeah Yeah,
yeah, we're like, because we're both losers, so we
understand each other.
Wait, no.
What do you mean we, bro?
Stop saying we.
He knows losers stick together.
Dude, stop saying, dude, stop saying we.
Yeah, all right.
All right.
Call another friend to play with us.
I bet you can't.
Oh, yeah?
How many friends rejected your invite?
Gully?
How many friends said no?
Where's my?
Gully?
Where's my bag?
How many?
How many friends said no to play with us?
Hyper-ventilating.
That's right.
You know what?
What?
Enough.
What are you going to do?
If no one will play with...
Wait, if they don't want to play with us...
Then no one will.
I'm killing the entire lobby.
Make them regret.
Make them regret ever leaving us.
That's it.
tv at the end of my name yes do it do it golly i'm a bush
dude lucky that's right never even this jug now i'm good oh
we gotta fill up your your thingy here no i'm good there is
a people on us yeah let me tell him soon where are they You
not see the little target?
Nope.
If I stand here, they'll just think there's a bush.
They'll just think there's a bush on the roof.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Footsteps!
There she is.
Wait, she's a real person too.
Wait, she's real.
Good.
Wait, someone dropping too.
Careful.
Wait, really?
On top of the hill.
I don't have an angle on this, Broly.
Is it how many people are on top of the hill?
I think it's only one.
Alright, watch this.
Watch it.
I'm gonna shot at.
It better be only one.
I think they dropped.
Yeah, there's three guys over here.
Yeah, they got rotated.
Yeah, they got left.
There's three guys over there.
You didn't expect the bush?
Wait, oh wait, that's Tracer.
Oh, shit!
I'm on the way.
Wait, they have Tracer from Overwatch playing with them.
That's cheating.
It's okay, we have Mercy.
Surely that's better.
They're like right behind here.
And I got a staff.
It's over.
Wrap it up.
Hey, um, I ran out of ammo.
I have zero ammo right now.
So I think we should leave.
We might have to leave, Gully.
I have no bullets.
I'm gone, Gully.
I'm very, very far away, Gully.
It would be a shame.
I really wanted to down that guy.
I downed him.
Nice.
Thirst him.
He's like a bajillion miles away.
Are you not a gamer?
I was tapping with an AR.
I am a gamer.
Yeah, thirst him.
I'm going to grab more ammo though what do you need um i
need just ran past an ammo box looking back yeah yeah also
there's people about to drop on top of us yeah but if they
drop that we'll watch oh i missed wait wait wait what we can
do that inside inside we'll wait again cool I told you!
I told you!
Just wait!
I hear this.
All we had to do was wait.
Wait.
Why can they just do that?
Don't worry, we have a scanner right here.
Now I'm gonna go back.
Wait, what if we shake it out less?
What?
What if we shake it out less?
What does that even mean?
Dude, what if we shake it out less?
yeah yeah yeah hey what is shake it out West dude good one
no no no no no no no I think people are here wait wait wait
wait let's just do this I just call myself jiggle peeking at
fortnite people um do you think they hear our emotes i think
they do wait i'm gonna stay here
they'll never know people never know oh wait they can hear
our emotes wait they must have heard our evo they actually
heard our he must have heard us shaking it out last year
it's over up the zones come in wait what the fuck okay
they're capping they're capping they're capping don't come
down don't come up don't come up don't come up don't come up
don't come up do not come up they're right here they're
right here it's two it's at least two it's at least two they
did the thing that i we did gully i'm gonna die gully
goodbye goodbye gully no they're coming We don't literally
murder you!
We murdered you!
Get a shotgun, bro.
It's over for me.
Oh my god.
You died to Genji.
Wait, that's the guy that I downed at the Ghostface?
That's not him.
Yeah, I guess that's why they actually waited up there for
us.
I can't believe it.
They actually camped us.
Like, we camped them.
It's so sad.
That's so sad.
sad siri plate desposito the accepted i i sent a friend
request and he didn't accept it guys he does not with you
bruce more report him
amk not participating that's right he broke our hearts get
reported
you haven't been there to kill someone that's email
That's fucked up.
Oh yeah.
Bro, I like the part of this emote where he just like points
at you.
Yeah, he's like, look at that.
That's for you.
That's for you right there.
He like winks at me?
Yeah.
He's like, remember me.
Wait, that is true.
Bro, if I had Genshi skin, I win.
Yeah, but you...
Invite a friend.
Then I'll get you a Genshi skin.
That's all you need to do, Gully.
Invite a friend.
Like, it referred to a friend.
If you look closer, you see that Gully lost because he
doesn't have a Genshi skin.
That's true.
Wait, we have Frieza!
It's over.
It's so over for the enemy team.
We have Frieza.
Bro, Lord Frieza.
You have cold hard killer.
It's cold hard killer.
Go fucking fix your mic.
Wait, hello?
You did not fix your mic.
Fuck.
Wait, unless I have like voice, oh I might have voice comms
muted, that's why.
I don't I don't know if they could hear me though like I
don't I have voice comms muted so I'd never I actually did I
didn't know that's like nobody talked to me because nobody
can bro you ever seen uh meet the robinsons you know yeah I
forgot who is he goob is the the sad boy he's like oh yeah
He's a bowler bowler hat.
Yeah.
He's like, hey goob.
Do you want to come over to my house?
Hey goob.
Bro, you are goob.
Nobody loves him.
All right, I want to see.
I can't.
Where is it?
Allow voice detection.
Wait, where?
Okay, there you go.
Voice chat.
Everybody.
All right, try talking.
Nope, it's not working.
No, it's not working.
You'll open my mic.
is i'm not doing you open my just do open my just to see if
it works all right hold on i wonder if kiddo talked to us he
did not say a single word wait do you have voice comms but
do you have voice comms open though yeah i could see that
they have a mic i just don't see oh the mic your thing he
says is muted yeah because i have push talk
Why are you so shy?
Wait, do I have Mike?
Let me check.
Yeah, why aren't you open Mike?
No, you should.
It's because I'm streaming.
That's different.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Miss privilege.
Yeah, I'm freaking privilege.
You better be sorry.
Well, excuse me, princess.
Let me go.
Let me go over Mike.
Do it.
Are you a pussy?
where is the yeah I guess oh fuck I threw the pizza down by
accident oh hey I guess I'll just take some pizzas I guess
I'll eat I'm trying to look for the push to talk where's the
push to talk guys I don't know I have an SMG I need a gun
why is my push to talk I don't see it on the keyboard when I
met you in the summer a movement weapon hover vehicle it's
just all vehicles fall guys all guys there's oh
communication there we go my blind oh wait no it is
your voice chat all right everybody push a talk
i'm going in
oh i'm getting i'm getting shot there you have the one with
the bots are you getting shot from behind you're fine
There's two teams.
What the fuck is happening?
They're so healthy.
Yeah, but there's two teams fighting each other near me.
Yeah, but it's two bot teams.
You can't lose to that.
They're AI.
They haven't learned your playstyle yet.
Oh, that guy's definitely not AI.
That guy's definitely not AI, by the way.
The one that drove away.
Bots don't know how to use the car.
I can't believe Mika drove away, bro.
Come on, head over.
Wait, where did he go?
Yo, yo, can you hear me?
No?
Well, my mic is activated now, so...
Oh, I saw it.
Bye.
Goodbye, little boy.
Goodbye, sapphire.
Oh, hey, bazooka.
It's your favorite.
want to trust me with the bazooka yeah of course i trust you
we could go wrong do you remember what happened last time
you're right all right i'll say wait vendetta flopper what's
that what is that i don't know sounds cool let's see it i'll
just say both of them by accident oh well i guess that's not
cool anymore i'm gonna go do another rivalry i want them all
to come to us come on guys all of you team oh wait wait miku
i think you're running into this uh bro angel wolf i didn't
even realize we have a rivalry wait well that's you well
you said let's go team and i was expecting like high octane
gameplay you know yeah but you didn't go at the time i told
you to go wait we're stone cold killer no you weren't i did
not see you i'm going to wait where's stone cold killer go
too dude he's all the way over there i'm following him wait
you're not following me turns around all right well i'm
following him right now so why are you turning around see
this is i can't believe you want to help your teammate gully
see this is why nobody wants to play with us you keep
driving people away this is that's right that's right
remember That's right, Gully.
That's okay.
I'm here to fix you.
I'm here to help change you to the better.
If only I was more considerate.
It's alright.
Everyone makes mistakes.
Wait, there's people like...
Wait, who shot us?
Some little dude over there.
Where is over there?
What is this?
Oh.
That answers my question.
it's like over here
over yonder over Sean alright let's go oh you're having a
new loot box
alright here we go um it appears they're not over yonder
anymore well there is a target over there oh well I guess
we're not oh okay but what if they're in front of me wait
they're right Yeah, they're out there walking over to us.
Did you get him?
He's behind a fucking...
Nope.
It's Miku!
Angel, wait, wait, wait, don't kill him!
Don't kill!
No!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, we gotta help him.
There's another Miku.
There was more than one Miku.
Why is my team running all the way to the floor?
Where's the other Miku?
Oh!
I accidentally fell and I'm one HP.
Bro, this shotgun is so fucking ass.
Um, I lost all my HP because I fell down.
That's a little...
You broke your ankles?
Yeah.
On skid?
I might have.
Okay, I can only take one shot.
So I'm gonna try.
There's a bush, bro.
There's a bush.
Oh my god.
This is my one shot!
Bro, that shogun is so ass.
Oh my god.
It was just one bullet.
It was literally...
I feel...
I don't want to play with Frieza.
I don't want to play with Stone Cold Killer.
I don't think I fuck with him anymore.
I don't think I fuck with Stone Cold Killer.
You might not be as stone or cold as I expected.
what happened to your friend the the wordle one i think she
like i think she's afk i think she got stuck at her final
guess in war yeah she's stuck she's trying to figure out the
last wordle would you do wordle today no i don't do wordle
um why not i don't do because it makes me feel stupid is
that what you want to hear it was that because i'm just a
dumb dumb because it makes bitch is that what you want me to
say golly is that is that think about all the words you can
like add to like your vernacular like what like what golly
like what when would you ever use the words you learned from
word oh when name me three instances where you use a word
that you learn from word oh the word quaint hmm yes hmm oh
wait wait wait she's here wait she's okay she's back okay
okay hop on we don't know how long canceling queue yeah
cancel how long we are gonna play because we have been
playing for a while
all right since i got us a third you have to buy me a skin
gully you have to buy me a skin That's right.
Like a gillianair.
I want, and you too, you are a gillianair too.
I do.
Gully, I want the Keanu Reeves skin.
You gotta buy me a skin because I got us a third.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Check this out.
Yeah.
You rocking with it?
Wait, I'm in the shop.
Okay, now buy me the skin.
We can be, we can be Keanu.
We can be Keanu Reeves together.
Golly, golly, we can be Keanu Reeves together.
And since I brought the third person to join us after we've
been begging multiple people.
I feel like I won other than two of us.
Maybe there's only one loser here.
Do you want me to give my pocket pick?
Look, all right, how about us?
You buy me the Keanu Reeves skin and I'll buy you the Genshi
skin.
You buy me Keanu Reeves skin and I'll buy you the Genshi
You're a gajillionaire.
You too!
Listen, listen, listen, listen.
Yeah.
I have 300 V-bucks to my name.
How many do you have?
I have 200 V-bucks to my name.
There's bullshit!
I have 200 v-bugs to my name right now.
I just opened your screen.
I have 200, yeah.
You have 3800.
No, I have 200.
Where do you see that?
I don't see that.
No, I don't.
Where is it?
Go ahead and click that.
Click that gift Genji button.
Go ahead.
You go ahead and click the gift, Keanu Reeves button.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stumble on your words.
Yeah, no.
Oh, oh, just because English is my second language, you're
going to make fun of my English right now?
Well, jokes on you.
English is also my second language.
English was actually my first language.
You're a liar.
No, I said slash JK.
I said slash JK.
The five second rule.
Unfreaking believable.
You know what's unbelievable?
Not gifting me a Keanu Reeveskin.
You have 3800 where does it say?
I don't see it.
I don't see it right now.
Where does it say that?
Steve, where does it say that?
I don't see it.
I'm so sorry.
I forgot.
I forgot that like you just don't know how to read it.
I'm so sorry.
It's so insensitive.
It's just not here.
Yeah, exactly.
Now you're insensitive.
I'm going to send you a screenshot because I feel so bad.
I feel so, so bad.
Here you go.
so that's you like see you have enough you have enough for
the hiana reek skin no no you just screen you just
screenshot your own account no that was the screenshot of
it's a screenshot of your own account gully that's not how
that works that's a screenshot of your own account you
clearly have enough here i'm gonna screenshot it again there
there's that's you see i can't would photoshop your meat
bugs.
I can't believe you're that desperate, Gully, that you would
photoshop your own Fortnite account just to not buy me a
Keanu Reeves skin.
I'm even doing such a great deal for you.
I get you the Genji skin and you get me the Keanu Reeves
skin.
That is like the art of the deal.
You can just buy the Keanu skin.
No, you buy, you give me the Keanu skin and I gift you oh oh
i get it i get it yeah yeah you get it right i get it now
yeah you just want to be gifted it you don't want to buy for
yourself yeah but also you want someone to give a exactly
exactly because you don't you know that is so sad bro gully
when was the last time someone gifted you a skin gully when
was i'm gonna start crying when was the last time that's the
we only When was the last time that someone gifted you a
skin, Gully?
Have you ever felt that moment before?
Bro, are you about to have two aliens holding each other to
a PNG moment?
Don't you want to know what it feels like to have someone
that actually cares about you?
Don't you want to know?
Bro, this is going to...
Bro, this is the best one.
This is the best one.
Wait, let me save that.
Oh, so, yeah, we're going to use Code Doki Bird to have the
similar moment like us.
Toxic codependent behavior.
That's what Fortnite did to us.
That's what two plus hours of Fortnite did to us.
Okay, but you got to remember, we've won more times together
than we've ever won with Sherpa.
That is so true.
guys maybe sure for was maybe sure for was the sandbag all
else this is what goalie said he was the weakest link out of
all of us also perhaps thank you for the 10 gift the ships
thank you thank you so true this is this is golly and I
right now two aliens holding each other bro gift me Genshi
bro gift He cried.
Bro.
You know how sure Ford wouldn't be catching strays?
If he was in our group right now playing Fortnite with us.
He could defend himself if he wanted to.
Yeah, he could have easily defended himself.
But he chose to leave us.
He was like, you got to do one business day if you want me
to play with you.
You know what, Gully was like, when you went, when you were
running, I was like, I'm down for whenever.
And then, and then, look at that.
We're down for whenever.
We literally hopped on Fortnite together.
Well, he hopped on later.
I don't need one business day.
He doesn't need one business day.
When a homie asks, we hop on.
We don't ask questions.
We're here.
Wait, wait, wait.
Doki.
Yeah.
Someone summons you.
What do they need to summon you?
What do you mean?
Like, what are the...
need to gift me a kiana reuskin and now i'm there and i'll
and i'll be there
brim for me it's a 32 ounce modello yeah um second you ports
um and a fruit roll up yeah and you can summon me that'll do
it thoughts on that
that's that's how you summon him oh my god
all right did Pia so hot from from the passion from the
passion I'm wearing a sweater I feel like I have to take it
off now yeah oh my god that's why that's why we've been
losing we haven't won in a while this is why you've been
losing you wore the sweater I didn't even notice dude I
didn't even notice I've been having so much fun playing
overwatch fortnite who would have known dude you guys could
also play overwatch fortnite yeah code dokeybird code
dokeybird to support your favorite streamer aka dokey a.k.a
dokeyster yeah that's me dude i should bro i should get paid
for this for like doing ads your payment is paying out with
me in fortnite
poison out gully if a snake bites your if a snake bites
major for on the dick would you suck the poison out to save
his life okay so knowing sure for yeah you would kill
himself no no he would poison himself with snakes like
regularly so he can like become immune that's true he would
micro dose and he's a he would microbial some poison also
it's not poison it's venom yeah so that's how I don't need
to do anything because he's he's trained his body.
You're right.
Yeah, he would he would micro dose on venom He would he
wants to be like immortal or some shit Yeah, that goes a
freak.
Yeah, so you don't you would be a homie and let him let him
like micro dose on venom What a real homie I mean
Fuck it, bro Can't believe what would you do what would I
do?
i'd watch okay because i know someone else would would suck
it so i'll be there in the corner watching wait so you're a
watcher you just like to watch i just want to watch yeah
what color is your what color is your chair bro um it's the
herman miller i you know you have to be comfortable you know
oh you got money i don't know how long you sitting here and
watching.
I got the Herman Miller.
And she's feeling extra.
She's got the lazy boy.
I got, no, I have to, what was it called?
I have the Logitech Herman Miller chair.
It's a thing.
Yeah, the Logitech Herman Miller chair.
Yeah.
It's the gamer chair.
Did you see, did you see that I think it's Toyota.
They're like selling like a $3,000 car seat.
It's like a legit car seat.
Okay, you might as well be living in that car like in that
car at that point no it's like a it's it's for your home for
your desk it's like oh oh like a car seat that you can sit
at home i think car seats are that comfortable though but i
don't think car seats are that comfortable like not long
term wise well doki you don't drive so like that's true what
does matter yeah it's true i like to be driven i like to be
chauffeured bro you're just bougie like that we actually
blocked kiddo because I reported him.
I accidentally blocked him because I sent him another friend
request.
I sent him another friend.
Wait, where...
Doki, where's your friend?
She's updating her game.
Yeah, it's going to take like 10 years.
Okay, look.
Okay, cue up.
I'm cueing up.
Hold on, hold on.
I gave him mixed signals.
What?
Oh my god, you're level 30 now.
Remember when you made fun of me for being level 29, now
look at you.
You know, Doki?
Yeah.
That just shows, like, my innate gaming prowess, okay?
It's that much of a gamer.
Yeah, I am.
You know life is as much as me.
Yeah.
oh
yo golly i'll gift the chat so get the skin look golly
that's awesome someone someone's sponsoring it from chat
yeah someone's spot someone's dropping you a sponsor it's
like the hunger games the joculous
it's like the hunger games yo yo you entertained the dragons
and elf you got a sponsor with the battle royale the jokie
hunger game
that's awesome look at that look at that golly you got
yourself the gengis skin Dude, and I didn't even have to
invite anyone.
You just got a sponsor.
Alright, we're ready.
Oh my god, we have K-pop.
K-pop demon hunters.
We have, what's her name?
I forgot her name.
I've never seen it.
Wait, you never saw K-pop demon hunters?
I like the songs.
The story is, like, pretty simple, though.
The songs are very catchy.
It's just very, like...
Like, it's not, like, the best story ever type deal, but the
songs are just super catchy.
Yeah, how much is the skin?
Gotta help Gully give Kiyonu to Tokyo.
He got sponsored Gully.
I can't believe it.
They really want to see this exchange champion.
Wait, where the fuck are we landing?
I don't know what I'm following.
I'm landing here.
I don't care.
sure sponsor for sponsor there's a lot of people here okay
i might get shot there is a possibility that i will get shot
i live in your youth but i don't look out there's a country
oh they shoot at least hey they're shooting other people
i'll grab this oh i hear people near us all right let's rock
and roll i see them they're in front of me
oh my god how do they have shields already i feel so naked
oh it's because of this wait there's a there's a blue gun
there's a blue gun right here yeah well i found a freaking
mercy staff oh okay never mind you don't need this oh yeah
well um i found this that's right that could have been you
whoa wait where's his buddy oh my gosh jake is he chasing me
oh that's you he's solo he's solo wait wait wait wait wait
let me oh wait what the fuck wait wait it's tracer I got him
no stormtrooper he's right here oh my god I'm getting shot
by so many people it's okay dude any avatar is shooting you
from the but careful.
I know.
Oh my god.
Come over here.
That shotgun was so fucking loud.
Oh shit!
It's Steve.
Oh my god, Steve!
No!
Oh my god, these are the gates!
They're- They're so low.
Where's- Where's our teammate?
Sabry's steak.
Wait, he's coming.
He's coming.
Just ping him.
Just ping the enemy.
pick him pick him he's got this savory steak remember kpop
wait that's different wait that's a teammate wait how come
we catch go leave that's the team right there diva tracer
where's my overwatch duo where is he you know what what you
know what yeah how did she get here once this wait they're
gonna residence how did she get here we have why is she so
far how did she get here
she teleported how did wait what the fuck when oh there
she's gonna you think she's coming for us i don't know i
don't i don't think she's coming back golly no can we just
leave her not again you know everybody left us we might as
well leave her too golly leave her this is it wait but golly
leave her all they do is disappoint us I left all right oh
I'll wipe my hands I don't know how to leave it oh it's the
gear and then leave it's our turn to leave people all right
you got sponsored so congratulations golly wait wait wait
wait dude do i get dude diva i'm giving you genji you're you
don't get the the sponsor says genji they said genji all
right all right now you can gift me kiana reaves you can
give me kiana reaves now Am I actually gonna have to swipe
for this fucking thing?
You didn't give me Keanu Reeves?
Wait, that guy talked.
Wait, what?
Don't listen to him.
Get out of that lobby.
I did, but like, they talked.
What did they say?
It was a grown-ass man, bro.
I hope so.
It's 1.30 in the morning.
That kid's gotta go to...
Oh, wait, no.
It's a fried...
No.
Yeah, no.
Wait, you said Keanu Reeves, but that's Johnny Silverhand.
That's Keanu Reeves as Johnny Silverhand.
Yeah, it is.
That's Keanu Reeves.
He's wake up, wake up samurai.
No, that's Johnny Silverhand.
No, whenever Keanu Reeves comes to the shop, I'll get it for
you.
But that's that's Johnny.
Okay, I want Johnny Silverhand.
That's my second choice.
You can't just change.
Yes, I can.
That's my second choice.
You can't just change your mind.
Yes, I can.
chat room is that johnny silverhand or is that kiana reeds
he's trying to ride out the deal well we're both getting the
deal oh my god look at us rujin wo kenru kure look at us who
is that it's john wick that's john reeds it's kiana for me
it's kianu silver hand exactly all right gully bring out
that credit card i can't believe i'm swiping for this bring
out that credit card garbage how dare you say that about
kiana reeves dude if you keep this up i'm not gonna use
kodoki bro if you keep this up wait where's my wallet
can't believe it after everything he sacrificed for us
After everything Keanu's done for us.
He literally saved the world.
Also, PMP is at 30%, guys.
I will say, I don't know how much longer I can play.
I will say that, chat.
I don't know how much longer.
I've been playing Fortnite for five hours.
I've been playing Fortnite.
Wait, that Kianu Nuked the city to save all of us Yeah, he
did it for all of us
Do it for Kianu We can do this, I believe Oh, she's at 64
now?
Okay, okay there, I can I can survive
I will do it
For Kianu
hold the line look at my wallet in my car you left in oh did
you get it now yeah okay alright I'm ready I can't wait to
see it this is the most I've ever played Fortnite I think
this this has been longer than than two times you played
Fortnite together Gully are you having fun?
of course I am I freaking love Fortnite X Overwatch I love
Overwatch X Fortnite collab!
Oh my god!
I love it so much!
I'm gonna give my friend Kenji skin!
Oh my god, but mine's Keanu skin.
Where's your little buddy?
Do you not have a little buddy to run around with you?
You think Fortnite would like...
Or like what?
You think Fortnite would pay me to like VA one of the
commercials?
I think you have to pay Fortnite.
Wait, I have to pay them to do it?
I think you might have to pay them.
Wait, why?
You think you're the only one that wants to be in Fortnite?
No, I don't want to be in Fortnite.
I just want to, like, voiceover, like...
Oh.
They're, uh...
They're little commercials, you know.
Oh.
Blogging to Fortnite is playing with your friends.
Death, treasure, guns.
Mercy staff.
Yeah, baby.
Yay!
Play with your friends.
Awesome.
We can do this.
All right, but where's your friend, though?
It's at 64% now.
I think she's just lying to you.
No, she sent me a screenshot.
There's no way.
She's just not.
She has 64.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, yeah.
What if you're wrong, huh?
You want to bet?
You want to bet, Gully?
You know what?
If she shows up, if she shows up, you have to buy me
another.
You have to buy me an emo You can't just do it bro You are
you are doubting me you're doubting my word you're doubting
my word right now I just know I just know you were the worst
fucking like elementary school kid bro Like actually like
the worst how what kind of elementary student was that huh?
The yeah, well if I do baby baby like Yeah, well I'm better
than you by infinity times eight yeah well boys go to
jupiter to get stupiter yeah i mean that's true i'm glad we
both think alike buddy i'm glad we both agree no no i was
impersonating it it's different no no we were sharing the
same wavelength you're impersonating me you're impersonating
me because you want to be me dude i'm nothing like you yeah
i know i'm sorry like you now you're just lying to yourself
Why would I ever want to be a bird of all things?
Because you can fly.
Wait, I didn't think of that.
It's genius.
Hold on, I might need to add some wings to my character.
Where's my skin?
Dude, I've never like...
I have to input my credit card information.
Okay.
What's the last three digits of your card?
You want me to double check for you?
i can help you double check if it's correct i thought you
can't read i can look at numbers i sent you two screenshots
of vpux and you can tell them apart that's not true because
that was your account you sent me screenshots of your own
account gully and then you try to photoshop that remember
you can't gaslight me i'm not gaslighting i'm trying to tell
you the truth gully i'm your only friend right now you think
i would gaslight
Bro, you got jokes.
Yo, you got jokes, bro.
You're funny.
Thank you.
I think I should be a streamer.
What do you think?
I think you should go live right now.
I think I should go live right now, guys.
Dude, bro, you should be streaming to sit on TikTok live.
Oh, my God.
You're so sure I should be doing on Instagram real right
now.
Imagine the real potential.
Oh, my God.
I imagine.
The rev?
Damn.
Hold on, I got a...
Oh, yeah.
That code.
Wait, what was the code again?
It's Doki Bird.
Is that capitalized or all lowercase?
You can do either.
That's the great part.
Can you check how many people, like, actually use that code?
No.
But I just know how much I make off of the code.
Oh.
it would be cool if like monthly they like send you like x
people used your code last month that'd be pretty awesome
you should add fortnite about that
at fortnite at fortnite at fortnite
i think by the time you buy me that skin our third will show
up
bro you too much bray you too much bray thank you I wonder
about if one day I can be a streamer, Gully.
Do you think it's possible?
I think so, bro.
I can't believe I just bought V-books.
Would you be my first subscriber?
Dude, I have your stream open on a different tab as we
speak.
Oh, my.
Wait, but I'm not streaming, though.
I've never streamed before.
No, did I got you, bro?
Yeah?
I'm going to have a founder badge and everything.
But I'm on YouTube.
We don't have that.
Oh.
Do you only stream on YouTube?
I do Twitch sometimes.
Only like if I like have...
If it's not on my schedule, I just rip it on Twitch.
He's watching from the future.
Because I mean, you think in the future I'll be a successful
streamer?
And I'm in the future now.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Do you think if I became a successful streamer?
Shuffle will play with us.
I think so, bro.
I think so.
Do you think he'll play with us if I become successful at
that?
I think he would actually fuck with us by then.
Do you think he'll fuck with us?
Okay, so was I supposed to put the code before I buy the
V-bugs?
No, you were supposed to put the code before you fucking buy
the V-bugs.
You're joking.
That's okay.
You can still put the code on.
I'm buying more.
You're gonna buy for...
Yeah, for our next Fortnite, like for our next Fortnite
collab together, right?
Wait, was I actually supposed to put the code?
Yeah, yeah, you can buy V... Yeah, because then the code,
the...
It also goes towards V-bugs, too.
How come they didn't tell me to do it?
That's how they get you.
Wait, so how do I... So it's over?
And then you go... No, and then you go to shop and you
support a creator.
and then you click dokeybird you see the bottom right it
says support a career oh i see i see him yeah and then you
write dokeybird i got you new search applied it wait a
minute wait a minute yeah and then you buy the skin i just
realized what you're doing what what am I doing you're good
you're good I don't know what you're talking about I'm not
just trying so hard to teach you how to work the how to work
the shop okay yeah exactly i'm teaching you gully so then
you won't have to you won't have to worry about it later
also where are you like on my it's just dokey bird what do
you mean you clicked it see you click it and you click gift
party member.
You get to be a party member.
I see you.
Why can't you see me?
Hold on, hold on.
You can also enter display name.
Gully.
Oh, I see.
There you are.
There I am.
Alright, wait.
She's ready.
See, by the time we figured it out, she was ready.
Two aliens holding each other?
Dot PNG.
That's us.
We did it, guys.
We fucking did it.
Did you get it?
Wait, where, how do you...
Oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
How do I accept it?
I forgot how.
How did you accept the gift last time?
It just appeared on my screen.
It just showed up.
Yeah.
Are you sure?
Why don't I have it?
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Did we get scammed?
I think you might need to re-log.
No.
Did you buy it for yourself?
There's no fucking way.
Did you?
Okay, I didn't.
I didn't.
Okay, I can do it to you.
Okay, I'm trying to find it right now.
Did I find my gift?
Where is it?
I can't believe you actually bought the...
I remember we taught sure for how to do it.
But, like, how?
How?
am i actually gonna buy diva and tracer and mercy bro yes
you might as well buy the whole bundle now oh my god don't
help make me google this no wait how to claim how i'm pretty
sure it's bug and you have to read from friend in fortnite
okay did i click lock pop up will i automatically click open
oh i have to reload yes bro don't want to bro bro dude your
ears are drooping again no no no no it's okay here i can
send you another gift no it's okay we can no it's fine we
can get you yeah you can you send me another one and they'll
show up okay do you want do you want the black dino ranger
or the white dino ranger um Dude, no.
Why not?
But I like both.
Why can't I have both?
Do you hate me?
I'm having flashbacks.
I thought we were friends.
Yeah, why is your vocal fry getting heavier?
Put that shit out.
Hey, stop.
You hate me?
Stop it.
That was fucking great.
I don't like this game anymore.
I don't like this game.
Alright, where's my Gengi skin?
You already have a Gengi skin.
Alright, where's my...
Oh, I received a gift from Gully!
Oh my god.
Look at me go.
Look, I'm Kiana.
Keanu Reeves now.
Look at me.
Fucking Arasaga.
I'm so cool.
I'm so fucking cool.
I invited her.
I can't believe it.
Oh, son.
Where is she?
What is she even?
Oh, she's an alien.
Wait, you should gift her a skin, too.
Dude, I've never met this person.
in my life.
Yeah, but then like, so to have good first impressions,
gully, you know?
You want to make a good first impression?
Bro, if someone, if I just met someone and they gifted me a
skin or gifted me anything, I would think it's fucking hexed
and cursed and like, no.
That's not true.
If I just met you and I give you- That is the most ill
intent.
If I just met you and I'd be like, oh, hey, do you want a
Genji skin?
And then I gifted to you, you'd be like, oh my God, that
person.
person is so nice you know what I'm gonna follow him
that is I feel like I feel like you're you're more like
puppy coated and I'm more cat coated because I was fucking
hiss and paw like you're just like oh my god it's Peggy Hill
what the oh my god it's fucking Peggy let's give Peggy Hill
a warm welcome
Why don't you say hello to Peggy Hill, gully?
Not in the call.
Yeah, nope, I meant we gotta give him a little 6-7.
And then I add her to the call.
Wait, I gotta re-equip 6-7.
When you unequip 6-7?
How could you?
Well, I bought this emote and immediately, like...
You just wanted to dance.
I mean, is this not sick?
Yep, but is this more sick than this, though?
I can't believe that you're a larper.
You're fucking larper.
I'm a larper.
You're a goddamn larper.
You know, you know, did I ever tell you like some chick
called me performative?
You know what, Gully?
She was right.
I told her, I told her I'm a clown, baby.
That's the idea.
She's like, okay.
Damn, wait, that's so...
Okay.
That's smooth.
That's smooth though.
And then she blocked you after, right?
Yeah, I woke up as Instagram user.
Yeah, she blocked you right after.
I'll add her to the call.
Give me a sec.
Wakes up as Insta user.
Whatever.
Golly, fucking take the call!
Golly, join the other call, Golly!
Oh shit, my fault, my fault.
I wasn't paying attention.
What do you mean?
Oh my, hello.
Hello.
Hello, Pio.
Golly and I have been playing for six hours, so we don't
know how long we got left.
There's no way we've been playing for six hours.
We've been playing together for three, but I've been playing
for six hours.
I think it feels like we've been playing for like 20
minutes.
I feel honestly true true Yeah, no we got like 20 wins on
there, you know, yeah, we've been pretty much gaming, you
know Yeah, no, don't worry and then we'll let you yeah,
we're gonna let you have a chance to shine Pia We're gonna
let you shoot the gun dude, we're gonna wait we finally got
an igl.
Yeah, yeah, Pia You're gonna igl us.
Don't worry.
Keanu and Genji will just listen to Peggy Hill Dude, we've
been running around like headless chickens.
No, no, no, no, Gully, don't lie to her, Gully.
I mean, we were, we were, we were alpha dogs in that.
We were prime Kobe and Shack, yeah, we were prime Kobe and
Shack.
We're hitting 40 bangers each game.
We killed like 90% or we killed like 90% of the lobby.
That was us, right, Gully?
Yeah.
maybe under like 20 kills per that's crazy yeah i think we
got reported for hacking too like we got a little warning in
between games and then we had to talk to the dev for a bit
yeah yeah we got flagged by the anti-cheat but then like you
know we hooked up with the dev and be like no we're good
we're just gamers you know we're just we just unlocked our
third eye hire you to be the aim bot yeah yeah yeah we're
here to stress test the uh anti-cheat so it doesn't
accidentally flag I'm gonna be I'm gonna be like your beard
because they're not gonna flag you anymore Because they're
gonna see no no they're not gonna flag us because they're
like whoa all three of these players are so fucking good
Like holy shit like oh my this must be the next eSport team
right golly.
Oh, yeah We're like the next eSport sign up like sign us up.
We're gonna win a million dollars people are scouting in the
chat Yeah, yeah in the chat any scouters in chat right now.
No scouters type one of your scouters Where's TSM sentinels
sentinels sign us you know, I know you're in there sentinels
I know you're there.
Pencent just opened up their bank account.
They're just like, ha.
Alright, oh, and P is still low.
Okay, wait, is Sound Guy here, guys?
Is Sound Guy here?
Make sure everybody's volume is okay.
I can boost myself a little bit, too.
I can boost myself slightly.
Alright, Pia needs Uppies.
Alright, I'll put her up.
Uppies, please.
Alright, we're all ready to up.
Oh yeah, Peggy.
Peggy Hill, ready up.
ready uh hold on wait holding holding holding there's like a
million things on my screen uh holding holding how's there a
million things on your screen the ready button right there
no there is no right there oh but god finally wait wait
uncancelled no no they're literally okay okay i there's
there's like a million things on my screen right now because
they were like Yeah, you and Ben here in a while.
So like, you need to like.
Oh, yeah, I claim all of this.
You need to claim everything.
Can we play a steal a brain rot?
Fortnite?
Dude, can we play steal a brain rot in Fortnite?
Wait, is there steal a what's steal a brain rot on Fortnite?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Wait, I was joking.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no.
Please.
Unironically, I put way too many hours in steal a brain rot.
Wait, what?
What even is that game?
Look at this shitty little kid game.
And then I put like 45 minutes into that.
And I was like, wait, what happened?
Where did my time go?
I don't know.
What do you do?
It's Roblox, bro.
Yeah, it's Roblox.
You just, you steal a brainrock.
Wait, is that the one where Bruno Mars, the Bruno Mars show?
What?
He did a car.
It's the strawberry elephant, bro.
No, it's not the one.
You know how Bruno Mars did a concert in Roblox?
I missed out on.
I was so sad.
I don't think he did it at Steal a Brainrock, though.
I don't think it was there.
Wait, who, what, what, what was it?
what roblox game did he do all right where are we yeah where
are we landing you're the you're the some more sexy yeah
you're the igl yeah you're igl we only listen to you all
right we're gonna we're gonna go we're gonna go right here
where's here uh ping it where's the ring it ping it we can't
we don't know what to do we need a leader right here okay
okay okay right here all right see
Amateurs, man, amateurs.
I actually freaked out.
He's at the big triangle and I'm like, oh, there's three
triangles on my screen.
Which triangle is it?
Amateurs, out here.
Alright, I'm here.
I landed.
There's a lot of people around us, guys.
I'm a little scared.
I'm a bit jealous.
I hope Pia can carry us.
I'm a little scared.
Yeah, yeah, watch this.
Watch this.
I know.
I know she'll carry us.
Chat, how the fuck?
Chat, what the fuck?
What do I do?
Pia, why are you here?
Oh shit.
All right.
Golly, I'm coming over to you.
Wait, I see like a couple people here.
Oh yeah.
A lot of people.
Wait, they're coming to you.
Yeah, they're coming to me.
Oops.
Don't worry, SpongeBob's got me.
He's low?
I got him?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god!
Behind you, Pia!
What the?
That's okay, they're dead.
They're dead.
See?
Oh my god, Pia, you did it!
You killed all of them, Pia!
Wait, why is that crazy?
Wait, wait.
You just killed all of them.
Our hero!
Oh my god, our hero!
It's not firing, dude.
Wait, what the fuck is happening?
Wait, why is it my gun firing?
What the fuck did I do last time I played Fortnite?
Did you took off primary fire?
It's like, is that possible?
What the fuck did I do?
I think you took off primary.
I'm literally not firing.
I'm not even kidding you.
It's okay, you can be like, let me shield.
She's just sad.
yeah she's just afk what the fuck i'm gonna lose i'm sorry
pia just stand there and look pretty okay okay i got this so
you can't you can't shoot no it's not shooting it's not
shooting at all that's so weird the trigger discipline is
unreal yeah truly the ghost oh my that's so true that's so
true i just went oh my god she's so humble she's so humble
right now we love to hear it we bragging oh my yeah guys i
survived that even though i uh you know i actually turned
off my weapon because i felt so bad for everybody oh my god
say your peace queen say it i know oh my god stand back
everybody stand back okay literally though how did i how did
i not have uh my gun you're gonna have to look at your
settings well there's people here there's here people here
but these are bots by the way i know i know because i'm
still alive oh oh i ran out of ammo wait wait i gotta dab on
this bot nice do you think we can get victory royale oh 100
with you on our side we definitely yeah i was gonna say with
you here yeah anything is possible honestly yeah i believe
oh my god like You know what we're gonna win like 80 games
now.
Hell.
Yeah, I need ammo Yeah guys no worries just no worries don't
worry the moment we find the mercy staff Gully and I will
both one will damage boost and the other will heal.
Oh my god, Gully Yeah, yeah, we gotta find these staffs.
Yeah, two staffs and then and then we damage I'll be damaged
you healed You're so used to healing Gully.
I'm I like the team coming together.
Golly, you don't pick, you don't pick that role.
You were born to be a heal slut.
You can't save him like yours is drooped.
You were born with that power.
All right, there's a...
Oh yeah, Pia, you gotta heal, take that.
It's just not fair, bro.
It's like...
That's not fair.
Yeah, Pia was born to be a...
freaking killer i know i am yeah yeah it's hard and i'm born
to be a freaking healer are you kidding me yeah it's in your
genetics y'all blame your parents for that that's your
parents fault i was like i was low-key i was panicking i was
like why can't i shoot anything do i really am i really that
bad at game that i forgot how to but i actually just didn't
even how does that even happen i mean how do you how do you
actually just not have a have the firing button enabled what
did i do i don't know as of i'm curious like how do you like
turn off the primary fire yeah she's doing a pacifist run
right now oh shit wait it's perry perry the platypus i'm so
sorry i had to kill him this last guy oh wait there's a guys
we're killing it that real quick oh wait that i don't
remember wait what gun is this oh wait i got the nuke button
i got the nuke the one that has a left and right click
there's also your can you like that one the super shredder
slowly maybe i think the other guy is uh inside yeah but
that's just a bug all right i believe i want to have i want
to have sponge bob as a pet oh he's out of rotation now yeah
wait yeah i'll come back yeah you gotta follow the trackers
did you buy today The overwatch bundle yeah When I okay when
I opened up epic and I saw fortnight at first I like looked
at it and I was like hmm, where's fortnight because it had
all the overwatch characters on it Yeah, it's all the you
thought you were playing overwatch imagine dad who plays we
who plays overwatch itself anymore guys It's it's all about
the overwatch in fortnight.
That's the craze.
That's where all the kids are playing now All right guys
have ammo that's what's trending it's over there it's Perry
the platypus again I wonder if like bot skins rotates and
stuff too I don't like how tall he is he's so buff he's so
big and strong oh my god you could like rub oil on his abs
oh my god oh oh golly golly golly golly it's time so what do
I do with this thing which one with that thing i have a i
found a card but i don't know what it does seven compound oh
we don't have yeah it's a vault key basically we gotta find
a vault but i don't want to wait wait i don't want to what
where's the bed i don't know so am i dropping this i guess
so oh oh i'm gonna grab we're gonna grab a rivalry thing so
we'll know where people are let me sec i'm i'm blinking hold
on sir am i You're healing Pia, and I need to find another
one so we can damage Buster.
Yeah, you gotta keep me alive because, you know, yeah, if
she dies, it's your fault.
I think Pia has a staff.
Pia, do you have a staff?
Uh, yeah.
Wait, there's people in front of me.
I found it at the last place.
Okay, so that's the mercy staff so you can like heal, you
can heal yourself with it too.
The bush is crazy, what the fuck?
Where are they?
Oh my god.
Oh, I hear.
I see who's him.
You too.
Thank you.
We're, like, linked right now.
Interlinked.
Cells.
Oh, I one-shot.
I one-clipped him.
Just like my...
Just like Tracer does in Overwatch, because I am playing
Tracer.
Oh, my god.
Where's the last guy?
Look at that.
They may or may not be bots.
I'll never know for sure.
You know what?
I think they were real players, yes.
You know what's crazy?
Bro, that was a real player.
Did you notice how, like, did you notice how when Pia, like,
rolled up?
Like, they just all killed over and died?
Oh, that's so true.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I got there and then, like, they were all dead.
Yeah, what did you do?
I noticed that.
Holy shit, Pia.
Bro, she didn't even have to shoot.
I know, that's crazy.
Like, her aura literally killed them all.
Yeah.
That was insane.
Wait, you know, I'm glad I could make some time to help you
guys out today, you know.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I know.
I didn't know you had, um, conquerors hockey.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I, I, when I got the Peggy Hale skin, I also got that.
Oh my God.
Pia, did you kill these people too?
I got it and they all just died.
Pia.
I was trying to keep that a surprise.
Holy shit.
Wait, I just, I just ran over the hill and there's a bunch
of loot everywhere.
Yeah.
I just got, I was about to head there and then they were
just dead.
Yeah.
I just, I just wished that they would, they would die and
leave all their loot behind and then they did.
No.
it's amazing that's insane yeah i'm so scary right now yeah
you guys the anti-g just pinged me too it's kind of crazy oh
my god pia you did it again i'm sorry yeah she can't get
away with this oh my god i downloaded a bunch of mods before
this don't tell wait wait what kind of mods can you like see
where the people are tracer it's actually just i got tracer
you're ready uh that's that's So you know where they are.
Oh, don't worry.
We won't tell.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
It was mostly like a cosmetics thing, but you know, like,
yeah, yeah, sure.
I also know where they are.
People are in front of us.
Oh, there they are.
Dude, not for freaking long.
Oh, yeah, true.
Pia's pulling up right now.
I'm using my mind powers right now.
Right here.
I'm hitting them.
I'm hitting them with my mind powers.
Wait, it's there and she's in front of me.
Oh, my God.
You did it again, Pia.
Yeah, don't, don't, don't overextend yourself, Doki.
I'm just...
Oh my god.
There it goes.
You're doing it again.
God, I need to...
You know what?
You know, my doctor told me I need to just stop doing it,
you know?
Too much.
I know.
It really is.
Oh, shit.
You're doing too much.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm doing too much by existing, apparently.
I'm doing too much, man.
I'm doing too much.
Yeah, there's a guy there's a guy that's just a guy.
I don't know.
I can't tell I was a real person that was I can't tell if he
was real or not.
It was hard to tell Definitely a real person Wait, where
were you shooting at fully?
Oh, I it was wiped.
Oh, okay.
I didn't shoot at anybody actually.
Oh true.
Pia.
What were you shooting at?
That was suppressing fire.
Yeah.
I was so scared.
It's okay.
I'm so glad Pia was here.
Think for the heal man.
Thanks Doki, I feel like if you ever shot a gun, you would
actually like close your eyes when you shoot.
Actually, you know what's really crazy?
Oh shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I actually need help.
Wait, wait, what?
I did it.
Wait, okay.
Sick him, Sick him, Sick him!
Oh my god.
Dude, she just- Oh my god.
No fear.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No fear, you guys.
what i just saw what did you see she she walked bro she
watched she didn't even run at them oh my god i knew i knew
they couldn't hit me oh my i was moving so fast that there
was no way they could shoot me so i didn't i didn't even
have to now we can damage and okay i'll be damaged and then
you can be here okay yeah all right pia now go sorry pia all
right right here right here
pia oh she's right pia's you're right you're right you're
right it's like those like blindfold challenges oh my gosh
she is insane that aura walk right there i'm so scared i'm
so scared goalie i'm so glad she's on our team and not on
the enemy team right now yeah i didn't yeah you went across
me you said i'm bringing a friend i wasn't expecting you
weren't expecting her did you a murderer oh my yeah did she
blow the smoke off the guns yeah smoke is really bad for you
it can give you i'm grabbing you gotta you gotta pull off
your gun yeah but you don't you don't care about that
because you are you're better than cancer oh yeah you're
stronger than cancer i was doing that for yeah yeah yeah for
the viewers for the viewers yeah yeah yeah you're like don't
do this at home kids you're not you're not built like me no
she's built different she's built different guys oh my god
we like cleared all the rivalries there's no more we can't
take any more challenges we we sanctuary okay i haven't
played this game
Killed everybody.
No, no, no, you know, you guys did a lot.
You guys, you know, I want to share the credit with you
guys.
You know, you were- No, no, no, no.
Don't do that to us.
No, no.
Don't pity us, Pia.
No, that's not like you, Pia.
Don't pity us.
You ain't know we're worthless, Pia.
We know we're, we don't matter.
Come on, come on.
All weird to you is just damage and heals.
We know our place, Pia.
That's important to you.
That's our place.
That's all we are into the world.
You can replace us with AI, and it wouldn't make a
difference.
I could never replace you with AI.
That's what they all say.
The AI is not nearly as nice as you are.
Wait, didn't she, like, whispered, computer, make Gully a
healer, and doki a damage booster in this game?
You heard that?
Dang, your ears are so good.
What the fuck?
Why are they doing in zone?
You see that?
right now dead dogs i'm heading over you guys i'm i'm
joining can't do without me i know you're so right i'll wait
for you guys at the edge wait have you ever been to like a
firing range irelden what i'm canadian oh wait we have a
kinna's kinna's bears so like you gotta yeah the only you
can only own like hunting rifles if you're We don't have a
range.
Bro, the only firing range he's ever hit up is the one in
Apex Legends.
Yeah, and the one in Apex Legends.
I was like, what do you mean, firing range?
We don't have that here.
I don't know.
Canada gave the impression of like, you know, you got like
moose.
Yeah, we have like bears in the neighborhood, like just
walking on the outdoor.
It's like, sorry guys, I can't stream today.
I gotta shoot a bear real quick.
Do you ever see how pissed I was when I learned about
loonies?
Loonies and toonies?
Why were you pissed out at loonies and toonies?
Because, okay, I was okay with loonies, and then I heard
about toonies, and I actually, like...
You actually, you actually raged?
I...
Yeah.
Oh, what the fuck?
Rival Intercept.
Oh, they killed him.
Oh.
He died to the storm.
Never mind, the storm killed him.
Wait, it's one guy left.
That was me.
I'm the storm, yeah.
Wait, one guy's left.
Wait, are we gonna get a victory?
Anyone else just feel like a fucking chill up their spine
after she said that?
Dude, I...
Holy fuck.
Wait, wait, what?
Say what?
Pia?
It wasn't the storm.
Oh, oh.
What is it?
Wait, it's one guy.
Okay, golly, we have to let Pia kill him.
We have to let Pia kill him.
I'm going.
Let that one, the last guy, I'm taking the last contract.
Oh, there's, wait, I don't have enough.
Wait, wait, someone already got the contract.
It's all the way back.
Oh, wait, we're gonna, oh, they're in storm.
Oh, I know that's a bot.
Is there, are they in storm?
Is that not the storm contract right here?
Where are they?
I don't freaking know.
Oh my gosh, they're so scared to play hide and seek right
now.
They need to know.
They know that we have, oh, that's going on.
Wait, do you see?
That's them.
Yeah, kill them.
No, no, that's an NPC.
No, we had to wait.
Oh my god.
The sheer aura.
Guys, I did it.
Absolutely disgusting display.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking sick, bro.
I'm so scared.
It's all right.
You don't got to be scared.
We're on the same team right now right now for now For now
for now.
Oh my god.
Golly.
Don't you fortnight tomorrow.
Yeah, don't you fortnight tomorrow.
I like you Yeah, what can I say?
I can't believe it nothing so I won't yeah I can hear your
fucking remote That's right, but it's Christmas time.
We're defrosting Mariah Carey.
I can't even imagine how much money Mariah Carey makes off
of...
I don't think she has to do anything anymore.
No, definitely.
No, like, okay, so lady who made the Evangelion theme song,
she makes so much money off of that song that she owns an
island in Turkey.
So, like, I can't even imagine how much money Mariah Carey
makes.
I don't know.
Why Turkey?
Dude, they have good coffee and cash.
I'm working.
He asked for it.
The island just has coffee and cats.
You can't have anything else.
They're like, would you like some breakfast?
And he's like, yo, we only serve coffee and cats.
Do you think that they have turkeys in Turkey?
That's like been a lifelong question.
I'm pretty...
Actually, are turkeys?
Can you come look at me real quick?
Can you find me?
Yeah, yeah.
Look how Genji is sitting down, bro.
Why is he throwing...
Why is he arcing his back like that?
Oh, my God.
He's throwing a bag.
Yeah.
He's getting ready.
He's practicing.
So slay.
See, this is why you're...
That's why you were born to be a support.
Wait, dude.
Your weapon is sick.
I like your...
Or my chicken.
Your dual chickens.
Yeah, it's pretty sick.
Hey, guys.
Where are we going?
Yeah, you can use my creator code dokeeper to get yourself
your own chicken.
Chicken knives.
You're the IGL.
Yeah, you're the IGL, Pia.
You don't say where are we going.
You say we're going here.
we're going drop here now yeah drop here now and we're like
yes sir yes sir sir i lied i want to go to the music park
all right i freaking love wonky land i want to ride the
ferris wheel wonky land wonky land every time i try to do
the little like firing range thing here i always die maybe
you should kill them first and then do the fire range have
you ever thought about that yeah but like nothing's cooler
than not giving a right that's true that's so true but do
you think they give a fuck did anyone run here they're
ruining my fun that's so true a bunch of asses i got all
this uh i'm slurping i'm slurming
oh i hear you guys doing the fire range right now dude us
that's Pia bro oh shit you're right oh my god when she plays
it's she sounds like three people yeah I know when she plays
even when she performs yeah I'm just I'm just whistling
she's like the sheer force of the wind it's hitting the
fucking targets it's so tough man that's crazy why I'll take
all that.
See, I'll take it.
Oh, man.
Are you watching?
Yeah.
That's all he could do.
He couldn't move at all.
He was stun locked.
Lego Batman give.
Oh, wait, I got tracer's guns.
Hell yeah.
Oh, my God.
The tracer's gun is so funny is I've been abusing that the
entire day.
Oh, shit.
Wait, it actually works.
Yeah, it's like the double jump is the blink and then right
click is recall.
Or I'm going to grab a contract.
All right, let's go.
Let's head over.
I'm ready.
I'm just got...
It's like they're, like, up here.
Wait, what's the thing on top of that hat?
Do you guys see that?
Yeah.
Is somebody, like, flying above us?
Wait, I think that was the guy.
That was the contract guy.
He flew above us.
It's like...
Looks like he's over yonder.
I'm just going to go this way.
Like, he's somewhere.
around here where is he where's harley quinn
harley quinn every time i see little sponge bob it's so cute
she's so cute yeah he's he's peace us over looking at it
he's a little snitch that's all i can say oh i like when you
shoot at him and he gets like angry oh yeah he gets angry
he's like what are you doing what Yeah, he gets lit again.
Wait.
You shoot at him.
Look at him.
Oh, he's like, why are you out of?
He's coming for you.
He's glancing his little fish.
It's like, how dare you?
She's like somewhere around us, but it's a bot because it's
like Zeno botanist.
Should we go fly?
Fly.
I'm shen running.
Oh, I hear shots this way.
On me.
The bots are fighting each other.
Slowly gliding towards them.
Oh, shit.
Wait, the bots are shooting me from...
Wait, I don't think that guy's a bot.
Wait, that guy's not a bot.
Actually, that guy's a bot.
That guy's real.
Wait, these are real players.
Wait, there's real players here.
That is...
There's real players here.
I'm booking it.
Oh, P.M.
P. Careful.
It doesn't fucking matter.
Wait, Gully, you're so far from us.
Wait, Gully, who are you fighting?
Marco Robbie!
I killed the whole squad.
No!
Dude, I don't know what came over me, man.
I swear for a second, that was a vessel for Pia.
She took over my body.
Only briefly.
Oh, fuck, Lola Bunny, no!
Pola buddy the eyes the eyes rolled to the back of my head
and I just like woke up in a blinding rage all right there
are real players somewhere they might come actually come
over but I don't know exactly he's got it he's got it get
her get her get Lola I can't she's too hot oh my god you did
kill Kurei she's too hot man she's too hot there's a that
hurt me that hurt me to do that do I gotta do all right you
guys like that
that's right gotta do a little dab first wait there's people
in front of me oh yeah here's somebody oh wait they're like
down there that's another it's another bot versus bot
Oh, nice.
Let's see.
Oh, I need...
I should need this for his.
Oh, they have a shotgun, too.
Oh, my God.
These bots, thank you for delivering this loot for us.
Thank you.
Wait, what's over there?
What's the exclamation point?
Does anyone know?
Oh, it's an odd...
It's lore.
I don't freaking know.
Guys, let's just...
You know, let's just...
Let's just hang out.
Yo.
Yeah, get chilling.
You know, it's been a rough day.
You know, sometimes you got you got chill, you know?
And take it in life.
Just take it in the environment, you know?
Relax.
Slow down.
4K Peggy.
Let's go.
Oh, wait, the campfire is gone.
I guess we gotta leave now.
Oh, man.
Oh, wait.
It's mom.
Okay, that's a real person.
That's I don't think fortnight would put that as an actual
name Mommy's fun toy That guy's real that that guy's real
that's a real person.
That's a real person.
Oh, they're fighting
They're like right over here Dude, someone consciously chose
it to be their name.
I think that's freaking awesome.
I think so too will great guys i would hope that they chose
it and not their parents that's kind of messed up if it was
their parents i think it was i think it might be a core
memory for him they're like what's this and the mommy's like
that's mommy's fun toy oh not for you though where is he
what kind of ammo do you need oh i don't know oh shit oh
shit think about mommy's
Where?
That's not mommy's fun toy.
You lied.
Mommy, that wasn't very fun.
But I think they're on you.
Oh my god.
Dude, I'm...
Whoa.
That wasn't mommy's fun toy, though.
She's like all the way over there.
She's running away from us.
Why is she running away?
She's scared.
She didn't realize I was in this group.
Oh, she saw your name.
She saw your name on...
the kill feed well actually oh they might actually run at me
i'm like next to them somewhere
they're around me right now i'm a little scared i'm alone
but there's no overwatch the box i got you we're on her
freaking oh my god i have to i got the staff healing stream
engaged i gotta take the healing stream Close to me.
Wait, they're rising.
They're rising.
No.
Dude, they're so lucky.
They're so lucky if he wasn't there, bro.
Yeah, they're so lucky.
They're so lucky right now.
It's just, it's, you know, sometimes it takes a little bit
of time to walk with.
Okay, I got my respawn toy.
Wait, wait, don't kill him.
Don't kill him.
Okay.
I got it.
Now you kill him.
Only because you only because you...
I just wanted to dab.
Alright.
They're on top of that building up here.
Where is it?
Ping?
That building?
Well, shit, they have no guns.
I'm just gonna go for it.
What does the pizza do?
Oh, it's just healers.
Oh, okay, okay.
Sick.
Are you sure they're still there?
I mean, that's where I got shot from.
That's where I saw them land.
Yeah, they're right here.
Oh!
Oh, I see them.
Oh, I didn't see them.
I hear them.
Oh.
Wait, wait, I just might die.
Wait, oh, wait, there's two.
There's, I thought that was you guys.
Oh, my God.
Okay, now they have loot.
I thought those were.
I thought the other guy next to me was you guys.
It's okay.
We're here.
Okay, they might have my loot now, guys.
So they might.
Oh, they didn't even know.
Yeah.
Oh, they have a, they have the mercy beam.
They're healing with mercy.
Because I did a lot of damage earlier.
Gully, this is up to you, Gully.
Go, you got this!
Dude, I don't know what happened.
I became a vessel again, and Pia took over.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If Pia got knocked, it took over yourself.
Yeah, I had to surrender my body because I didn't want you
to take any damage.
Wait, did you grab...
There's a card.
There's a raise at the front.
Did we pick up your card?
Yeah, you guys did.
I'm pretty sure, right?
I want to go.
Yeah, yeah, I see it.
for some reason i thought you guys were like there was a guy
next to me and i thought it was one of you guys i was like
that that they can back me up all right heroes never died
though i'm back baby welcome back all right i want to grab
oh no do i need a new staff yeah where do we kill good news
for you i have one but where did we kill them there you go
you guys remember wait where do we kill them because i want
my stuff back over there oh no you're walking towards it no
it's too i don't think it's fine uh hit it control and then
just drag it to the floor oh okay it's fine i don't need it
i'll just find stuff again oh wait what control oh wait in
inventory inventory okay okay it's here okay there you go
actually maybe i can grab it kink no worries kink
exact same charge wait was that the one that's funny no I'm
pretty sure they have the same wait I might have picked up
yours no they have they have a little charge it's like no
different wait what the fuck they took all oh wait they
didn't take everything that's good I have some tracer guns
if you want them I got I got it I also don't worry I got it
I'm gonna blink over soon yeah yeah I have heals here a lot
of there's some slurp slurp things here yeah smack smack it
okay I don't think I got it but that's okay I do have like
one jug I got a I got a four pack I think I might need it
yeah wait oh there's a shield i'm using my last heels on you
oh yeah yeah use it on p yeah yeah there you go we shield
each other no we have to yeah yeah yeah all right we have to
you're you're literally uh the carry oh man what do we do
about you anything for you dude anything for my freaking igl
i know for our leader wait there's a i hear gunshots in
front of me
It's like stop.
It's like they heard Piaq was coming and then they just
stopped shooting.
Many such cases.
Like, it's gone.
My lead is gone.
I can't sniff them out anymore.
Where do we go, Pia?
Uh, I think...
Where do we go?
They're definitely over there.
Alright, let's go.
Pia said we should go there.
Pia just licked your finger and put it up in the air.
Yeah, yeah, it's like...
Yeah, it's like...
Yep.
That's it.
He's there.
I swear.
He's like, I can feel, I can sense their presence.
You can't.
I'm not as good as you, Pia.
That's all right.
You'll get there.
Really?
You think so?
You really think so?
You know, we're just, really?
Oh, my fuck.
Did you hear that, Gully?
We have potential.
You do.
This is so exciting.
Oh my god.
I don't know how to feel.
Do you think we're going to get scouted by the end of the
season?
Don't cry.
Oh my god.
Pia, Pia, you're right.
You're right here.
Of course I'm right.
How did you know?
I just know.
He's right over there, by the way.
Um, he like, he dodged me.
I don't know where he went.
Pia, do you know where you went?
Oh, he took the portal.
Trust your gut.
He took the...
Oh.
Oh, I might...
Oh, I'm...
They're all behind.
They're on me.
I'm on me.
Oh, my God.
No!
Oh, they blinked towards me.
Wait, where's Gully?
Right here.
Gully?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Not...
Did I saw people...
Did I...
Bro, I saw Triple T behind Pia, and I, like, freaked out.
Yeah, you went mute there.
You went mute.
You're like...
You ever see two Titans fighting?
Bro, I think that one solo...
You can't do anything but, like, sit there and all.
The one solo I was shooting, I'm pretty sure that team was
literally chasing him, because he was so scared.
I was just like, why is he running so fast?
They were literally chasing that guy.
But that's just like watching Godzilla versus Kong bro.
You just don't interrupt that battle That was crazy.
I was so I was like I was when I saw him I got stunned
locked.
I didn't know what to do Yeah, I got too distracted by
Italian brain rot.
I just I really liked I really like But you were supposed to
be you were supposed to be our carry I know I had one my one
flaw is Italian brain rot I can't control myself whenever I
steal them.
I just I have to steal them.
Oh my god.
These guys are try-hards.
Um, it's 2 41 a.m.
What are you guys doing here?
Why are you guys trying so hard?
This is someone's freaking life, bro.
They should be a streamer.
We should tell them that.
Oh, true.
Yeah, we should be like, are you ever considered streaming?
Pretty good.
about the kiddo bro the kid wait what kid oh we encountered
that one guy and he was he was yeah it was bent it and
honestly he could have been he was shroud 2.0 he could have
been the next round that's crazy yeah now he was insane i
wanted let's go
well how did you do it i can't do it continuously with you
You just got a log.
Don't run.
Alright, P.O.
Where do we go?
You know, I'm thinking, I'm thinking, I'm thinking, uh, you
know, right over there.
Oh, shit.
I jumped way too early.
Oh, it's okay.
You intended to do that.
Right here instead.
Alright.
We're landing there with you.
Here we go.
What is this?
Is it a ball?
I think it's just...
It's just a place.
It's another triangle.
I think that's a circle.
Just another triangle.
Imagine what, golly.
Playing with someone who only does call outs with like
shapes?
Yeah, it's like a circle.
Guys, yo, yo, go to the rumbus, guys.
I mean imagine, that's what I'm doing right now.
Yeah, and I'm imagining it right now.
Yeah, the rumbus, bro.
Yo, bro, me me at the rumbus.
all right I hear people I heard somebody you'll drop traps
bro bro traps bro trap zoids guys there's people on me at
the square it's okay when's two you get certain it's
freaking over that's true all right one down oh enemy team
wiped it's just that easy oh shit I hear more people but I
did I did as well they're like right below us I just jumped
to the fucking window.
Oh, another team white.
Let's go.
Just that easy.
No big deal.
It's another day.
I just shot the guy in the back of the head.
Am I your murder?
He deserve it.
No, he was going to be on death row anyway.
Yeah.
Yeah, he was about to be on...
He was literally one day away from being executed.
So you just sped it up.
Yeah, you actually saved tax dollars.
so you know the the american taxpayer yeah you know they
they owe you some money
yeah there's some pizza up here for heels
did spongebob just fucking booking it across the future
wait what other pets do they have is it just spongebob no
there's like a there was uh itchy from Itchy and Scratchy.
Oh, shit.
And then there's, like, a bunch of them.
I know...
It was a Meat Boy, right?
Yeah, there was.
I'm trying to remember.
Was there a binding of Isaac or no?
I don't think so.
I think that was, like, after, that was, like, before they
added companions.
I know I bought, I bought, like, two of them, but I don't
remember what the other two were.
Oh, yeah, Rigby from Regular Show.
Ooh.
What was the other one that I have?
Because I don't remember.
Wait, there's a person.
Is that a person?
No, it's not.
Oh, yeah.
Isaac was a back.
Oh, the blue monkey.
Yeah, the blue monkey is a is a companion too.
The blue monkey?
The bloons.
What'd that mean?
You know, bloons?
Oh, bloons.
Yeah, yeah.
Balloons.
The darts.
I thought you said blue monkey.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, they could be blue.
The ice monkey's blue.
What's the last time you played Bloons?
I don't remember.
Oh, last time it was for a Marvel Rivals tournament.
Because I had to wait an hour for my match.
And I just pulled up Bloons.
Actual?
Yeah, I was just like, who went?
I pulled up Fortnite and Bloons until my match started.
I literally waited like an hour and a half.
I heard shots.
Yeah, nope, that was not me.
This is my bad gas.
That was me.
Oh, bubble guts.
Yeah, sorry, man.
Yeah, oh my god, I heard it from across the map, too.
Yeah.
Oh, we wait for him, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my god.
Oh my god, we shot at this.
The seagull tamer.
I get over here, little guy.
Wait, I'm sticking a tree.
I'm sticking a tree.
Okay, I'm good.
Don't worry.
I'm stuck, step bro.
Wait, did you kill him?
I killed the other guy, yeah.
I got my contract, too.
But there's one more guy on you.
Yeah, I killed him.
There you go.
Wait, Dragoons, what was the other companion that I have?
I can't look at my locker.
I know Spongebob was not my first companion.
Oh, shit.
Okay, don't worry.
Come over.
Is he a real guy or is he bots?
I think it's a real guy.
Oh, you think?
I mean, yeah, it must have been a real guy.
A bot could never get me down.
It must have been a freaking pro player stream sniping you,
bro.
Yeah, man.
Bro, I can't believe the audacity of them stream sniping.
Fucking shameless.
Oh, shit.
Go, you go.
There's a guy on me!
Do you Scotty?
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
Yo, T.
Scotty pulled up.
Like, he owned the place.
Well, he tried to jump away.
Yo, this is Pia's lobby, bro.
Does he not know?
How dare you?
Somebody should have told him.
Alright, I'm actually...
Hit him on the newsletter.
Sign him up.
I'm gonna grab this.
And then...
Alright, I got two pieces.
I'm just gonna grab this.
And I'm just gonna kill him.
Come over here right here with me.
Yeah.
And then I'm just gonna grab all of that.
Did you see...
Did you say come over here?
Yeah, come over here.
Yeah, exactly.
Come over here.
Yeah.
All right, we're good.
All right, let's go grab Pia back.
We're not the same without her.
Oh, it's Tally!
I feel like a freaking empty, bro.
I have Tally.
I feel like a freaking husk, bro.
Without Pia.
It's like I can hear them right now.
All right, I'll get the res.
You covered me.
I'm gonna cover you.
Okay.
I'm covering.
Oh man, picking me up.
Bring in a pizza.
Dang.
I pressed E instead of F.
I mean, I got inside the car.
There's people right in front of us.
Right here.
Get in the car.
The moment I read it, the moment I read it's getting in the
car.
Get in the car.
Goodbye Pio.
You can- Wait, you just left Pio!
Oh!
No, no, no, we're repositioning.
We're repositioning right here.
Just sliding away.
Don't worry, P.O.
We're just repositioning right now.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm getting shot.
Where am I getting shot from?
Oh, my God.
I'm going to.
Wait, wait for me.
Wait, I freaking...
Did you freaking laugh at me?
You're...
I got it!
There's no one shooting you!
Get over here!
All right, we have to go...
We have to...
Wait, we can just buy it, right?
We can buy it.
Yeah, we can't.
Bro, this is like the loudest fucking truck.
I got a little sandwich there.
Wait, is the person right in front?
I can just turn around.
She starts...
You know, we're just gonna keep on driving.
Keep on driving.
Did you see that guy?
That guy had two exclamation points, like, above his head
when he heard us come in.
Wait, where the fuck?
Oh, that's an NPC that's him.
EF squad reboot.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
See, look, it's just that easy.
Nothing to worry about.
I guess.
I'm dropping this pizza.
Come eat.
I need to take.
I'm gonna take high ground.
I hear gunshots in front of me.
Oh, right here.
All right, Pia, here.
Thank you.
There's people fighting in front of me here.
I was gonna do it with my karate hands, but I guess a gun
was nice.
All right, demon on wheels.
It's down.
We eliminated another AI.
And yeah.
All right.
Pia, IGL?
now that you're back on your feet yeah yeah now that you're
back on feet we don't know what to do now well i'm like a
lost like puppy we're i'm like a bandy i guess you know i i
feel like i feel like this zip line looks really fun and i
think we should ride it okay i trust that call out and i'm
right behind you guys was it fun exhilarating my heart is oh
my god yeah i'm thinking about it right now how fun that was
crazy it's always a good time it's always a good time
there's still 20 teams left guys i'm a little and there's a
staff for me uh dude we're so up let's go wait where are you
gully i'm in the river in the river i don't even see you all
swimming oh you're all the way down there oh you're right
below me oh yeah so there's gonna be people to our left
you're in the storm appeals appeals appeals oh yeah i need
that and pia might need a lot of heels too i have yeah i got
no armor she has no armor at all we should take the high
ground i feel i gave it to sponge bob he looked like he
needed it all right oh shots to my right people are fighting
right now shots to my right
That's...
AI?
It's AI?
Get rid of the AI?
Yeah, GPT!
Why would chat GPT fight me?
You know, they're afraid.
I think they're both AI fighting.
You have to be careful because the real people are very
scary.
That guy's just rolling in the ground.
I don't think he's...
all right at least we get rid of the AI real quick
okay guys yeah I'm gonna say okay over there all right we're
weeding out the AI real quick who's this chaos cube I don't
know I've just oh there's another staff yeah how much is
there it's I'll grab it.
Just like gunshots over there.
Oh, yeah.
They're right next to us.
That's a real person.
Dude, that guy's monitor is definitely on.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Oh, they're going to res, though.
Yeah, but they're resing.
I mean, do you guys want to run?
run at them or we chill in here?
I mean, they have high ground.
So like, yeah, I can't fly.
That's the only issue.
I can't hit Pia.
There we go.
Dude, why would I want to- Wait, after you damage boost me?
You'll let me latch, bro.
Wait, that damage boost me.
I got you.
Hey, you damage boost.
I'm a difficult one.
Oh my God, look, I can't peek anymore.
That guy's hitting every shot.
To where I heal myself and you heal me.
Did someone call a doctor?
Yeah.
I mean, how it feels.
Okay.
I think we should move towards Circle.
Thoughts?
Yeah, I think you're right.
I agree.
There's a...
Can we drive this truck or no?
No, it's tire locked.
You can see on the tires.
They didn't pay their bills.
Pay bills, kids.
Yeah, we parked in the no parking zone.
Yeah, tiki.
mojito physique there's like two teams left and one of them
is next to us you're working that circle but there is a
there is a can of slurm juice over there if you need it it's
a can of fuck oh bro there's a camera
you don't have a staff anymore I feel naked without my staff
Those people with the bounty knows exactly where we are
because I picked up the bounty.
Dude, I'm like an angel who lost his wings.
Wait, is that card drivable?
No, it's tire locked.
I'm trying to find you another staff so you can go back to
heaven.
I don't know where the leather team is.
Chilling.
Yeah, I don't want to fight the...
team to my left oh wait are they shooting at you guys or oh
up here up here oh okay so that means that's they found the
other team
how the fuck did you make that jump i don't know how core
they're like bionic legs how core no one doesn't know how to
parkour wait ready
nice wait i got sniped oh my god i got sniped i don't know
by who Oh, I'm right behind you.
I'm gonna roll over to Pia.
Pia!
Right behind you!
Turn around!
There.
I got you.
Did you thirst him or no?
I'm just, I'm just a petting skibbity toilet right now.
You're good.
Alright, go.
I'm getting res right now.
Quite skibbity.
On skib room?
I got snipeed by something.
I don't know by what.
Oh, nice.
I already killed that guy.
wait I need a heal right now I don't have shields I've got
bandage I need shields both of you here thanks all right
last is for you my friend I don't know oh yeah that was the
original team that we were fighting before so we basically
flanked all right I guess we go
We don't Sucks we don't have any of this the staff anymore
Oh, so this team knows exactly where we are I see them your
high ground your high ground right now I'm so freaking slow
and fat and ugly and Why why can't middle-aged women run
fast why come on Peggy?
Come on Peggy Pick it up Peggy pick it up peggy all right
i'm in this are you guys gonna be okay because they're on my
ass right now i might yeah yeah all right i've distracted
them a little bit got some bandits you could they got the
run to us i'd be good i heard them here i see them they're
right there they i've all have high ground I have an off
angle.
Alright, I'm coming.
Well, we have Nick Circle.
So I'm running towards you.
I have a good off angle, you guys.
Oh, wait.
They're going to run this way.
I see them.
Yeah, they have to.
Yeah.
The two are...
They're here.
They're here now.
153?
And they're jigging peaking them.
I have the angle for this.
They have to come this way, too.
I think they might cross all the way to the right because I
don't see them.
Or left.
I think they're crossing all the way to the right and
they're waiting for the circle.
I see them.
Yeah, they're right there.
You guys guard the circle.
I want Gully, you should go over there.
Pia.
I mean, I'm red-sided now.
I will say Pia.
You are using a shotgun.
uh yeah you got a problem with that you got a problem with
that i do not you doubt my you doubt no i do not doubt your
abilities oh my god i fell down it's crazy i just i was just
very impressed that you were making those shots thank you
and they're on me
yes we're here my ping i pinged them okay i'm trying to
check i don't see him I dare right below me he's right below
me I got one
nice where do you go oh no I don't like this me too oh he's
healing over here it's like give it a sniff you'll find him
where I think he disappeared we gotta go to zone Oh no.
My head over.
Wait, he's on me, he's on me!
Oh shit.
Got him!
Yeah!
Let's go.
Dab.
Six, seven.
Look at that.
Dab.
Oh no, no, no.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, no, no.
Dude.
what is it the second win oh my god is that it oh my god
he's look at that kind of shredding it look at that pia
shooting with her shotgun they were so threatened she hit
every bullet the sprint hit every shot it was crazy it even
the mountains were tremoling oh my god mostly because they
were getting hit with a lot of buckshot but you know like
you know i can't believe it i've
sniper shotgun that's crazy she was trying to she was trying
to cause what is it called the uh when the snow goes down
the mountain and everyone yeah there's too many guns
i love fortnite for its variety but like every time i come
back i'm like what the is all of this what are all of these
items only take the only gun i actually take is the is the
the tracer gun yeah i'm looking for a good shape what shape
pia just need good shapes oh wait that's a good shape now
that's a good shape where's the shape uh dude he's gonna run
yeah let's go to rob this let's go that's a good shape yeah
let's go to the circle in a circle in a circle oh my god
good call igl
yeah all right oh I have pizza actually going here I am I'm
already at the rhombus wait where are you guys met circle
circle wait did you guys when did you guys pick the other
circle I picked the first circle oh my it's okay I can I'm
gonna steal a car I'm gonna download a car real quick do not
worry I in my feet she doesn't know her shape but it's okay
it's okay it's okay guys earlier she said on my right and
they were on her left so like i was close enough it was
close it was close up do you put two l's up i don't know
what you're talking about i'm heading over i'm holding
heading over it I'm heading right over running near me but
like I don't see them It's me.
Yeah, it's here.
Oh, they're right here.
Oh shit Don't worry.
I'm almost there guys
Dude, I'm almost there we collected bro.
Yeah Oh shit.
Oh, shit.
Fine.
Fine behind behind behind don't worry.
You guys are so safe I'm almost there guys.
No not jinx.
Oh Oh, wait, I have a soul.
There we go.
Bro, she's 166 right here.
She's searching me.
Wait, are you guys okay?
Oh, no.
I don't know how they got behind us.
Wait, you guys are dead?
Yeah, it's a different squad.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
I have an idea.
Dude, lock in, bro.
You got Skib on your side.
I have an idea.
You just gotta channel the energy of Skibity Toilet episode
69.
Okay, where's the closest res?
Okay, I have an idea.
All right.
I got the pizza.
I don't know.
And I'm slowly gliding in.
And then I think I have enough.
There we go.
Freaking way.
Look at that.
I told you I had an idea.
That's crazy.
I told you.
And then pizza!
And I'm gonna eat my pizza.
And then I'm gonna drive away.
I'll see you guys later.
Hey!
What the?
Wait, at least you dropped this pizza though.
Like, at least you dropped this pizza.
You guys pizza.
Get in here.
Come on guys.
We're going.
Come on bitch.
Get here.
We're going.
We're going shopping.
Eat your damn pizza.
I'm in.
All right.
At Gio, where do we go?
I'm up top.
I don't know my shapes.
I believe in you.
You'll find it.
What do you mean the sexiest triangle?
Well, how can you differentiate?
What is considered sexy?
What are the angles?
Is it like what kind of angles are the sexiest?
Like it's like a little bit rounded but like in a dangerous
way, you know?
What do you mean by dangerous though?
You'll know.
You'll know when you see it.
I don't know I guess I'll know what is yeah, can you send us
the sexiest triangle that you know like we're curious I
swear if you send us if you send a picture of a Yeah,
seriously guys take this seriously We just want to know what
what is the sexiest triangle like how would you rate aren't
gonna believe this What do you find a staff?
There's a bazooka too.
I found something better.
What?
Yeah, bro.
Wait, we were trying to find that for a while earlier.
I'm glad we were finally able to.
I'm here now.
Is it true you were...
Is it true you were heart-stuck doing Lordle?
Oh, I think it was a...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we play words on the street.
Oh, my God.
You're him.
You're actually him.
Yeah.
You're him.
I've been told that before.
Yeah.
You know that sword has...
ammo golly i i see that yeah i'm just wasting it for the
larp why did it just why am i in oh there's there's fall
damage there's fall oh no well i well i hit a really sick
move well there's a there's a thing here there's a thing
here no no wait there's a thing here for her to oh okay okay
yeah chug jug me i think you have to do it wait no she okay
before you chug jug before oh shit i chugged oh okay party
foul party foul i'm chugging no no it's okay It's okay, it's
okay.
Yeah, I was going to say, Darius, slurm here.
Oh, well, I guess it's too late.
Peggy's got a drinking problem.
All right, let's go.
Where do we go?
No, I'm going to go to this town.
Look, it's the cube.
We need guns.
I mean, this place is free.
It doesn't seem like it's...
I feel semi-looted.
They might have been left already.
I'm going to take a contract.
But you're getting signed already?
Yeah, I'm getting contract.
I knew Klingapia would bring us opportunities.
I knew it.
Yeah, I have a rivalry in progress.
Wait, when do we have a...
Boy, the guy is like 80 miles away.
He's not fucking killing anything.
Well, I hear shots, though.
Do you remember when we ran away from, like...
Yeah.
I'm going for these bot kills.
I'm up with my KDA.
Oh, my glob.
Dude, I'm so...
Wait, these are real people.
These are real people.
Oh, shit.
I'm coming back.
Where are you?
The guys, I should have known.
They're on high ground.
It's okay.
They're like over here.
I got my secret weapon.
I'm coming over to you.
Alright, I'm back.
Wait, where are they at?
They're like all the way up there.
Like all the way up there.
I...
knuckles bro yeah where are they show me the bogeys i'm
ready i'm ready to go back are you guys ready let's go
nothing that uh nothing that a little all the way oh i don't
i you're a little further than that what what just happened
um i i was trying to mind bell into them and you uh you got
a little bit of the heat.
Raid it on a curve.
Okay, they're like right in front of me.
The real team.
Very much very real team.
You can tell they're real because they use the jump pads.
Oh my god.
She's so low though.
Where did she go?
Oh, you did?
Nice.
So their teammates are up on that hill, by the way.
Oh, I got the pizza.
Uh, does everyone want the arms?
Or no.
Actually.
Dude, I have the ultimate loadout right now.
Yeah, what is it?
I have a rifle.
I have the pulse guns.
I have a katana and I have a staff.
Oh my, you're him.
You're actually him, buddy.
I have, like, all the infinity stones.
I don't know where the others are.
I don't know.
But do you have a rocket launcher?
Because there's a refresh.
Wait, there's a res.
There's a res in front of me.
Wait, guys, guys.
There's a res.
I'm a freaking loser.
It's all right.
I knew it.
I shouldn't have brought it up.
Oh, no.
Look at him.
You gave him PTSD.
Oh, no.
Look what you did.
I'm so sorry.
Dude, she's never going to play with us again.
do it there's like people over there
boom they're on me I could do that too oh wait oh my god he
can do it too hit me
I like how we're both just when we just start blasting
oh my god did you see the guy yeah holy shit wait you can
charge the poles wait you can or you can't i just did it i
couldn't yeah look at oh my god it's a res res car versus
res car right now you see that dude it just blew them up
should we go down there like i feel like this is i don't
know i don't i don't know there's like three teams down
there i don't feel very safe they're throwing rockets at us
by the way oh well two can play you left them I'm eating
pizza.
There's pizza here.
Do you need it?
I need a backup.
Oh shit, they're coming up.
Wait, who is pushing up?
There's pizza here, you need it.
I will take the pizza.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my gosh, wait, he headshot me!
Gully, he's, oh wait, where's Gully?
Gully, are you?
Oh my gosh.
He's rolling.
Gully, Go, Gully, go.
How is she still alive, Gully?
Oh, Gully.
He's right here.
It's okay.
Oh, no.
I don't think he's going to win.
No!
Like, that's the...
Dude, I had all the weapons in the world and I still watch.
No.
Maybe you didn't have all the weapons in the world.
they went for us they were having their they were like fuck
these guys shooting on the high ground like because he was
okay was it just me how many slashes yeah i don't know how
many slashes bro you were like slashing forever i was
hacking and slashing them cosmetic weapon man this is not
bro bro that you needed an anabus bro you needed a anabus i
should have said the lion Oh, you should have larp tighter.
Yeah.
You weren't him.
You didn't have the nano and you didn't.
You didn't use your inner Genji.
It's okay.
We all make mistakes.
You can get him next time.
Yeah.
You can do it next time, champ.
I believe.
You think so?
Yeah.
Really, Pia?
Yeah, you're going to get him next time.
I believe in you.
You got this.
I'm filled with determination.
That is coming from a level 18.
fortnite player so you know like yeah you know it's pretty
great i just got a boon yeah awesome this is it the fuck is
this oh it's all right this actually might be my lg i i'm
tired i'll fail you yeah we've been playing for a minute i'm
on seven hours now this might be lg guys let's make it worth
it i'm kind of tired i know i just like like something
simple for a the fort the fortnite adrenaline hit me like
four hours later like get on fortnite yeah i was like i did
we found the we're gonna make form a group we're gonna form
a team it was just too dude i'm locking in was just too good
watch x fortnite i know exactly the adrenaline was just too
much you know you know when it hits you the second third and
fourth win i was like i was giving me be nice two hours
stream and then seven hours later all right i think we
should go to overwatch wait where's overwatch is that an
actual place where yeah look it's the overwatch headquarter
there's like the little the little overwatch logo and over
here wait really what the fuck yeah yeah wait it's it's like
close to it's like over here with the weird big banana wait
what overwatch was in fortnite all along i just saw the
overwatch all of them wait oh my god there's the ship there
it is keen eye bro keen eye from here oh my god it's like
it's like she was in overwatch all along oh my god did you
know Winston did you know Winston back then no but like yeah
you know I mean oh my god wait can get can you get him an
autograph for me I mean from bastion if bastion if bastion's
good I mean Oh, he's not Winston, though, but...
Okay, all right, well...
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I thought that was you.
No, no, that is not us.
And I'm fighting Superman.
Nah, you'd win.
Nah, you win.
I was just like, I was like chilling.
I was thinking about...
So humble, bro.
Yeah.
So humble.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Oh, wait, you got shot by someone else.
Oh, a shot got shot by Gully.
wait superman's right here wait superman's chasing you i
don't have like i didn't have any weapons it's okay we got
overwatch yeah yeah yeah yeah because yeah because yeah
because we're we're we're yeah we're you're genji yeah i'm
gonna set a contract just i've been i've been waiting Evan
wanted to say that.
They're a bastion, yeah.
I need he- oh, we both need shields.
Oh, he's like right there.
It's gonna go this way.
Where are the shields?
I'm gonna pick mercy.
Oh, there it is.
What does a Chaos Cube do?
I don't know, I think it's just a collectathon thing.
Oh, hey.
Oh my god, it's the basketball!
Round two?
Round two golees?
I'm not picking up that fucking sword.
You coward.
You fucking coward.
I'm not a coward.
You're a coward.
I know, it sounds like what a coward would say.
Yeah, I can't believe you- What would Genji think?
What would Genji say if he knows you're giving up the sword
life?
What would he say?
Genji would say...
There's like a one of them is here.
Time to go 80.
My da, my da.
Oh, I hear, oh, I'm on me, on me, on me.
I hear it.
Oh, here.
Hey, guys.
There we go.
They're all dead.
What happened?
Um, I might have ulted.
Maybe.
me might have voted i got a little taste of the uh
tentavirus whoa yeah i was on a cruise earlier and then i
flew back home instantly you went to the northern line yeah
press yeah i went to the northern line cruise yeah yeah they
said it was canceled but like only the real gamers got the
invite it got canceled so quick was so was it like actually
real or yeah it was real i think it was like because like
people it was real yeah i think people were just like safety
concerns a terrible idea like it like being trapped because
like people were like making plans on like doing like you
know crazy shit on the northern lion cruise so they got
canceled for like safety reasons did i heard that i heard
that you could find a level of your life at the northern
lion he didn't want he didn't want people to find happiness
that ain't the northern lion way.
It is so sad.
I'll see a bush.
I'm going to rock it.
You rock that bush.
I'll grab this.
Thank you.
There's some sodas here.
I read that Northern Lion just really loves cruises.
So he was like, this is he's like, this is my dream sponsor.
I think it comes with being bald.
Like, once you go bald, you just really want to go on
cruises.
How do you know that?
You know Mr. Cow?
Oh, wait, oh, wait, is he?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we would play...
Bedford's bald, so like, he's a...
Wait, is he a cruise enjoyer?
Bro, that guy, yes.
I've never been on a cruise, but YouTube will not stop
recommending me cruise videos.
I was gonna be on a cruise, but then, like...
I had to cancel.
I don't like the idea of being on a ship for, like, a week.
Anything can happen.
Did you know how the hanta virus basically it started
because some guy was birdwashing in a garbage dump?
Yeah, why were they at the garbage dump?
It's because they were birdwashing.
Birdwashing would do anything for the birds.
But there's like birds everywhere.
That's where...
Yeah, but it's a rare speckled sparrow bird though.
It only comes like what... Oh wait, in front of me?
All I'm saying is if I wanted to see a bird, I'd go to
youtube.com forward slash dokeybird.
Where's the last guy?
I don't know.
I just nerded those guys, though.
Oh, hey, you can fish here.
Yeah, we nerded these bots.
Nah, they were totally real people.
Yeah, I'm so so humble.
I still have not found the tracer gun yet.
Wait, am I drowning?
Wait, kid.
Oh.
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna get fall damage there.
I didn't panic.
You panicked.
And my drowning?
Damn.
That was full on fear.
Fear?
No.
I don't have fear.
I never feared anything in my life.
Wait, what the fuck?
He's up here.
He's fired.
Well, you got him?
Oh, they were just, I literally just got on top of them.
I'm reloading very slowly, but he's dead now.
Yeah, that was a real person.
Yeah.
Dang, that was crazy.
That was crazy.
I got real guys.
Oh my god, there it is.
Wait, there's a person behind you.
Oh, shit.
There was a person behind me.
Yeah.
What is this?
Oh, that's the snipe.
That's why I got snipe.
This is the first time I've seen this gun.
Yo, Pia, drink this one.
Yum.
I'm going to grab the...
I'm going to grab another contract.
Alright, there's another guy.
I'm telling you, bro, ever since we started playing with
Pia, we've been getting contracts non-stop.
Oh my god, you're so right.
Oh, shit, staff.
Yeah.
grabbing the staff it's beautiful there is a team around
here i got a contract oh thank you no problem dang dang i
feel so supported right now this is all i'm good for is
holding mouse one bro it's just what you're born to do it's
your calling accept who you are oh i see them they're right
here we're on our way oh oh i get it dang yeah i just led my
shot there wait there's another staff if anyone wants it
oh eliminate a taco cat if anyone wants it there is a taco
cat backwards is taco cat Oh my god, wait, really?
Wait, there's someone in front of me.
Wait, there's someone behind us.
Wait, what?
I just saw a sound ping from behind.
I saw a sound ping in front.
Oh, I see you.
You're right here.
I'm...
Really right...
I don't know who to listen to.
Wait, what am I saying?
I, Jill, where do you want me to shoot?
What the?
Oh, they're not real.
These guys aren't real.
I'm not real, apparently.
apparently when I whiffed all those shots.
There we go.
I will say shooting down is a lot harder than it looks,
guys.
Dookie, do you hold your breath when you like shoot?
Oh yeah.
Like you aim?
Oh yeah, for the immersion?
Yeah.
I actually exhale before I shoot, you know, like in...
Yeah, like in Demon Slayer.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you can have like this.
special effects go off yeah you're really sweaty do you like
bite your lip i don't get sweaty i mouth breathe when i
shoot my gun i don't get sweaty because i cry so much oh
there's another contract he started warning 1496 what
happened on 1496.
is that the bite of 1496 where could it be they be maybe
behind us maybe they're a bush and they're just holding
still you know oh that's true never trust any bushes never
trust a bush i learned that in college i learned that yeah
you went to college you actually got admitted yeah yeah they
uh you know even even
needs people oh my god university yeah it's like a it's like
a real college for mcdonald's oh it's like i want to go to
clout college coney island i'm gonna grab them in clout
college yeah what would you learn to be a clown yeah how to
down the clown you know you could just like do that for free
on twitch.tv so yeah but you don't know if you're getting
better at it you know ah but like you get it you get a
certificate you know yeah you can be an official clown Dang,
that's so true.
You need to be certified, a certified clown.
It's this way.
I could finally make my parents proud.
I want to be a battery.
Yeah, what's stopping you?
Yeah, yeah, what's stopping you?
Connected.
We're free from Education Connection.
Wasn't that just like a trade school?
What was that?
I have no idea.
The song was such a banger, though.
I mean, it works.
You're thinking about it still today.
That's true.
Fuck.
Wait, I mean...
I think your age is showing just a little bit.
No!
Do you hear that?
Where is it coming from?
Dude, I don't know.
Hold on, let me put my ear to the floor.
Oh, they're in the tunnels!
They're in the tunnels!
Secret tunnel!
I lied!
Oh, a bush.
Wait, where is that?
wait there's so many shots coming from around us wait what
is it above wait golly are they with you oh you what got
them thank you all right well it was another yeah but
there's more shots oh here i see them they're like here
oh that's real that guy's a real he got shot at and then
instantly ran Yeah, bugs have no reaction.
Um, guys?
I don't know what I do.
Guys, I'm so freaking scared.
It's okay, I'll hold your hand.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
I could always count on her IGL.
Jesus.
Um, guys.
Oh.
Wait, there's a race behind us.
There's a race behind us, Gully.
Oh, shit.
Bugs is dead.
oh wait i have to leave i have to leave golly there's people
around us there's people all around us hold on hold on i'm
raising pier okay i'm slurming oh they're blowing up the
building they're blowing up the building okay okay okay okay
okay there's a team right here too golly so we gotta leave
we got bucket yeah we gotta go all right i'm gonna i'm
bouncing i'm out of here me too i'm out of here uh here run
i'm running we gotta go to the zone we gotta go from here
thank you i owe you my life all right it's all right they
eliminate each other
Thank you.
No freaking problem.
Thanks, Mercy.
Dude, this is all I am.
It's just a mouse one freaking...
Oh.
What's it like?
It's freaking awful.
Oh my god.
I deserve the fucking...
I think someone just runs.
No, it's the rift.
They like went up.
They went to reposition on the rift.
What?
sniper bullets?
Oh, I do.
I do.
How do I?
Let me hold that.
Oh, I, oh, drop here.
I dropped it.
Wait, is it heavy bullets?
Sniper bullets?
It's the one that's a one bullet.
That's the one bullet is a sniper.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it is.
Here we go.
I've got some.
Yeah, but I hear gunshots like this way.
Oh, I see them.
Oh.
I see them like literally right here.
And there's people here.
I'm just gonna reload.
You actually have to lead your shots.
What the fuck?
23.
Oh.
Oh, you didn't, you did not.
You did not use your glider there.
Yeah, I'm gonna drop you a chug jug.
Just in case.
I tried to use my glider and it um so i'm holding it it
seems it's okay it's okay it happens that's freaking orange
yeah half is the best of us
there's one so you know you can run it good i didn't run in
uh there's more you can do a lot of things while you're
drinking there's more drinks here i don't
know where they are i have pizza too I don't think we need a
pizza yet.
I'm not even going to go to this house.
I want to feel safe.
Endorse.
See, we can't get sniped if we're inside.
There's also heals here.
You need it.
Oh, there's loot.
Wait, actually, I'm going to refill that.
Not now, SpongeBob.
He's going.
Yeah!
I see him.
Oh, wait.
That number.
That's an NPC.
I see them.
Oh my god.
This is a...
How did I not like fully...
There's a Fiona down here too.
Yeah, I'm on the heal.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Can you raise her?
I got it.
We're not in the open.
Not in the open.
Oh shit.
Oh I believe.
here yeah they are oh wait what though what though what even
just happened i don't know but i'm i'm healing i'm healing
good good luck everybody you're on your own oh no
they fully rushed us that's crazy no i got my freaking head
knocked off yeah i didn't get a shot in i think i fell
through the floor i don't know what happened i suddenly was
in a different location.
Hello, Spongebob.
We got freaking blown up.
Someone had a physique.
Hello.
Oh, I hear them fighting.
I can't wait for Spongebob to give away your position.
Stop!
He's gonna go, like, run out there and, like, run back.
He's gonna go out there and wave his little finger, like,
come here.
Yeah, she's over here, guys.
She's over here.
Yeah!
I don't even know if it's worth fighting what do you mean
it's only seven people there's two squads and then you is it
okay i'm gonna wait for a knock then oh that's two oh you
saw the heal nice jola nice shot oh she picked up my sword
what oh she's scared oh my god i can't dash when I'm inside
no I can't dash when I'm inside where's the oh the other guy
must be a solo the other the other guy must be a solo I
think but there were seven people left I don't know where
the other guy went but I fucking styled on the Fiona though
I just got you did I styled on him he tried what is it act
no it is it's a solo so like i needed the other solo to play
with me but then he like fucking bailed like a oh ggs though
ggs freaking ggs ggs guys good games we got so many victory
royales we did many many victory yeah they're talking about
us in tomato Yeah, they're like, I hope they don't.
I'm so scared.
Oh my God.
It's like, it's like our squad.
They'll remember our squad for generations.
Are we making headlines and tomato town?
Yeah.
We're going to be on the, we're going to be on the next
newsletter, the Fortnite newsletter.
It's like be warned.
Oh my God.
GG's everybody.
If you ever want, if you ever want my support, I'm always
open.
i'm always down i'm so tired now but thank you everybody
thank you guys for the games thanks gully for dropping by
nice to meet you nice to meet you too igl thanks pia for
joining us bye bye guys bye bye oh my god i did not expect
to play fortnite that long but it was so fun bro i was So I
felt like I was like gaming with the I was looking gaming
with the tracer guns.
Oh my god, but I was like hitting so many shots.
I was so proud of myself with the track.
I just kept getting better and better at tracking with the
tracer guns too.
Yeah.
I was just like it was the adrenaline rush of just hitting
my shots.
I love I love the gunplay.
Yeah, I love the gunplay.
with the new guns.
Just because like I love tracking in general.
So it just hits that like it just hits that serotonin for
me.
The dopamine.
Anyway guys, thank you all for watching.
It was supposed to be a short stream.
I was like it was gonna be two to three hours stream.
But then I just kept playing.
I just kept playing and playing and playing.
And I just want to play more.
I just love.
I don't know.
It's just something about those the new guns.
It just feels so good compared to the other Fortnite
updates.
Like, all the guns for this update, just all of them feel so
fucking good.
I was just fucking bam, bam, bam.
Like, I could just use all of them, too.
Oh, anyway, guys, I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you step for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye, you showed it, Gully, and Pia for playing with me.
Bye, everybody.
Bye, bye.
I really did think I had so much energy today.
I but I don't know the fortnight adrenaline really did hit
me anyways.
Bye.
Bye